hey everyone i welcome you all to this
aws crash course by simplylearn in this
crash course we will learn about aws its
features and different services in great
detail and help you become the master of
amazon web services in less than six
hours i'm raul and i have with me samuel
and akil who will take you through the
various topics in aws all the way from
creating an account on aws your first
instance working with ec2 s3 iam route
53 and other services with various
practical examples and ending it with
interview questions that help you crack
the aws certified solutions architect
certification in one go
and all of this in under 6 hours
so without further ado
let's get started
but before we begin make sure you
subscribe to our youtube channel and
don't forget to click on the bell icon
so that you never miss an update from
simply learn
hi there i'm samuel a multiplatform
cloud architect and i'm very excited and
honored to walk you through this
learning series about aws let me start
the session with this scenario let's
imagine how life would have been without
spotify for those who are hearing about
spotify for the first time spotify is an
online music service offering and it
offers instant access to over 16 million
licensed songs spotify now uses aws
cloud to store the data and share it
with their customers but prior to aws
they had some issues imagine using
spotify before aws let's talk about that
back then users were often getting
errors because spotify could not keep up
with the increased demand for storage
every new day and that led to users
getting upset and users cancelling the
subscription the problem spotify was
facing at that time was their users were
present globally and were accessing it
from everywhere and they had different
latency in their applications and
spotify had a demanding situation where
they need to frequently catalog the
songs released yesterday today and in
the future and this was changing every
new day and the songs coming in rate was
about 20 000 a day and back then they
could not keep up with this requirement
and needless to say they were badly
looking for a way to solve this problem
and that's when they got introduced to
aws and it was a perfect fit and match
for their problem aws offered at
dynamically increasing storage and
that's what they needed aws also offered
tools and techniques like storage
lifecycle management and trusted advisor
to properly utilize the resource so we
always get the best out of the resource
used aws addressed their concerns about
easily being able to scale yes you can
scale the aws environment very easily
how easily one might ask it's just a few
button clicks and aws solved spotify's
problem let's talk about how it can help
you with your organization's problem
let's talk about what is aws first and
then let's bleed into how aws became so
successful and the different types of
services that aws provides and what's
the future of cloud and aws in specific
let's talk about that and finally we'll
talk about a use case where you will see
how easy it is to create a web
application with aws all right let's
talk about what is aws aws or amazon web
services is a secure cloud service
platform it is also pay as you go type
billing model where there is no upfront
or capital cost we'll talk about how
soon the service will be available well
the service will be available in a
matter of seconds with aws you can also
do identity and access management that
is authenticating and authorizing a user
or a program on the fly and almost all
the services are available on demand and
most of them are available
instantaneously and as we speak amazon
offers 100 plus services and this list
is growing every new week now that would
make you wonder how aws became so
successful of course it's their
customers let's talk about the list of
well-known companies that has their idea
environment in aws adobe adobe uses aws
to provide multi-terabyte operating
environments for its customers by
integrating its system with aws cloud
adobe can focus on deploying and
operating its own software instead of
trying to you know deploy and manage the
infrastructure airbnb is another company
it's an community marketplace that
allows property owners and travelers to
connect each other for the purpose of
renting unique vacation spaces around
the world and the airbnb community users
activities are conducted on the website
and through iphones and android
applications airbnb has a huge
infrastructure in aws and they're almost
using all the services in aws and are
getting benefited from it another
example would be autodesk autodesk
develops software for engineering
designing and entertainment industries
using services like amazon rds or
rational database servers and amazon s3
or amazon simple storage servers
autodesk can focus on deploying or
developing its machine learning tools
instead of spending that time on
managing the infrastructure aol or
american online uses aws and using aws
they have been able to close data
centers and decommission about 14 000
in-house and co-located servers and move
mission critical workload to the cloud
and extend its global reach and save
millions of dollars on energy resources
bitdefender is an internet security
software firm and their portfolio of
softwares include antivirus and
anti-spyware products bitdefender uses
ec2 and they're currently running few
hundred instances that handle about five
terabytes of data and they also use
elastic load balancer to load balance
the connection coming in to those
instances across availability zones and
they provide seamless global delivery of
servers because of that the bmw group it
uses aws for its new connected car
application that collects sensor data
from bmw 7 series cars to give drivers
dynamically updated map information
canon's office imaging products division
benefits from faster deployment times
lower cost and global reach by using aws
to deliver cloud-based services such as
mobile print the office imaging products
division uses aws such as amazon s3 and
amazon route 53 amazon cloudfront and
amazon im for their testing development
and production services comcast it's the
world's largest cable company and the
leading provider of internet service in
the united states comcast uses aws in a
hybrid environment out of all the other
cloud providers comcast chose aws for
its flexibility and scalable hybrid
infrastructure docker is a company
that's helping redefine the way
developers build ship and run
applications this company focuses on
making use of containers for this
purpose and in aws the service called
the amazon ec2 container service is
helping them achieve it the esa or
european space agency although much of
esa's work is done by satellites some of
the programs data storage and computing
infrastructure is built on amazon web
services esa chose aws because of its
economical pay as ego system as well as
its quick startup time the guardian
newspaper uses aws and it uses a wide
range of aws services including amazon
kinesis amazon redshift that power an
analytic dashboard which editors used to
see how stories are trending in real
time financial times ft is one of the
world's largest leading business news
organization and they used amazon
redshift to perform their analysis a
funny thing happened amazon redshirt
performed so quickly that some analysis
thought it was malfunctioning they were
used to running queries overnight and
they found that the results were indeed
correct just as much faster by using
amazon redshift fd is supporting the
same business functions with costs that
are 80 percentage lower than what was
before general electric ge is at the
moment as we speak migrating more than
9000 workloads including 300 desperate
erp systems to aws while reducing its
data center footprint from 34 to 4 over
the next three years similarly howard
medical school htc imdb mcdonald's nasa
kellogg's and lot more are using the
services amazon provides and are getting
benefited from it and this huge success
and customer portfolio is just the tip
of the iceberg and if we think why so
many adapt aws and if we let aws answer
that question this is what aws would say
people are adapting aws because of the
security and durability of the data and
end-to-end privacy and encryption of the
data and storage experience we can also
rely on aws way of doing things by using
the aws tools and techniques and
suggested best practices built upon the
years of experience it has gained
flexibility there is a greater
flexibility in aws that allows us to
select the os language and database easy
to use swiftness in deploying we can
host our applications quickly in aws
beat a new application or migrating an
existing application into aws
scalability the application can be
easily scaled up or scaled down
depending on the user requirement cost
saving we only pay for the compute power
storage and other resources you use and
that too without any long-term
commitments now let's talk about the
different types of services that aws
provides the services that we talk about
fall in any of the following categories
you see like you know compute storage
database security customer engagement
desktop and streaming machine learning
developers tools stuff like that and if
you do not see the service that you're
looking for it's probably is because aws
is creating it as we speak now let's
look at some of them that are very
commonly used within computer services
we have amazon ec2 amazon elastic bean
stock amazon light sale and amazon
lambda amazon ec2 provides compute
capacity in the cloud now this capacity
is secure and it is resizable based on
the user's requirement now look at this
the requirement for the web traffic
keeps changing and behind the scenes in
the cloud ec2 can expand its environment
to three instances and during no load it
can shrink its environment to just one
resource elastic beanstalk it helps us
to scale and deploy web applications and
it's made with a number of programming
languages elastic beanstalk is also an
easy to use service for deploying and
scaling web applications and services
deployed a bit in java.net php nodejs
python ruby docker and lot other
familiar services such as apache
passenger and iis we can simply upload
our code and elastic beanstalk
automatically handles the deployment
from capacity provisioning to load
balancing to auto scaling to application
health monitoring and amazon lightsail
is a virtual private server which is
easy to launch and easy to manage amazon
lightsail is the easiest way to get
started with aws for developers who just
need a virtual private server lightsail
includes everything you need to launch
your project quickly on a virtual
machine like ssd based storage a virtual
machine tools for data transfer dns
management and a static ip and that too
for a very low and predictable price aws
lambda has taken cloud computing
services to a whole new level it allows
us to pay only for the compute time no
need for provisioning and managing
servers and aws lambda is a compute
service that lets us run code without
provisioning or managing servers lambda
executes your code only when needed and
scales automatically from few requests
per day to thousands per second you pay
only for the compute time you consume
there is no charge when your code is not
running let's look at some storage
services that amazon provides like
amazon s3 amazon glacier amazon abs and
amazon elastic file system amazon s3 is
an object storage that can store and
retrieve data from anywhere websites
mobile apps iot sensors and so on can
easily use amazon s3 to store and
retrieve data it's an object storage
built to store and retry any amount of
data from anywhere with its features
like flexibility in managing data and
the durability it provides and the
security that it provides amazon simple
storage service or s3 is a storage for
the internet and glacier glacier is a
cloud storage service that's used for
archiving data and long-term backups and
this glacier is an secure durable and
extremely low-cost cloud storage service
for data archiving and long-term backups
amazon ebs amazon elastic block store
provides block store volumes for the
instances of ec2 and this elastic block
store is highly available and a reliable
storage volume that can be attached to
any running instance that is in the same
availability zone abs volumes that are
attached to the ec2 instances are
exposed as storage volumes that
persistent independently from the
lifetime of the instance an amazon
elastic file system or efs provides an
elastic file storage which can be used
with aws cloud service and resources
that are on premises an amazon elastic
file system it's an simple it's scalable
it's an elastic file storage for use
with amazon cloud services and for
on-premises resources it's easy to use
and offers a simple interface that
allows you to create and configure file
systems quickly and easily amazon file
system is built to elastically scale on
demand without disturbing the
application growing and shrinking
automatically as you add and remove
files your application have the storage
they need and when they need it now
let's talk about databases the two major
database flavors are amazon rds and
amazon redshift amazon rds it really
eases the process involved in setting up
operating and scaling a relational
database in the cloud amazon rds
provides cost efficient and resizable
capacity while automating time consuming
administrative tasks such as hardware
provisioning database setup patching and
backups it sort of frees us from
managing the hardware and sort of helps
us to focus on the application it's also
cost effective and resizable and it's
also optimized for memory performance
and input and output operations not only
that it also automates most of the
services like taking backups you know
monitoring stuff like that it automates
most of those services amazon redshift
amazon redshift is a data warehousing
service that enables users to analyze
the data using sql and other business
intelligent tools amazon reshift is an
fast and fully managed data warehouse
that makes it simple and cost effective
analyze all your data using standard sql
and your existing business intelligent
tools it also allows you to run complex
analytic queries against petabyte of
structured data using sophisticated
query optimizations and most of the
results they generally come back in
seconds all right let's quickly talk
about some more services that aws offers
there are a lot more services that aws
provides but are we going to look at
some more services that are widely used
aws application discovery services help
enterprise customers plan migration
projects by gathering information about
their on-premises data centers and a
planning a data center migration can
involve thousands of workloads they are
often deeply interdependent server
utilization data and dependency mapping
are important early first step in
migration process and this aws
application discovery service collects
and presents configuration usage and
behavior data from your servers to help
you better understand your workloads
route 53 it's a network and content
delivery service it's an highly
available and scalable cloud domain name
system or dns service and amazon route
53 is fully compliant with ipv6 as well
elastic load balancing it's also a
network and content delivery service
elastic load balancing automatically
distributes incoming application traffic
across multiple targets such as amazon
ec2 instance containers and ip addresses
it can handle the varying load of your
application traffic in a single
available zones and also across
availability zones away auto scaling it
monitors your application and
automatically adjusts the capacity to
maintain steady and predictable
performance at a lowest possible cost
using aws auto scaling it's easy to set
up application scaling for multiple
resources across multiple services in
minutes auto scaling can be applied to
web services and also for db services
aws identity and access management it
enables you to manage access to aws
services and resources securely using im
you can create and manage aws users and
groups and use permissions to allow and
deny their access to aws resources and
moreover it's a free service now let's
talk about the future of aws well let me
tell you something cloud is here to stay
here's what in store for aws in the
future as years pass by we're gonna have
a variety of cloud applications born
like iot artificial intelligence
business intelligence serverless
computing and so on cloud will also
expand into other markets like
healthcare banking space automated cars
and so on as i was mentioning some time
back a lot or greater focus will be
given to artificial intelligence and
eventually because of the flexibility
and advantage that cloud provides we're
going to see a lot of companies moving
into the cloud all right let's now talk
about how easy it is to deploy and web
application in the cloud so the scenario
here is that our users like a product
and we need to have a mechanism to
receive input from them about their
likes and dislikes and you know give
them the appropriate product as per
their need all right though the setup
and the environment it sort of looks
complicated we don't have to worry
because aws has tools and technologies
which can help us to achieve it now
we're going to use services like route
53 services like cloud watch ec2 s3 and
lot more and all these put together are
going to give an application that's
fully functionable and an application
that's going to receive the information
like using the services like route 53
cloudwatch ec2 and s3 we're going to
create an application and that's going
to meet our need so back to our original
requirement all i want is to deploy a
web application for a product that keeps
our users updated about the happenings
and the new comings in the market and to
fulfill this requirement here is all the
services we would need ec2 here is used
for provisioning the computational power
needed for this application and ec2 has
a vast variety of family and types that
we can pick from for the types of
workloads and also for the intents of
the workloads we're also going to use s3
for storage and s3 provides any
additional storage requirement for the
resources or any additional storage
requirement for the web applications and
we are also going to use cloudwatch for
monitoring the environment and
cloudwatch monitors the application and
the environment and it provides trigger
for scaling in and scaling out the
infrastructure and we're also going to
use route 53 for dns and route 53 helps
us to register the domain name for our
web application and with all the tools
and technologies together all of them
put together we're going to make an
application a perfect application that
caters our need all right so i'm going
to use elastic beanstalk for this
project and the name of the application
is going to be as you see gsg sign up
and the environment name is gsg signup
environment 1. let me also pick a name
let me see if this name is available yes
that's available that's the domain name
so let me pick that and the application
that i have is going to run on node.js
so let me pick that platform and launch
now as you see elastic bean stock this
is going to launch an instance it's
going to launch the monitoring setup or
the monitoring environment it's going to
create a load balancer as well and it's
going to take care of all the security
features needed for this application
alright look at that i was able to go to
that url which is what we gave and it's
now having an default page shown up
meaning all the dependencies for the
software is installed and it's just
waiting for me to upload the code or in
specific the page required so let's do
that
let me upload the code i already have
the code saved here
that's my code
and that's going to take some time all
right it has done its thing and now if i
go to the same url look at that i'm
being thrown an advertisement page all
right so if i sign up with my name email
and stuff like that you know it's going
to receive the information and it's
going to send an email to the owner
saying that somebody had subscribed to
your service that's the default feature
of this app look at that email to the
owner saying that somebody had
subscribed to your app and this is their
email address stuff like that not only
that it's also going to create an entry
in the database and dynamodb is the
service that this application uses to
store data there's my dynamodb and if i
go to tables
right and go to items i'm going to see
that a user with named samuel and email
address so and so has said okay or has
shown interest in the preview of my site
or product so this is where this is how
i collect those information right and
some more things about the
infrastructure itself is
it is running behind an load balancer
look at that it had created a load
balancer it had also created an auto
scaling group now that's the feature of
elastic load balancer that we have
chosen it has created an auto scaling
group and now let's put this url you see
this it's it's not a fancy url right
it's an amazon given url a dynamic url
so let's put this url behind our dns
let's do that
so go to services go to route 53
go to hosted zone and there we can find
the
dns name right so that's a dns name all
right
all right let's create an entry and map
that url
to our load balancer right
and create now technically if i
go to this url it should take me
to that application all right look at
that i went to my custom url and now
that's pointed to my application
previously my application was having a
random url and now it's having a custom
url now let's move to the next level of
discussion let's talk about what is ec2
and some of the use cases of ec2 and
this use case we're going to talk about
are this architecture we're going to
talk about it notifies a group of users
about a new letter and the components or
resources this architecture would need
the first ec2 instance then sns a simple
notification service and
coupling ec2 and s3 service together
that's all it would require to get an
architecture that notifies a group of
users about a new newsletter and now i
think it would be a good time to talk
about what ec2 is aws offers plenty of
services offered under different domains
like you know compute storage database
migration network management tools media
services security business productivity
application integration machine learning
game development and lot more coming up
out of which ec2 falls under the compute
capacity so what is ec2 ec2 is a web
service which aims to make life easier
for developers for providing secure and
recessable compute capacity in the cloud
with ec2 it is very easy to scale up or
scale down our infrastructure based on
the demand and not only that this ec2
service can be integrated well with
almost all the services in amazon and
out of all this the best part could be
we only pay for what we use all right
let's talk about this use case a use
case here is that a successful business
owner has a bunch of users and a
successful product that's running and
now he has developed few more products
that he thinks will be very successful
that he thinks his customers are going
to like now how can he advertise his
product to his new and prospective
customers or the solution for this
question can be addressed by aws in aws
we can use services like simple
notification service sns and ec2 for
compute and s3 for storage we can in a
way integrate them all and achieve this
business use case and that sort of got
this business owner very cheered up and
now he wants to use the service and he
wants to get benefited from the service
he wants to advertise or he wants to
notify his users every time the company
creates a newsletter all right so let's
talk about what it would take to get
this environment up and running or what
it would take to connect the environment
and put the applications on top of it
firstly we would require an aws account
and then for compute capacity we would
require an ec2 instance and here's how
we go about doing it the first thing is
to create an ami which is amazon mission
image that's really the softwares and
the application packages we would need
to run our application and the second is
to choose the hardware in here it's the
instance type depending on the workload
we would be choosing the hardware and
depending on the intents of the workload
we will be choosing the size of the
hardware and finally we would configure
the instances and how many instances do
i want you know which subnet do i want
them in and what's going to be the
stop or terminate a behavior of the
instance and do i want to update any
patches when the instance starts running
all those pieces of information go in
here when we configure the instance
and then the first three steps is really
about the os volume and the basic
hardware now it's time to add additional
storage to the ec2 instance that would
be step four here we add additional
storage to the ec2 instance and then
tags we use tags or we would configure
tags to easily identify an ec2 instance
at a later point you know we give it
some meaningful names so we can identify
like you know which team it belongs to
which billing department it belongs to
what's the purpose behind launching this
instance stuff like that in an
environment where we run 700 to 800 or
even more instances identifying an
instance and trying to understand you
know who owns the resource for what
purpose we created it could be an
full-time work so tagging comes to a
rescue at that time after tagging as
step 6 we would configure the firewall
which is also called security group for
the ec2 instance and this is where we
would allow or deny connection from
external world to this particular ec2
instance well it works both ways from
outside and from inside out this
firewall blocks the connection based on
port number and ip address and finally
as step 7 we review all the
configurations that you have done and we
make sure that the configurations is
what we wanted and finally click on
summit that's going to launch an ec2
instance all right this was just an
overview of how to create an ec2
instance now let's talk about each and
every step in detail so to begin with
let's talk about how to create an ami
well the ami is just a template a
template that's used to create a new
instance or an a new computer or a new
vm or a new machine based on the user
requirement the things that go into an
ami are the software the operating
system the additional applications that
get installed in it stuff like that the
ami will also contain software
information you know information about
operating system information about
access permission information about
volumes they all compact in the ami
again the ami is of two types one is
predefined amis are called amazon
provided amis the other one would be
custom amis the amis that we create and
if you're looking at a particular ami
that you don't want to create but still
want to get it from amazon there is a
place or a portal called ami marketplace
there we get like thousands of amis in
there available for us to shop and use
them on a pay as you go business model
and use them as pay as you go billing so
there you can search ami that you're
looking for most probably you'll be able
to get it there now let's talk about
choosing the instance type the instance
type is basically the hardware
specification that's required for a
machine that we're trying to build and
the instant types is categorized into
five main families they are to begin
with it's compute optimized now compute
optimize gives us lots of compute power
or lots of processing power so if my
application is going to require a lot of
processing power i should be picking
compute optimized instance and the
second one is memory optimized now this
is very good for application that
require in-memory caching you know there
are some application that performs well
with cache or through cache or the
application would create a lot of data
that it wants to keep in cache for
or for processing you know for lengthy
processing stuff like that for those
type of application this memory
optimized instance that comes with in
memory cache is a very good use case and
the third one is the instant that comes
with the gpu otherwise called gpu
optimized gpu stands for graphical
process unit and this is very good for
application that deals with gaming this
is very good for application that's
going to require large graphical
requirements and storage optimize is the
fourth option just like the name says
this is a very good use case for storage
servers and the fifth family type is
general purpose just like the name says
it's for general purpose if you're not
particular about the family then you
generally would end up picking the
general purpose because here the
services are sort of equally balanced
you know you'll find a balance between
the virtual cpu and the memory and the
storage and the network performance it's
sort of balanced all the components all
the features that needs to go in a
computer are sort of balanced in general
purpose now these instant types are
fixed and they cannot be altered because
it's hardware based we buy hardware we
do not have much control on the hardware
that's being used well we have options
but we do not have control on the
hardware and these instant types are
divided into five main families they are
compute optimized memory optimized gpu
enabled storage optimized and general
purpose then as third thing we have to
configure the instance now here is where
i have a lot of options about
purchasing you know what type of
purchasing do i want to do do i want to
go for a spot instance do i want to go
for a reserved instance do i want to go
for an on-demand instance these are
different billing options available and
that's available under configure
instance not only that here's where i'm
going to put the ec2 instance do i want
and public ipads assigned to it do i
want an iam role attached to it im role
is authentication what kind of
authentication am i going to provide and
the shutdown behavior the shutdown
behaviors include do i want to stop the
instance when the user shuts down the
machine from the desktop or do i want to
simply terminate the instance when the
user shuts down the instance from the
desktop so those things going here just
like the name says configure instance a
lot of instance configuration options
comes in here that's the third step and
not only that under the advanced details
or advanced tab under configure instance
i can bootstrap the instance with some
scripts now bootstrap is nothing but the
scripts that you want to be run in the
instance before it actually comes online
let's say you're provisioning the
instance for somebody else you know
instead of you launching the instance
and then logging in and running some
commands and then handing it over to the
other person you can create bootstrap
shell scripts and you know paste it in a
console option available under configure
instance and amazon is going to take
those commands run it on the instance
before it hands over to the user that
initially requested for that instance
now it could be a different user or just
you it sort of automates you know
software installation procedures in the
instance that we will be launching and
not only that there are multiple payment
options available under configure
instance the user can pick an instance
under normal price and that instance
would apply normal rates applied to it
and there are also options like reserved
instance where the user can pay for an
instance upfront before a year or before
months you know for a span of year or a
span of months and that way they can pay
less per hour for using that instance
not only that you can also go for spot
instance like bidding for those
instances whoever bids more they get the
instance for that particular time well
these instances are a lot cheaper than
on-demand instances and through bidding
and buying you can keep the instance as
long as your bid price doesn't exceed
the price that amazon is proposing and
as the fourth step we will have to add
storage to the instance that we are
about to launch and here we have bunch
of storage options i can go for a
permeable storage which is free or i can
go for an external elastic block storage
also called ebs which is paid and it's a
permanent storage or else i can
integrate my ec2 instance with s3 for
its storage needs and the best part
about storage is free subscription users
they get to use 30 gigabit of ssd
storage or magnetic storage for the
whole year in this page where we are
ready to add storage we will have to
mention or provide the size in gigabit
and the volume type is it going to be an
uh provisioned volume is it going to be
an general purpose volume is it going to
be a magnetic volume stuff like that
they are volume types and we also need
to give inputs about where the disk will
be mounted and whether this volume needs
to be encrypted or not so all these
options are all these inputs are
received from us under the adding
storage section and then the fifth
option would be adding tags like we
discussed some time back tags are very
helpful to identify a machine in an
environment where we have 700 or 1000
vms running and security groups are the
actual firewall that sits in front of
ec2 instance and it protects that ec2
instance from unintended inbound and
outbound traffic now here is where i can
fine tune the access to my ec2 instance
based on port numbers and based on ip
address from which it can be accessed
and finally we get to review the whole
changes or the whole configurations that
we have made to find out whether they
are intact with the requirement and then
click on submit that's going to launch
an ec2 instance but hold on we're not
done yet when we're about to launch or
before the amazon console actually
launches the ec2 instance it's going to
give us an option to create a keypad
remember i said it's key pair you know
key pair is two things one is public and
private the private key is downloaded by
the user and is kept with the user and
the public key is used by amazon to
confirm the identity of the user so just
go ahead and download the private key
and keep it for yourself and this
private key gets downloaded as a dot pem
file it's a format of the file and it
gets downloaded as dot pem file and our
next step is to access the ec2 instance
and because the instance that we have
launched in this example let's assume
it's linux instance and that's going to
require a tool called putty to be able
to access it and this putty tool is
really needed when we're trying to
access and linux instance from windows
instance most of the time windows
instance will have putty installed in
them but in some rare cases they do not
come with putty in those cases we can go
ahead and download putty and put the
generator and we can start using it to
access the linux instance now you might
ask well i understand putty what's putty
generator now the file that we have
downloaded is in dot pem format but
unfortunately putty does not accept dot
pem format as input you know it has to
be converted into a different format
called ppk and puttygen is a tool that
helps us to convert the dot pem file
into ppk file so the quick way to do it
is download generator open it up click
on conversion and insert the dot pen key
that we have downloaded and save the
private key and this when we save the
private key it gets saved as a dot ppk
type private key and when that's done
the next very step is to open puti and
try to log in and the way to log in is
to open putty put that ip address here
and then click on auth
you know this is where we would input
the file that we have created so click
on op and then click on browse and find
the dot ppk file that we have converted
and stored browse it and upload it and
then click on open now that's going to
open up a login screen for us and the
amis comes with a default username
depending on the ami that we have picked
the username might differ in our case we
have picked an ami for which the
username is ec2 hyphen user and this is
the default by the way let's put the
username ec2hyphen user and hit enter
and that's going to open up the linux
instance using cli there are a few other
things that we can do with the terminal
that will explain it a little later
alright so we have successfully launched
an ec2 instance and
yeah give yourself a pat on your back
launching an instance was just one part
of the solution so let's actually talk
about how we can notify our customers
sns or simple notification service is a
service or a product in amazon that
helps us to notify customers through
email so navigate to sns in your account
and create a topic and we're going to
use this topic for public notification
so let's make it public and then add
subscribers to it now these subscribers
these subscribers are the people who you
want to be notified about the newsletter
so we already have the email database in
there add them to the subscribers list
and then they will start getting new
newsletters as and when we post them to
the topic and as next step create a
bucket in s3 where you can store content
and in that bucket create an event that
triggers a notification to simple
notification service so this is how it
will be set up and notification will be
sent to our subscribers anytime we put
something in our s3 bucket so s3 bucket
is going to create an event for the
notification and the notification is
going to make sure that it's delivered
to your end customer because they're
already subscribed to the topic as
subscribers and finally let's connect
the s3 with ec2 so the bucket and the
aws instance are in sync so we put some
content in the s3 bucket our email
system notifies our customers and the
customers can go online to a website
that's hosted in ec2 and because s3 and
ec2 are in sync the items that we put in
s3 will also show up in ec2 see how this
is all connected and it's working
together and once this is all connected
our subscribers will regularly be
informed anytime we put new content in
the s3 bucket and the same content will
be made available in ec2 instance
through the website now let's move to
the next level of discussion so in this
section we're going to learn about the
features of aws lambda and we're going
to talk about what lambda is and then
we're going to talk about where lambda
is being used in the it or in the cloud
environment as we speak and then we're
going to talk about how lambda works and
some use cases of lambda and we're going
to be particularly discussing about the
use case about automatically backing up
the data that's put in the cloud storage
let's talk about lambda in detail lambda
automatically runs our code without
requiring us to provision or manage
servers just write the code and upload
it to lambda and lambda will take care
of it that means that we don't require
any server to run or to manage and all
you need to do is write the code and
upload it to lambda and lambda will take
care of it which also means that we can
stop worrying about provisioning and
managing servers the only thing lambda
expects from you is a code that's
working aws lambda also automatically
scales our application by running code
in response to each trigger our code
runs in parallel and processes each
triggers individually scaling precisely
with the size of the workload scaling
here is done automatically based on the
size of the workload lambda can scale
the application running the code in
response to each and every trigger that
it receives billing in lambda is metered
on the seconds we only pay for the
amount of time that our code is running
which means that we're not charged for
any of the servers the only payment
required is for the amount of time the
code is computed with aws lambda we are
charged for every 100 milliseconds we
are actually charged for 100
milliseconds our code executes and the
number of times our code is triggered
and
we don't pay anything when the code is
not running let's talk about what is aws
lambda now lambda is one of the servers
that falls under the compute section or
the compute domain of services that aws
provides along with ec2 ebs elastic load
balancer lambda is also a service that
comes under the bigger umbrella of
compute services in aws and lambda
allows us to execute code for any type
of application with aws lambda we can
run code for virtually any type of
application or backend services all we
need to do is supply our code in one of
the languages that aws lambda supports
as we speak the languages that are
supported by aws lambda are node.js java
c-sharp go and python and lambda can be
used to run code in response to certain
events from other services and based on
the event it can run functions and those
functions can be of node.js java c sharp
etc now let's talk about where is lambda
used there are huge number of use cases
for lambda and there are many ways aws
lambda is used specifically in the
business world let's talk about some of
them one use case is aws lambda is used
to process images when it is uploaded in
an s3 bucket let's say the object gets
uploaded in an estee bucket in a format
that we don't expect it to be which
means the file needs to be formatted so
it gets uploaded in a raw format and aws
lambda is triggered anytime a new object
is added to the bucket and the images
are processed and converted into
thumbnails based on the devices the
other end device that would be reading
the data it could be an pc it could be
an apple machine it could be an android
phone it could be an apple phone it
could be a tablet what not so based on
the devices different formats lambda can
get triggered and convert the video or
convert the picture into the different
format that it requires another use case
for lambda is to analyze the social
media data let's say let's say we're
collecting the hashtag trending data and
the data is received and it's uh added
into the kinesis stream to feed into the
amazon environment and lambda action get
triggered and it receives the data and
then the data is stored into the
database which can be used by
businesses for later analysis and some
of the companies that have gotten
tremendous benefit using lambda or
thomson routers bench links
not storm coca-cola robot are some of
the companies to name at the moment that
have received tremendous amount of
benefit by using lambda let's look at
how lambda works in other words let's
look at how the complicated function
behind the scenes work in a simple and
in a seamless way so here clients send
data now clients send data to lambda and
clients could be anyone who's sending
requests to aws lambda it could be an
application or other amazon web services
that's sending data to the lambda and
lambda receives the request and
depending on the size of the data or
depending on the amount or volume of the
data it runs on the defined number of
containers if it is a single request or
if it is less request it runs on a
single container so the requests are
given to the container to handle and the
container which contains the code the
user has provided to satisfy the query
would run and if you're sort of new to
containers then let me pause here for a
while and explain to you what container
is now container image is a lightweight
standalone executable package of a piece
of software that includes everything
needs to run it like the codes the
runtimes the system tools the system
libraries and any other settings needed
and it is at the moment available both
on linux and windows based application
and containerized software will always
run the same regardless of the
environment it's running on and
containers isolate software from its
surrounding for example there could be
difference between a development and
staging environment so that's sort of
isolated and this helps in reducing the
conflict between the teams running
different software on the same
infrastructure all right now that we
know containers needed to understand
lambda so if there are few requests it
sends to a single container but as and
when the request grows it actually
creates multiple containers shares the
multiple requests to the different
containers there and depending on the
volume depending on the size depending
on the number of sessions the more
number of containers are provisioned so
to handle those requests and when the
requests reduce the number of containers
reduce as well and that helps in saving
costs we're not running any resources
and paying for it when we're not using
them and in fact we're not at all paying
for the resources we're only charged for
the amount of time a function is running
inside these containers now consider a
situation where you have to set up a
temporary storage and
as a system to backup the data as soon
as the data is uploaded which is a near
real time backup now a near real time
manual backups are nearly impossible and
they're not that efficient too and near
real-time manual backups that's what the
business demands but that's not near
real-time backup that to a manual one
that's not at all efficient even if we
come up with a solution of manually
backing up close to near real time
that's not going to be efficient looking
at the amount of data that will be put
in and looking at the random times the
data will be put into the source bucket
and there is no way we can do a manual
backup and they keep it as real as
possible but if that's still your
requirement we can use aws lambda and
set things up so aws lambda manually
handles the backup in other words for an
impossible or a difficult situation like
that aw slander comes for the rescue and
this is what we do create a 2s3 bucket
one would be the source bucket where the
data will be uploaded and the other one
is and destination bucket where the data
will be backed up from the source bucket
and for these buckets to talk to
themselves it's going to require an iem
rule and then for the automatic copy
it's going to require an lambda function
to copy the files from the source bucket
to the destination bucket and what
triggers the lambda function the lambda
function is triggered every time there's
a change in the metadata for the bucket
and this data is then uploaded into the
destination bucket and after setting all
this up we can literally test it by
putting a data in the source bucket
that's going to automatically replicate
or that's going to automatically copy
the data from the source bucket to the
destination bucket all right let's see
how we can replicate data between two
buckets well we have a feature to cross
region replicate in s3 that's a feature
that comes along with s3 what if you
want to replicate between two different
buckets in two different accounts in
those cases we can use lambda to
replicate the data between the buckets
so you put one data or you put data in
the source bucket and that data gets
replicated to the destination bucket and
let's see how that's done the procedure
here will be to have two buckets to
begin with and then create an im role
that lets you access to pull data from
the source bucket and put data on the
destination bucket and then create
lambda files or lambda event or triggers
to actually look for event in the source
bucket and anytime a new data gets added
lambda gets triggered copies the data
from the source bucket and moves the
data to the destination bucket and it
uses the iam role and policy for the
needed permissions and in just a couple
of clicks we have set up a temporary
backup system that can run seamlessly
without any manual intervention and that
can be as near real time as possible all
right that's the concept and let's see
how it is done real time through this
lab so to begin with we need two buckets
so i have here a source bucket and a
destination bucket and the source bucket
as of now do not have any data in it so
as the destination bucket all right so
that's one down the second would be to
create an im role right so let me create
an im role and the role is going to have
this policy in it a policy that's
allowing get object on the source bucket
and a policy that's allowing put object
on the destination bucket and here i'm
going to use or i'm going to paste my
source and destination buckets arn all
right go to services go to s3
source
bucket all right click on the source
bucket and copy the bucket drn
so that would be the source bucket arn
all right on on the destination bucket
copy the destination bucket arn
and this is going to be my destination
bucket arn so with this i'm going to
create a policy
all right
go to im
create a policy
now i i have already created a policy
with the same information all right
destination bucket arn and a policy is
available with the name s3 bucket copy
lambda attach the policy to the role
right go to roles create a role lambda
is the service that's going to use it in
here attach the policy that we have
created
right give it a name
and then create a role now i have a role
created as well
right copy lambda and that's having the
policy that we have created sometime
back now create a lambda function right
so go to lambda
create a function give it a name like s3
bucket copy all right choose the role
that we want to use
all right that's the role that we want
to use copy one two
create a function
all right
and in here
we're going to use node.js code right i
have a sample code
this can be used as template here
replace the source bucket with the name
of the source bucket and the destination
bucket with the name of the destination
bucket this is a node.js code that gets
run when an event get triggered now
what's an event anytime there is a new
object placed in the s3 bucket it
creates an event and the evil triggers
lambda and lambda checks the source s3
bucket picks the data puts it in the
destination bucket all right paste it
here
paste it here
and click on save
right now before you click on save just
ensure that you have the appropriate
roles defined
that's all you got to do click on save
all right now i already have created
a lambda function
all right
which is the same thing same code and
the role is attached to it
now it's running it's active now let's
put this to test go to s3
pick the source bucket
put some data in it
all right and in theory those data
should be present in the destination
bucket as well
there you go it's all done by lambda
let's move to the next level of
discussion we're going to learn about
what is cloud storage in general and
then the types of storage available in
general in the cloud and how things were
before anybody adopted using s3 that's
something we're gonna learn and then
we're gonna immediately dive into what
is s3 and then the benefits of using s3
over other storage and then we're going
to do a couple of
labs or
console walkthroughs about what is
object and how to add an object what is
bucket how to create a bucket stuff like
that and then we're going to talk about
how amazon s3 generally works now it
comes with a lot of features it comes
with a lot of promise um how does this
all work how does amazon able to keep up
with the promise we're going to talk
about that and then we will talk about
some features add-on features that comes
along with the amazon s3 so what is
cloud storage in general cloud storage
is a service that provides web services
where we can store our data and not only
that the data can be easily accessed and
the data can be easily backed up
everything over the internet in short if
you could store your data if you could
access the data if you could back your
your data everything you do through the
internet then that's a good definition
for cloud storage and the additional
definitions are in cloud storage we only
pay for what we use
no commitment no pre-provisioning is you
know pay-as-you-go type subscription and
the best part is we pay on a monthly
basis you know we don't rent a hardware
for the year or we don't uh give
commitment for the whole year it's pay
as you go and pay on a monthly basis and
these cloud storages are very reliable
meaning once you put the data in it it's
never going to get lost and these cloud
storages are scalable assuming i have a
requirement to store 100 times of what
my actual data sizes and i want it now
it's available in the cloud and these
storages are secure as well because
we're talking about data data virginity
they need to be secure and amazon
provides tools and technologies through
which we can secure our data and these
are generally not found in the
on-premises storage system so let's talk
about the different types of storage in
general so s3 is a cloud storage in aws
and then we have a elastic block store
now elastic block store is actually the
ssd hard drives that gets attached to
our ec2 instance you know it's like the
c drive it's like the d drive it's like
the e drive that gets attached to our
instances now efs is elastic file system
the underlying technology is kind of the
same but it differs from ebs in a way
that ebs can be accessed only by the
system that's attached to it meaning the
e volumes and the d volumes we spoke
about they can be accessed only if there
is an instance connected to it but these
efs are actually shared file systems
elastic file system all right they're
shared systems they can be accessed by
multiple systems they can be accessed
from inside the amazon environment it
can be accessed from on-premises
equipment as well glacier is actually
the archiving solution in the cloud if
you want to dump a data and try to keep
them in
the low cost as possible then glacier is
the product we should be using and then
we have storage gateway if i want to
safely move my data from my local
environment to the cloud environment and
also want to keep a copy of the data
locally so users locally can access them
and in a cloud users or internet users
can access the data from the cloud if
that's your requirement then storage
gateway is the one we would be choosing
and then we have snowball snowball is
really an
data import and export system but
it is actually an hardware that gets
shipped to our premises where we can
copy our data into it and then ship it
back to amazon and amazon would copy the
data into whatever destination we give
them in our account and if the data is
really huge then i can call for a
snowmobile which is actually a data
center on a truck where amazon would
send me and truck loaded with the data
center as you see that has compute
capacity lots and lots of storage
capacity and electricity uh ac and lot
more so they get come parked near our
data center and cables run into our data
center we can copy data into it send it
back to amazon and they would copy it to
our account in whatever storage that we
advise them so if the data is really
really huge then i would be calling
snowmobile snowmobile is not available
in all the regions all right let's take
this example how things were before s3
was introduced you know two
professionals are having a conversation
and one of them is finding it very
difficult to sort of manage all the data
in the organization well if the data is
small it can be easily managed but as
company grow and we are living in an era
where data is everything we want data to
back up every idea we want data to back
up every proof of concept that we
provide so data is everything so this
era it's all about
collecting data analyzing them and
saving you know not losing logs you know
saving them analyzing stuff like that so
coming back to our discussion here one
person finds it very difficult to store
and manage all the data that they have
so some of the data that this person is
having problem uh storing is data's that
applications use to running and then
data that gets sent to the customers and
data's that the websites require the
data that are because of the email
backups and a lot more other storages
that an enterprise can have and this
person is having problem backing up all
those data and even if
we think of uh increasing the local
storage capacity and that's going to
cost the fortune and few things that
make it sometimes impossible to increase
the storage capacity in-house is uh you
know we will have to go and pay heavy to
buy hardware and software to run these
storages and we need to hire a team of
experts for maintaining them the
hardware and the software and anytime if
there is a dynamic increase in the
storage capacity the on-premises or
in-house hardwares won't be able to
scale and data security data security is
very costly when it comes to building
our own storage environment in-house and
adding data security on top of it so the
other guy in the conversation was sort
of quietly listening everything the
manager was saying and then he slowly
introduced him to s3 because he knew
that all the problem that this manager
was worried about can be solved to
estimate in other words all the
scalability all the
data security all the
not being able to provision hardware and
software components are all available
with s3 so that actually brings us to
the discussion about what s3 is s3 is
simple storage service it actually
provides an object storage service let
me talk to you about object and block
storage object storage is where you can
store things into drive all right you
can't install anything in it and this
object storage
can be accessed directly from the
internet whereas block storage is
something that needs to be attached to
an instance and
we can't directly access it but we can
install software in it so that's a high
level difference between object storage
and block storage and s3 is an object
storage what does that mean we can store
data from the internet we can retry from
the internet but we can't install
anything in s3 all right so so s3 is an
object based storage and it's it's
really built for storing and recovering
or retrieving any amount of data or
information from anywhere in the
internet few other things you need to
know about s3 is that this s3 is
accessible through the web interface the
storage one type of accessing or one way
of accessing s3 is by dragging dropping
content into it and another way of
retrieving data from s3 is go to a
browser click on download that's going
to let you download any content and the
data can be five terabytes in size now
we're talking about one file you know
you can have hundreds or thousands of
files like that one file can be as big
as five terabytes in size and s3 is
basically designed for developers where
they can push logs into s3 or drive logs
anytime they want instead of storing
locally in the server they can use s3 as
code repositories you know where they
can save the code and have the
applications read the code from there
and a lot more if they want to safely
share the code with another person with
a lot of encryption and security added
on top of it that's possible as well so
there are a few things about s3 and on
top of all these s3 provides 11 9
durability and 4 9 availability meaning
durability is if i store the data will
it get lost amazon is like no it's not
going to get lost you're going to have
the data because we provide 11 9
durability for the data and availability
is if you want the data now will you be
able to show it amazon is like yes we
will be able to show it we have 99.99
availability and when you request the
data we will be able to show the data to
you all right so let's talk about the
benefits of s3 s3 is durable as we saw
it provides 11 9 durability s3 is low
cost out of all the storage options in
amazon s3 is the cheapest and s3 is very
scalable like we were saying that
there's no required to pre-provision a
storage capacity you know if you need
more go ahead and use more if you need
even more go ahead and use even more and
once you're done some data needs to be
removed just remove the data so that
particular month you will be paying less
so it's very scalable in nature and it's
very available as well s3 isn't regional
service you know it's not based on one
availability zone so one availability
zone going down with an amazon the whole
availability going down it's not going
to affect your ability to access s3
storage and s3 is secure a lot of
security features like bucket policy a
lot of security features like encryption
and then mfa authentication are possible
with the s3 that actually adds a very
good security layer on top of the data
that we have stored in s3 and not only
that this s3 is very flexible in terms
of cost flexible in terms of where i
want to store the data in terms of cost
there are a lot of pricing tiers within
s3
s3 itself is a cheap service now within
that we have a lot of pricing tiers
depending on the durability so i can
always choose to put data on a different
storage tier or storage option in s3
we're going to talk about it as you
stick along and in terms of flexibility
in the region i can always choose any of
the region available in the console or
in the s3 console to put my data to
there is no restrictions on where i can
or cannot put the data in the cloud as
long as there are regions available for
me to move the data to and data
transferring with s3 is very simple all
i have to do is
browse to the bucket upload the data and
the data gets uploaded and we can also
upload data using cli commands are very
similar to linux commands are very
similar to what we would use in the run
command prompt in windows and what we
would use in the run command prompt
in the powershell all right let's talk
about
a basic building block of s3 which is
bucket and objects now what's a bucket
what's an object object is the actual
data and bucket is the folder where the
objects get stored let me give you a new
definition for objects so object is the
actual data plus some information that
reference the data like is it a jpeg
file the name of the file and at what
time it was added to so they're called
metadata all right so object is actually
data plus metadata and bucket is
actually a container that receives the
data and safely stores in it and when we
add a data in a bucket amazon s3 creates
an unique version id and allocates it to
the object so we can easily identify it
at a later point let me show you a quick
lab on s3
all right i'm in the s3 console if
you're wondering how i reached here
go to services under storage and s3 is
right here
and let's create a bucket called simply
learn
now the bucket names will have to be
unique
so i really doubt if simply learn
will be available let's
let's check it anyway
all right it's doesn't seem to be
available so
let me pick another name or let's call
it simplylearn.samuel.com
and i'm going to put this in
mumbai or i can choose oregon
let me choose oregon
oregon
yes
let me choose oregon
and let me create a bucket
sure enough a bucket got created let me
upload an object into the bucket
and you know these objects can be as big
as
five terabytes we talked about it right
all right let me upload an object
all right so that's my object so you get
the relation right
here is a bucket
right here is my bucket and within that
is my object now object is the actual
file
plus what type of file it is
and then
and then the size of the file the date
in which it got added and the storage
class it is in at the moment
so if i have to access it
i can simply access it through the
internet
so let's talk about how does this s3
bucket work anyway all right so how does
it work a user creates a bucket they
will specify the region in which the
bucket should be deployed we had an
option we could have chosen to deploy in
all the regions amazon provides s3
service you know beat not virginia beat
mumbai beat tokyo beat sydney beat
argon and we chose argon to be the
destination region where we want to
create bucket and save our data there
and when we upload data into the bucket
we can specify three types of storage
classes in our case we picked the
default which was a s3 standard as we
saw on the object data it was on s3
standard so that's the basic thing later
once the object gets added we can always
add a bucket policies you know policies
define who access it and who should not
access it what can they access are we
going to allow users only to read or to
read write as well stuff like that so
that's bucket policy we're defining the
life cycle or the lifespan of the data
in the s3 bucket now over the time do
you want the data to automatically move
to a different storage tier and at any
point do you want to sort of expire the
data you know get the data flushed out
of your account automatically and those
things can be configured in life cycle
policies and version control is creating
multiple versions if you're going to use
s3 for a code repository creating
multiple versions let's say if you want
to roll back to whatever you had before
a month how are you going to do it if
you kept updating the file and never
took a version of it so version control
helps us to keep different versions and
it helps us to roll back to the older
version anytime there is a need so let's
talk about the different storage classes
in s3 the different storage classes in
s3 begins with s3 standard now this is
the default and it's very suitable for
use cases where you need less or low
latency for example if you want to
access the data of students attendance
you would retrieve them very quickly as
much as possible so that's a good use
case to store data in s3 let's
understand the different storage classes
in amazon s3 now let's take
a school for example and
the the different data is present in a
school
and the features of those data the
validity of the data all right so let's
take this example and uh there are
different storage options in s3 let's
take s3 standard for example and what
would be the actual candidate data that
can be stored in s3 standard let's talk
about that so s3 standard in general is
suitable for use cases where the latency
should be very low and in here the good
example or the good candidate file that
can be stored in s3 is a data that
needs to be frequently accessed and that
needs to be retrieved quickly something
like students attendance
report or student attendance sheet which
we access daily and then it needs to be
retrieved immediately as and when we
need it the other type of storage chair
in s3 is infrequent access or infrequent
data access just like the name says the
use case for that is less frequently
accessed data i mean the candidate data
that should go in infrequent access data
is a student's academic record you know
which we don't need to access on a daily
basis but if there is a requirement we
might want to go and look at it and
that's going to be quick so it's not a
data that we would access on a daily
basis but it's data that needs to show
up on your screen real quick and the
third option is amazon glacier now
glacier is really an archival solution
in the cloud so for archives high
performance is not a requirement so
let's talk about some candidate data
that can go into archives something like
students admission fee and it's not
critical also now anytime if you want to
look at the data you can always wait to
retrieve the data so in other words you
know put it in the archive and
retrieving from the archival takes time
so students old record are a good
candidate to be put in the archives the
other options are one zone ia storage
class where the data is infrequently
accessed and the data is stored in a
single availability zone for example you
know by default amazon stores data in
multiple availability zones and there is
a charge for that now it's not an option
but the charge includes storing data in
multiple availability zones but if your
data requirement is you want to keep the
charges in a low even further you can
choose a one zone ia storage class where
it stores data in one availability zone
and the candidate data that can go in
one zone in frequent access is students
report card and the other option with
amazon s3 is standard reduced redundancy
storage it is suitable for cases where
the data is not critical and the data
can be reproduced quickly for example
you know take
a copy of the library book take a copy
of the pdf library book for example now
we would have a source pdf and we would
make copies of it and then we make it
available for the readers to read the
other option in s3 is reduced redundancy
storage here the use case is data that's
not critical and data can be reproduced
quickly for example books in the library
are not that critical and we always have
a copy of the book we're talking about
pdf so if the customer facing or the
student facing book gets deleted i can
always copy the same pdf put it in the
destination folder and make it available
for the users to read that would be a
very good use case for reduced
redundancy storage all right let's
summarize everything that we learned
about
different storage options in s3 so s3
standard it's for frequently accessed
data it's the default storage if you
don't mention anything the data gets
stored in s3 standard it can be used for
cloud applications you know content
distribution gaming applications big
data analytic dynamic websites they are
a very good use case for s3 standard
frequently accessed data the other one
on the contrary is s3 standard
infrequently accessed data just like the
name says the use case is this is good
for data that will be less frequently
accessed and and then the use case are
it's good for backups it's good for
disaster recovery and it's good for
lifelong storage of data glacier on the
other hand is very suitable for
archiving data which is infrequently
accessed and the vault lock feature is
the security feature of the glacier that
also provides a long-term data storage
in the cloud this is the lowest storage
tier with an s3 the other options are
one zone infrequent access storage class
just like the name says it's
infrequently accessed and it is stored
in just one availability zone and use
cases are any data that doesn't require
any high level of security can be stored
here in one zone
the fifth storage tier is reduced
redundancy storage this is good for data
that's frequently accessed
it's good for data that is non-critical
and that can be reproduced if it gets
lost and reduced redundancy storage or
rrs is an highly available solution
designed for sharing or storing data
that can be reproduced quickly all right
let's compare and contrast a couple of
other features that are available in
s3 for example durability availability
ssl support first byte latency and life
cycle management so in standard the
durability is 11 9 durability it's the
same for standard standard ia one zone
ia glacier except for reduced redundancy
the durability is 11.99 and availability
of all the storage classes is all the
same except for one zone ia where the
availability zone is
99.5 percentage all of these products
support ssl connection and
the first byte latency of these products
are most of them provide access with
millisecond latency except for glacier
it provides a retrieval time of couple
of minutes to a maximum of hours and all
of them can be used for a life cycle
management you know moving data from one
storage tier to another storage chair
that's possible with all of these
storage options all right now that we've
understood the different types of
storage options available in s3 let's
talk about some of the features that are
available on s3 lifecycle management now
lifecycle management is a service that
helps us to define a set of rules that
can be applied to an object or to the
bucket itself lifecycle is actually
moving the data from one storage tier to
another storage chair and finally
expiring it and and completing the life
cycle of the object with life cycle
management we can manage and store our
objects in a very cost effective way it
has two features basically transition
actions and expiration actions let's
talk about transition actions with
transition action we can choose to move
the objects or move the data from one
storage class to another storage class
with lifecycle management we can
configure s3 to move our data from one
storage class to another storage class
at a defined time interval or at a
defined schedule let's talk about
transition actions in
more detail let's say we have our data
in s3 at the moment and we haven't used
the data for quite some time and it's
that's how it's going to be for the rest
of the time so that data is a very good
candidate to move to the infrequent
access because s3 standard is a bit
costlier and s3 in frequent access is a
bit cheaper than s3 standard so the kind
of usage sort of fits very well for
moving that data into infrequent access
so using life cycle transition or life
cycle management i can move the data to
s3 infrequent access after 30 days and
let's say that the data stayed in
infrequent access for 30 more days and
then now i realize that nobody is
looking into the data so i can find an
appropriate storage tier for that
particular data again and i can move it
to that particular storage chair which
is glacier so in this case after 30 days
or in a total of 60 days from the time
the data got created the data can be
moved to glacier and what does this
really help us with the lifecycle
management help us to automatically
migrate our data from one storage cost
to another storage cost and by that it
really helps us to save the storage cost
lifecycle management can also help us
with the object expiration meaning
deleting the object or flushing it out
after a certain amount of time let's say
that our complex requirement requires
that we keep the data for seven years
and we have like thousands and thousands
of data like that it would be humanly
impossible to check all those or keep
track of all the dates and you know when
they need to be deleted stuff like that
but with life cycle management it is
very much possible i can simply create a
data and set up lifecycle management for
the data to expire after seven years and
exactly after seven years the data is
going to expire meaning it's going to be
deleted automatically from the account
all right let me show you a lab on
lifecycle management and let me explain
to you how it it's actually done so i'm
into the bucket that we have created and
here's our data into the bucket i assume
we have thousands and thousands of data
in the bucket and that requires to be
put in a different storage tier over
time and that requires to be expired
after seven years let's say so the way i
would create a lifecycle management is
go to management from inside the bucket
and click on lifecycle and then add and
lifecycle rule just give it a name name
like expire so all the objects that's
present in this bucket meaning the
current version of it set a transition
for it so the transition is at the
moment they are in s3 so here i would
like to put them in infrequent access
after 30 days and then
after it's been an infrequent access for
30 days i would like to move it to
glacier all right plus 30 days so how do
you read it so for the first 30 days
it's going to be in glacier so how do we
actually read it
after i put the data in s3 the data is
going to get moved to standard ia and
then it's going to stay in standard ia
and after 60 days from the data creation
it's going to get moved to glacier so on
the 31st day it's going to move to
standard ia on the 61st day it's going
to move to glacier let's say if i want
to
sort of delete the data if i want the
data to get deleted automatically after
seven years you know being in a glacier
how do i go about doing it let me open
up a quick calculator
365 into seven that's
2555 days
right after that the data is gonna get
deleted pretty much i have created a
life cycle so
after on the 31st day it's going to get
moved to infrequent access and on the
61st day glacier and after seven years
is over any data that i put in the
bucket it's gonna get deleted all right
let's talk about bucket policies bucket
policies are some permission files that
we can attach to an a bucket that allows
or denies access to the bucket based on
what's mentioned in the policy so bucket
policy is really an im policy where you
can allow and deny permission to an s3
resource with bucket policy we can also
define security rules that apply to more
than one file in a bucket now in this
case you know we can create an user or
let's say there's already a user called
simply learn we can allow or deny that
user connection to the s3 bucket or
connecting to the s3 bucket using bucket
policy and bucket policies are written
in json script and let's see how that's
done all right there are tools available
for us to help us create bucket policies
what you're looking at is a tool
available online that helps us to create
a bucket policy so let's use this tool
to create a bucket policy i'm going to
create a deny statement i'm going to
deny all actions to the s3 bucket and
what is the arn to which we want to
attach the arn of the resource is
actually the name of the bucket but it
really expects us to give that key in a
different format so the arn is available
right here copy bucket arn so this is
actually going to deny everybody now we
wanted to deny a user just one user now
look at that now we have a policy that
has been created that's denying access
to the bucket and it's denying a user
called simply learn pretty much done so
i can use the policy and go over to
bucket policies so once i save it only
the user called simply learn won't have
access
to the bucket and the rest of them will
have access to it
so once you save it it gets added and
only the user simply learn will not have
access to the bucket because we're
denying them purposefully
the other features of s3 include
data protection we can protect our data
in s3 with uh now one of which is bucket
policy i can also use encryptions to
protect my data i can also
use im policy to protect my data so
amazon s3 provides a durable storage not
only that it also gives a as unprotected
and scalable infrastructure needed for
any of our object storage requirements
so here the data is protected by two
means one is data encryption and the
other one is data versioning data
encryption is encrypting the data so
others won't get access or even if they
get access to the file they won't be
able to access the data without the
encryption key and versioning is making
multiple copies of the data so let's
talk about them in detail what's data
encryption now data encryption refers to
protecting the data while it is being
transmitted and
protecting the data while it is at rest
now data encryption can happen in two
ways one is client encryption encryption
at rest and server side encryption
encryption that's in motion client-side
encryption refers to when client sends
the data they encrypt the data and send
it across
to amazon and server side encryption is
when the data is being transferred they
get encrypted and stay encrypted
throughout the transfer
versioning is another security feature
let me it helps us so our unintentional
edits are not actually corrupting the
data
for example let's say you edited the
data and now you realize that the data
is incorrect and you want to roll back
now how do you roll back without
worsening it's not possible in other
words only with worsening it's possible
so versioning it can be utilized to
preserve recovery and restore any early
versions of every object that we stored
in our amazon s3 bucket unintentional
erasers or overrides of the object can
be easily regained if we have versioning
enabled and it's possible only if we
have
one file with the same key name and
anytime we update the file it keeps the
file name but creates a different
version id
take this bucket and data for example
you know photo.pmg is a file that was
initially stored it attached a version
id to it and then we edited it let's say
we added some watermark we you know
added some graphic to it and that's now
the new version of it when we store it
we store it with the same file name it
accepts the same file name but creates a
new version id and attaches it anytime
we want rollback we can always go to the
console look at the old versions pick
the version id and roll back to the old
version id
all right let's take this example now
i'm in a bucket that we've been using
for a while and let me upload an object
now before we actually upload an object
this bucket needs to be versioning
enabled so let me version enable this
bucket from this point onwards this
bucket is going to accept versioning so
let me upload an object photo.jpg let me
upload it right it successfully got
uploaded
good enough it's uploaded
now let me
upload another object
with the same file name now look at that
it was uploaded at 7 40 35 am let me
upload another object with the same file
name
that i have it stored right here that
got up to uploaded but with the same
name
all right so that's the other photo
now what if if i want to switch back the
way i would switch back is simply switch
back to the older version look at that
this is the latest version and this is
the
old version that i have i can simply
switch back to the old version that was
created at such and such time and
i can open it
that's going to open the old file so in
short it creates different version of
the data that i create as long as it's
with the same name and
at any point i can go and roll back to
the original data this is a very good
use case if you want to use s3 for
storing our codes let's talk about other
feature like cross region replication
now cross region replication is an very
cool feature if you want to
automatically keep a copy of the data in
a totally different region for you know
data durability for any additional data
durability or if you want to serve data
to your customers who live in another
country or who are accessing your data
from another country if you want to
serve the data with low latency cross
region replication is a very cool
feature that you can use and get
benefited from and let's see how that's
done so before we actually do a lab on
cross region replication let's put
together a proper definition for it
cross region replication is a feature
that provides automatic copying of every
object uploaded to our bucket or your
bucket source bucket and it
automatically copies the data to the
destination bucket which is in a
different aws region as you see here in
the picture i put data only in region 1
it's going to copy the data to region 2.
and for us to use cross region
replication
versioning must be turned on so it
creates versions and copies the versions
as well if tomorrow the original region
goes down let's say the other region
will be active and it has the complete
data that was present in the original
region or at any point if we want to
simply uh you know cut the region
replication and use the other bucket as
in standalone bucket it can be used as
well because it already has all the data
that was present in the master or all
the data that was present in the
original replication bucket let's see
how that's done so there are two things
needed one is worsening and another one
is roll when we transfer data from a one
bucket to another bucket we need proper
permissions to do so and these roles
they give us proper permissions to
transfer data from one bucket to another
bucket let's see how that's done right
so here's my bucket
a bucket in usr again
let's create another bucket
in
mumbai
call it dot mumbai
dot com
and put it in uh
put it in mumbai
or create that bucket in mumbai there
you go we have one in oregon we have one
in mumbai we're planning to replicate or
create replication between these two
right create application between these
two buckets so go to the first bucket go
to management and start a replication
add a rule so all content in this bucket
is going to get replicated this is my
source bucket it's quite simple select
the destination bucket now my
destination bucket is going to be simply
learn.samuel.mumbai.com
all right it says well you have
versioning enabled in your source bucket
but not on your destination bucket do
you want to enable it now without which
we won't be able to proceed further so
let's go ahead and enable versioning
through the console that shows up and
then
like i said it's going to require
permission to put data onto the other
bucket now i can create different roles
these are different roles
that are used for different other
services i can also choose to create a
role that specifically
gives permission only to move the data
from one bucket to another bucket three
months it's done so if i go over to my
source bucket and if i
add some data to it
let's say index.html
assuming i'm adding some files to it in
theory
they should
move to the other region automatically
they go i'm in the mumbai region and the
data's they got moved to the other
region automatically let's talk about
the other feature called transfer
acceleration now it's a very handy and a
helpful tool or a service to use if we
are transferring data which is very long
distance from us meaning from the client
to the s3 bucket let's say from my local
machine which is in india if i transfer
the data over to
oregon let's say it's a long distance if
it is going to go through the internet
it's going to go through high latency
connections and my transfer might get
delayed if it is an uh one gigabit file
it's okay but if we're talking about
anything that's uh you know five
terabyte size and if you're talking
about anything that's a five terabyte in
size then
it's not going to be a pleasant
experience so in those cases i can use
transfer accelerator
with which in a secure way but in a fast
way or a fastest way transfers my data
from the
laptop or from client to the s3 bucket
and it makes use of a service called
cloudfront to transfer or to enable the
data acceleration so the way it would do
it is instead of copying the data
directly to the location instead of
copying the data directly to the
destination bucket it copies the data
locally into a cloudfront location which
is available very local to whatever
place we are in and from there it copies
the data directly to an s3 bucket not
going through the internet that helps
eliminate a lot of latency that could
get added when transferring the data so
let's see how that's done right here i'm
in the s3 bucket and under properties
i can find transfer accelerator and if i
enable transfer accelerator so i'm in
another bucket
let me go to properties and let me go to
transfer accelerator and enable transfer
accelerator so now if i put data into
this bucket they're going to get copied
to the local cloudfront location and
from there they're going to get copied
to the s3 bucket from the cloudfront now
if i need to compare you know how the
speed is going to be compared to
directly putting the data to the
internet and using cloudfront there is a
tool available that actually runs for a
while and then comes with a report that
tells me
how much will be the improved speed if i
use transfer accelerator and it shows
for all the regions available in amazon
so from the source to the destination if
you want to put you know what's the
normal and what's the accelerated speed
when you transfer the data those results
we will get in the screen so at the
moment this tool is going through it
testing like uploading some file through
the internet and uploading some file
using cloudfront and it has come up with
the calculation that if i'm uploading
file to
san francisco compared to uploading
through the internet and through
cloudfront it's 13 times faster so
similar way it's going to calculate for
all the regions available and it's going
to give me a result welcome to this new
learning
series called i am a service in aws for
security by the way i'm samuel an aws
cloud architect cloud evangelist and
cloud author working for simply law here
in this section we're going to talk
about
what is security in aws and then we're
going to slowly or gradually move on to
the other topics like types of security
available in aws out of all the services
why i am is the most preferred one and
then we're going to talk about what is
im in general how it works the building
blocks or components and i am and the
features it the the attractive features
that it provides that makes iam stand
out from the rest of the services
available we're going to talk about that
and then we're going to end today's
session with a demo about how iam gets
well interacted with other services in
amazon and help create a secure
environment in the cloud let's talk
about aws security now cloud security is
the highest priority in aws and when we
host our environment in the cloud we can
be rest assured that we are hosting our
environment in a data center or in a
network architecture that's really built
to meet the requirement of the most
security sensitive organization and this
high level of security is available to
us on a pay-as-you-go type meaning there
is really no upfront cost that we need
to pay and the cost for
using the service is lot lot cheaper
than what it is in an on-premises
environment so aws cloud provides an a
secure virtual platform where we can
deploy our application now compared to
the on-premises with aws the security
level is very high and the cost involved
in using or attaching that type of
security to our application is very low
compared to on premises there's really
no upfront cost and the cost is very
lower whatever cost that we pay is very
lower than what it would be in on
premises and all this contributes to the
secure environment we can get through im
in aws cloud there are really many types
of security services available in aws to
name a few are to name the familiar ones
im stands first followed by a key
management system kms and then we have
cognito that's another service and web
access firewall vaf is another security
service in aws now let's start our
discussion by talking about im and
that's what this whole series is about
now i am or identity and access
management it really enables us to
manage access to aws services and aws
resources in a very secure manner with
im we can create
groups we can actually allow those users
or groups to access some service or we
can sort of deny them uh to access the
service whichever we want that's all
possible through identity and access
management and this feature comes with
no additional charge now let's talk
about how things were before aws before
aws or before i am
in general it was not that safe in a
corporate to share the password over the
phone or through the email that was the
practice that was existed at that time
now we all can remember the days when we
need to switch to a different account or
we had just one admin password commonly
stored in a location or one person would
reset it and maintain it and any time or
we need to login we call the person ask
for the admin password or the phone and
then we try logging in now that was not
secure at all back then you know
somebody could walk by and sort of
eavesdrop you know get the password now
they walk away with the password with
them so they're all possible when we
share the password over the phone and
through the internet or email now with
aws a lot of options are available that
i'm not sharing password over the
unsecure medium now a slack is a
third-party product available with aws
it's not an aws product but slack is in
third-party application that's hosted on
aws and it's really a communication tool
that helps people to share documents so
now we're not sharing the password over
the phone rather through the
applications and no eavesdrop person can
really catch the password and you know
try it in their system to access our
environment that's not possible so you
see the difference now back then sharing
password was only through phone and
email and you would write it on a paper
and you give it to somebody but now
technology is providing provisions
enough for us to share the password in a
secure way we're still talking about i
am im as an web service for securely
controlling access to the aws resource
now it really helps us to authenticate
or sort of limit access to a certain set
of users accessing the aws account or
certain set of users accessing a certain
set of resources in aws account now you
see this picture we have an im
administrator who is trying to allocate
permissions to different group of people
so we have group 1 on the top and group
2 in the middle and group three uh
towards the end the administrator using
iam or iam empowers the administrator
allow access to certain group to certain
resources that's what iam is all about
now let's talk about the building blocks
or let's talk about the elements that
make and complete im so the elements are
categorized into six
different elements we have the principle
in im the authentication the request the
actual request coming in the
authorization allowing denying access
actions what are the scope of actions
can be taken and on what resource is it
easy to is it ideas is it s3 bucket so
what resource these actions are applied
to so they are the basic elements of an
iem workflow let's talk about principle
for example an action on aws resource
can only be performed by a principal an
individual user they can be a principal
a role in aws im it can be a principle
as well in other words a principal is an
entity that can take an action on an aws
resource you know a principal can be an
user a principle can be a role a
principle can be an application that's
trying to access the aws environment
secondly authentication now
authentication is a process of
confirming the identity of the principal
trying to access the aws environment now
how do we get authenticated or how does
the user get authenticated by providing
credentials or the required keys to
validate that this is what he or she is
as per what's in the record so all
principle must be authenticated and we
get authenticated using the username and
password to log into the console if it
is cli or we get authenticated using the
access key and the secret access key
the other component that makes up im is
request when a principal tries to use
the aws management console what the
principal is doing or what the user is
doing is sending a request to the aws
environment and the request will have
the principle actually wants to perform
is it a put request or is it a get
request or is it a delete request stuff
like that and it's also going to carry
information about on which resource the
action needs to be done is it on easy to
one is it on
s3bucketsimplylearn.com stuff like that
so it has a specific action that it
wants to perform and the resource on
which it wants to perform and also some
information about from where the request
is originating from is it within an aws
environment or is it with another cloud
service provider or is it with
on-premises stuff like that so these
information will be present in the
request authorization now this iam uses
information from the request context to
check for matching policies and it
determines it takes a decision whether
to allow or to deny the request now here
it has a logic by default all the
resources are denied and im authorizes
your request only if every part of the
request is allowed by a matching policy
so there is an evaluation logic that
says by default all requests are denied
and if there is an explicit allow
then it overrides the default deny and
if you are explicitly denying a service
then all the allow statements gets
overridden and all the other statements
gets overwritten and this explicit deny
stands by default only the aws account
root user has access to all the
resources in that account so if you're
not signed in as a root user then we
must be specifically granted permission
through a policy in other words we need
to be authorized through the policy now
let's talk about action now after
authenticating and authorizing the
request aws approves the action that we
are about to take now using action we
can view the content we can create a
content or create a bucket or create an
ec2 instance i can edit content or even
i can delete a resource that's all based
on the action that i'm allowed to do now
that was about actions now where is the
action performed the action is performed
on the resources a set of actions can be
performed on a resource and anything
that's not mentioned in the action or
anything that's not tagged with the
action and the resource they don't get
to complete for example let's say if you
attempt to delete an im role and you
also request to access the ec2 instance
for that role then the request gets
denied now let's talk about some of the
other components of im so the other
components are im are the basic building
block is an user and then many users
together they form a group and then
policies are the engines that allows or
denies a connection
based on policy one gets to access or
gets no access to a resource and then
roles roles are another component rules
are temporary credentials i would say
that can get assumed to an instance as
in when needed let's talk about this
component called user in an im with im
we can securely manage access to aws
services and
we can create an im user anytime there
is a new employee joining our corporate
so its a one-to-one mapping you know one
user or one employee get a username
directly attached to them and a username
or a user is an account specific thing
you know it's very local to that aws
account that we are using so for in
detail an iem user is an entity that
we create in an aws environment to
represent a person or a service that
interacts with aws environment and this
user is going to have some credentials
attached to them and by default they do
not have
a password and they do not have any
access key or secret access key attached
to them in fact literally no credentials
of any kind now we must create an user
and we must create the type of
credential that gets attached to the
user do they want to access a cli so
based on that we would be adding
credentials to them a user by default is
not authorized to perform any action in
aws and the advantage of having
one-to-one user is that we can assign
permissions individually to that user
for example we might want to assign
administrative permissions to few users
who can administer our aws environment
and users are entity within an aws
account users don't have to pay
separately you know they start using
their servers and that get bills under
the account they are attached to so
separate users doesn't mean that
separate payment for those users they
are just users in our account and
you know the whole account gets to pay
for the resources that they provision
again the im user does not always
represent a person an iem user is really
just an identity uh with associated
credential and permissions attached to
it it could be an actual person who is a
user and it could be an application also
a who is a user next we'll talk about
groups talking about groups or
understanding group is very easy a
collection of user forms an iem group
and we can use iam group to specify
permission for multiple users so that
any permission that's applied to the
group is also applied to the users who
are at add to that group now there are
few things you might want to know about
group a group can have
many users and a user they can belong to
many groups but groups can't be nested
meaning group can only have users a
group cannot have a group inside a group
that's not possible and there's nothing
called a default group that sort of
automatically includes all users in the
aws account
if you want to have a group then we will
have to create a group now let's take
this diagram for example now this is a
diagram of an small company now the
company owner creates an admin group for
users to create and manage other users
as the company expands every day and the
admin group creates a developer group
and a test group each of these group
consists of users users who are a people
users who are application that interact
with aws environment so the different
types of users we have are jim is a user
brad is an user and
dev app one is a user and and so on so
each users have an individual set of
security credential like i said it's one
to one and the
10 users that we see on screen are
shared between or they belong to
multiple groups in the account and
managing group is quite easy we set
permission to the group and that
permission gets applied to all the users
automatically in the group and after we
applied the policy
if i add another user to the group the
new user will automatically inherit all
the policies all the permissions that's
already mentioned in that group so
administrative burden is sort of taken
away administrative burden about user a
privilege or user permission management
is sort of taken out with im all right
the next thing we will want to discuss
is policy a policy sets permission and
controls the access to aws resource and
the policies this permissions and
controls are stored in json format a
policy is a very clear document it
defines who has access to a resource and
what are all the actions they can
perform so in other words policy is an
entity in aws that when a policy gets
attached to an identity or a resource
you know it really defines the
permission what they can and cannot do
and aws it evaluates these policies when
a principal such as a user makes a
request and the permission statement and
the policy it really defines whether the
user is allowed to access a service or
is he denied to access a service all
right let's take this example now we
have a task the task is to give paul
who's a developer access to amazon s3
environment and what you're looking at
is a snippet of what a policy would look
like so these are some questions we will
have to answer or these are some
questions the policy uh tries to answer
and uh once it found an answer then it
becomes a complete policy so who wants
access to the service it's paul who
wants access to the service and what
action do paul want now paul wants to
download or paul wants to upload objects
in s3 in json language it's otherwise
called paul wants to get information
paul wants to put information otherwise
paul wants to get object paul wants to
put object in s3 and which resource does
he want now in this case every bucket
the star symbol represents all buckets
in x3 so which resource it's all bucket
in x3 so we can stop reading already
from the data present here so who wants
access paul wants access what action
does he want he wants to get he wants to
put and what's the resource that he's
trying to access or you want to give him
access it's all the bucket in aws and
when does he want these additional
statement that goes in a policy so since
when does he want that access he wants
access till march 2nd 2019 so all this
who all this action all this resource
you know till the time all this gets
allowed so this is the statement that
really defines now does this all refer
to an allow statement or does this all
refer to a deny statement if we had deny
here it's the direct opposite of what we
discussed but we have allowed that means
paul is allowed to get and put access in
an s3 bucket and all the buckets in s3
till march 2nd 2019 he's allowed to
access the resources so if we put
together put all the information that we
have gathered or all the answers that we
have so far if we put together in a json
format this is how it's going to look
like so
the effect is allow or deny here it's
allowing and the principle uh is any now
who can access it it's any an action
it's any bucket in s3 any action in s3
put get request and the resource is any
bucket in s3 so that's how a basic
policy would look like or that's how a
basic policy is formed by answering
those basic questions so let's talk
about the types of policies so we have
two broad categories manage policy and
inline policy the manage policy it's the
default policy that we attach to
multiple entries be users be it groups
and beat roles in our aws account on the
other hand inline policy are the
policies that we create and manage them
and these policies are embedded directly
into a single user group or a role so if
i need to brief
it a little bit more then a managed
policies are standalone identity based
policies that we can attach to multiple
users groups and roles in our aws
account we can use two types of managed
policies in other words manage policies
they themselves have two categories one
is aws manage policies which is created
and managed by aws and the other one is
customer managed policies just like the
name says it's managed by the customer
now we can create and edit an im policy
in visual editor or simply create a json
policy document directly and upload it
in the console and start using them so
that's
manage policy on the other hand inline
policies are policies that we create
and manage and that are embedded
directly into a single user group or
role let's talk about this next
component called role now this role is
very similar to everything that we
discussed so far it's
a set of permission that defines what
actions are allowed and denied by an
entity in an aws console the role is
very similar to an user i said very
similar i didn't say it's the same as
the user but i said it's very similar to
the user and the difference is that user
is hard coded user permissions are hard
coded but the role permissions are
accessed by any entity you know beat a
user or a beat and aws service and
moreover the role permissions are
temporary on the other hand user
permissions are permanent and the role
permissions are temporary
so in detail a role is very similar to a
user in that it's an aws entity with
permission policies that determines what
the identity can and cannot do in aws
now instead of it being uniquely
associated with one person a role is
intended to be assumable by anyone who
needs it rules generally do not have an
long term credential you know password
or access keys associated with it you
know it does not have
long term credentials it only has
temporary credentials created
dynamically and provided to the user as
in when the user assumes a role and
wants to access any service roles can be
assumed by users roles can be assumed by
applications roles can be assumed by
services that normally you don't have
access to aws resources for example you
might want to grant a user in your aws
account access to your resource that
they do not
normally have or grant users in one aws
account access to resource in another
aws account now this is something that
we don't have by default and this is
something we may not need all the time
or you might want to allow a mobile app
to use aws resource but you do not want
to save the key or save the credential
or save the passwords in the mobile app
or sometimes you might want to give
access to resources who already have
identities defined outside of aws like a
user who's already and google or
facebook authenticator if you want to
give them some service or if you want to
let them to access some of the resources
in your account we can use roles for
that purpose or you also might want to
grant access to your account to a third
party a consultant or an auditor so they
can for some time get some temporary
access to audit our aws resources
remember they're not permanent users
just templar users they want some
temporary access to our environment
until the audit is over so for those
cases roles are a very good use case so
let's take this
example let's see where role sits and
let's see how roles give permission to
other services so here is a scenario
where where an ec2 instance
wants access to an s3 bucket by default
though both of them were created by the
same username or the same admin they do
not have access by default so by default
they don't have access and i also do not
want to give permanent access you know
one-on-one hard-coded permanent access
instead i would like to create and share
access so that's possible to roll so
coming back to the discussion uh the
scenario here is that an ac2 instance
wants to access data in an s3 bucket so
the first thing is to create a role or a
permission we saw how that's done right
using policies roles use policies policy
is the actual working engine for any
permission related actions right so
create a role with an appropriate policy
that gives access to s3's bucket and
then launch an ec2 instance with the
role attached to it we said rules are
assumed by any entity right it could be
user it could be an application it could
be a service it could be another
resource in aws account so here it's
another resource in aws account right so
we create a role and we attach it to an
ec2 instance so now the ec2 instance can
assume the role now the same role can be
attached to another ec2 instance the
same rule can be attached to
another user the same rule can be
attached to another database service we
get the idea right roles can be assumed
by anyone so when the ec2 instance wants
to communicate with s3 it contacts the
role and then the role gives this ec2
instance some temporary username and
password that expires after one hour
let's say so it's a temporary username
and password now with that temporary
username and password the ec2 instance
can access the
s3 bucket and access the file with the
credential that it already has and that
credential is a temporary one and the
credential will expire after one hour or
how much ever time the admin sets it to
be and then the next time when is when
an ec2 instance wants to contact s3 it
will have to contact the role and the
role will propose a new access key and
secret access key in other words a new
credential with that new credential the
second time the ec2 instance will be
able to contact the s3 bucket and get
the information so the password is not a
permanent or a one-time or a hard-coded
password it keeps rotating it's a token
it's a secure token that an ec2 instance
or any application that uses the role
gets to access the resources on the
other end well let's talk about the
features of iam the main feature of im
is that i can create separate username
and password for individual users or
resources and i can delegate access now
those days where we had just one
username and password for admin and we
need to call the other person to get the
username and password over the phone uh
if it gets compromised you know the
whole account gets compromised stuff
like that those issues are gone i can
create separate username and password
for all thousand users in my account no
more username and password sharing i can
manage access to all those thousand
accounts in a very simple and an easy
way so im provides shared access for all
the thousand users in my account it
provides share access to the aws
environment and the permissions that can
be given through im are very granular
now we saw how restrictions can be put
on get request you know we can allow a
user to download information and not
update an information so that's possible
through the iem policies that we looked
at sometime back and with the use of
roles you know we're authenticating an
ec2 instance instead of the application
running on top of it so if there are
like 10 or 20 applications running on
top of an ec2 instance instead of
creating a separate username and
password for all those 20 instances i
can create a role and assign that role
to the
ec2 instance and all the applications
running on the ec2 instance get a secure
access to the other resources use the
role credential that's provided to that
ec2 instance now besides username and
password im also supports multi-factor
authentication where we provide our
credential the username and password
plus an otp from our phone or an
randomly generated
number that gets displayed in our phone
before amazon console or before amazon
cli would authenticate and uh lets us
access some of the servers in the
account so it's called multi-factor
authentication it's username and
password plus something else from what
you have i am also provides identity
federation if a user is already
authenticated with a corporate ad or
facebook or google you know im can be
made to trust that authentication method
and then allow access based on that
authentication now without federation
what would happen is the users will have
to remember two passwords you know one
for on-premises and one for cloud
anytime they work on on-premises they'll
have to use one set of password and
anytime they switch to the cloud which
is going to be very frequent in a every
day so anytime they switch to the cloud
they will have to again type in the
cloud username and password now with
identity federation we can sort of
federate or we can connect both the
authentication systems both on-premises
and im so users can just use one
username and password for both
on-premises and cloud environments and
all that we saw so far it's free to use
there is no additional charge for iam
security there is no additional charge
for creating additional users groups or
policies it's a free service comes along
with any account im is an pci dss
compliant product now im comes with
password policy where we can reset the
password remotely or rotate the
passwords remotely
and we can set rules like how a user
should pick an password it should not be
the one that was used in the past any of
the past three times stuff like that so
uh you get the idea right how the
features of im help us to build and a
secure authentication and authorization
system in or for our aws account
all right it's time to do a quick lab
let's let's put all the knowledge that
we have earned so far together and apply
it and try a lab and solve the problem
so here's a problem statement
we need to create an s3 bucket for a
company where users can read or write
the data only if they are multi-factor
authenticated so there could be like 20
users in an account but a user is
allowed to read or write a data in a
necessary bucket only if the user is
multi-factor authenticated you know this
is a very good use case if we have a
sensitive data in an s3 bucket and you
only want privileged or mfa
authenticated users to do changes to
those buckets and for those privileged
users you would enable multi-factor
authentication so let's see how that's
done before that let me talk to you a
bit more about multi-factor
authentication a multi-factor
authentication is that additional level
of security process it's provided by aws
here the user's identity is confirmed
only after the user proposes or the user
passes to level of verification now one
being the username and password and
another being an otp that gets generated
in this case it's the mobile phone it
could also be an rsa token key that
generates the one-time password that's
possible as well but in this case it's
the mobile phone now that's going to be
very similar to how we log in to our
gmail account sometimes when we log into
a gmail account and
i mean if you have the proper setting
enabled it's going to send an one-time
password to the mobile phone and only
after we put that information it's going
to let us log in let's see how all this
is done in an aws account so the first
thing is to log in to the aws account
create a user and attach the user to the
virtual mfa device now we're going to
use google authenticator here and we're
going to attach the user to
google authenticator and make the user
use the google authenticator one time
password every time he logs in to the
account now this is an addition to the
username and password that
he or she already has right so the first
thing is to log into the account connect
or sync the virtual appliance with the
aws username and password now when we
sync there will be an one-time password
that gets shown in the phone type in the
password in the aws console and then the
phone and the username comes to sync and
from that point onwards the user anytime
they log in they will have to propose
their username and password which is the
first step of security and then once
they typed in the username and password
type in the mfa code that gets generated
on the phone that would be the second
step or security or the last step of
security once that is done the account
is going to let them log in and access
the aws resources
alright so in order to test im mfa s3
together this is what we are going to do
so we are going to create
a bucket and we are going to have two
users and we are going gonna allow or
deny access to the s3 bucket to those
two users based on whether they are mfa
authenticated or not and on purpose uh
we're gonna assign mfa to one user and
no mfa to the other user like you might
have guessed by now the user with mfa
will have access to the bucket and the
user with no mfa attached will not have
access to the bucket both of them are
going to have full s3 services but mfa
like i said is one layer above the other
permissions mfa stands at all time so
irrespective of whether the underlying
policy says but they have full access to
the s3 bucket they are not going to
because mfa stands on top of it let's
see how that's done to begin with
firstly we need a bucket so let's create
a bucket
so i'm in my
aws console so let me go to s3
and in here create a bucket call that
bucket as simply learn mfa bucket and
let me put it in north virginia and
create
all right so that's done
now i'm going to put a separate folder
in here
i'm going to create another folder in
here and the name of the folder is tax
documents now this is where i'm planning
to keep my tax files
and i only want my privileged users to
be able to upload and download
information from the tax document so on
the bucket side it's partially done or
on the s3 side it's partially done so
let's go back to iam
and here we're going to create two users
one a junior employee and another one
and a senior employee the senior
employee is the one who is going to have
mfa access and
more access to the s3 bucket and the
junior employee is the one who's not
going to have access to that particular
bucket so let's get
started let's create an user under iam
click on users
and let's create a user call as user
junior
right so here's a junior user
and for the password
set a password
the user does not need to create a new
password at sign in because it's a test
environment and
the user who creates the username and
the user are the same person so let's
keep it simple username password
management console access
and this user is going to have
full s3 bucket access all right this is
really the policy
and we should be familiar
with this json document by now it says
effect is allowed and what action any
action in s3 and
what resource anybody who is attached to
it
review
and create a user
so this user is having
s3 full access now let's create another
user call them as senior employee
all right attach
a policy to the user
you know from the surface level both of
them have the same permissions both of
them have s3 full access
all right so
both of them have s3 full access as we
see
there's one thing different we're going
to do to this
senior employee now we're going to
attach
mfa to this employee so the way we would
do it is under the summary section of
that particular user click on security
credential and see here is a place we
can attach an mfa to this user so let's
attach mfa to this user
for mfa i can use both virtual mfa or
hardware mfa this being in lab
environment we're going to use virtual
mfa now that is an application there are
a lot of applications available but
there is one application that i'm using
at the moment called google
authenticator
so once we have installed the
application and once it is running
so i can go to virtual mfa device and
once it is running i can scan the code
using the google authenticator in my
mobile phone once you turn on the
application and once you do scan the
barcode that
is showing right here now that's going
to give us codes that we can use and we
will have to put in those codes here
twice we'll have to wait for some time
and it would generate a second set of
key that we can put
so my first set of key is four zero two
three five one right i'll have to wait
for some time and then it would throw me
a second set of key it's like validating
twice right here so let me put in my
second set of key
so this user is now mfa authenticated
user so anytime this user logs in it's
going to ask for mfa anytime this user
proposes something it's going to attach
the mfa key along with it all right so
we're done with im what have we done
with im we have created two users both
of them have actually full access but
one of them have
mfa access and the other one does not
have mfa access and based on whether the
user is having mfa or not you know we
are
privileged users by this mfa all right
so based on whether the user has mfa or
not are we gonna allow deny access in
the s3 bucket
so we already have a bucket we already
have a folder and this is a very
privileged
folder part here i would like to
restrict access based on whether the
user is having mfa or not
so let me create a bucket policy
here now here's a policy that i have
written
the policy
says that you know under tax document
folder give access only if the user is
mfa authenticated right if the user is
not mfa authenticated simply deny the
access to that user so as you might
guess right now the user one will not
have access or the
junior employee will not have access
because it's a privilege then you know
junior employee might tend to delete
them unknowingly and only privileged
users get access to the tax document
because it's confidential because it's
privileged because if it gets deleted we
won't be able to get it back for those
reasons right so apply the bucket policy
now try logging in as
the different users and see how the
permissions are applied on both the
users all right so let's make a note of
the im url
and then the two usernames and password
let's login
so let me login as the privileged user
sure enough i'm being asked for an mfa
code let me put my mfa code
so let's directly navigate to the s3
bucket
right here's my privileged path let me
try uploading some content
claim forms
sure enough i'm able to upload content
into it will i be able to delete
yes i'm able to delete as well now let's
see what's the situation for the other
user
so let's login
as the other user
navigate to the sd bucket
if you noticed when logging in it did
not ask for an mfa code because the user
is not set up for mfa
so navigate to the folder which we want
to test
now try adding some files
as you see it's failing
to add content to this bucket it shows
error because the bucket policy is
requiring mfa and this user is not mfa
and we did that in im or under iam
but still as you see you know they will
be able to view the content in the
bucket they can do all that we have
specifically restricted access to upload
and download content from the bucket and
that's exactly this user is now denied
with in this section we are going to
talk about
basics of aws and then we're going to
immediately dive into
why
why we need amazon route 53 and then
we're going to expand and talk about the
details of amazon route 53 the benefits
it provides over its competitors and the
different types of routing policy it has
and some of amazon ralph 53's key
features and we're going to talk about
how to access route 53 i mean the
different ways the different methods you
can access route 53 and finally we're
going to end with an a wonderful demo in
drought 53 so let's talk about what is
aws amazon web services or aws in short
is a cloud provider that offers a
variety of services such as a variety of
id services or infrastructure services
such as a compute power database
content delivery and other resources
that helps us to scale and grow our
business and aws is hot aws is picking
up aws is being adapted by a lot of
customers that's because aws is easy to
use even for a beginner and talking
about safety the the aws infrastructure
is designed to keep the data safe
irrespective of the size of the data be
it small data be it
very minimal data be it all the data
that you have in terabytes and in
petabytes amazon can keep it safe in
their environment and the wonderful
thing and the most important reason why
a lot of customers move into the cloud
is that the pay-as-you-go pricing there
is no long-term commitment and it's very
cost effective what this means is that
you're not paying for a resource that
you're not using in on-premises you do
pay for resources you're not using a lot
meaning you go and buy a server you do
the estimate for the next five years
and only after like three or four years
you'll be hitting the peak capacity but
still you would be buying that capacity
before four years right and then you
will gradually be you know utilizing it
from you know 40 percent date 60 days 70
80 and then 100. so what you have done
is that even though you're not using the
full capacity you still have bought it
and are and are paying for it from day
one but in the cloud it's not like that
you only pay for the resources that you
use anytime you want more you scale up
the resource and you you pay for the
scaled up resource and anytime you want
less you scale down the resource and you
pay less for that scaled down resource
let's talk about why amazon
route 53 let's take this scenario where
rachel is trying to open her web browser
and
the url that she hit isn't working a lot
of reasons behind why the url isn't
working it could be the server
utilization that went high it could be
it could be the memory usage that went
high a lot of reasons and she starts to
think is there an efficient way to scale
resources according to the user
requirements or is there an efficient
way to kind of mask all those failures
and kind of divert the traffic to the
appropriate active you know active
resource or active service that's
running our application you always want
to hide the failures right in it kind of
mask the failure and direct the customer
to another healthy service that's
running right none of your customers
would want to see a server not available
or you know none of the customers your
customers would want to see your service
not working not impressive to them and
this is tom tom is an i.t guy and he
comes with an idea and he's answering
rachel yes we can scale resources
efficiently using amazon rod53 in a
sense he's saying that yes we can mask
the failure and we can keep the services
up and running meaning we can provide
more high availability to our customers
with the use of route 53 and then he
goes on and explains amazon drop 53 is a
dns service that gives developers an
efficient way to connect users to
internet applications without any
downtime now downtime is the key amazon
route53 helps us to avoid any downtime
that customers will experience you still
will have downtime in your server and
your application but
your customers will not be made aware of
it and then rachel is kind of interested
and she's like yeah that sounds
interesting i want to learn more about
it and tom goes on and explains the
important concepts of amazon rock 53
that's everything that i'm going to
explain it to you as well all right so
what is amazon rod53 amazon drop 53 is
an highly scalable dns or domain name
system web service
this service this amazon raw 53 it
functions three main things or it has
three main functions so the first thing
is if a website needs a name route53
registers the name for the website
domain let's say you want to buy
google.com you want to buy the domain
name let's say you want to buy that
domain name you buy that through rot 53
secondly a route 53 is the service that
actually connects your
server which is running your application
or which is holding which is serving
your web page so that's the service that
actually route 53 is the service that
connects the user to your server when
they hit google.com in the browser or
whatever domain name that you have
purchased so you bought a domain name
and the user types in
yourdomainname.com and then roth53 is a
service that helps the user to connect
their browser to the application that's
running in an ec2 instance or any other
server that you are using to serve that
content and not only that rot 53 checks
health of the resource by sending
automated requests over the internet to
a resource so that's how it identifies
if there is any resource that has failed
can i say resource i'm referring to any
infrastructure failure any application
level failure so it kind of keeps
checking so it understands it first
before the customer notices it and then
it does the magic kind of shifts the
connection from a one server to the
other server we call it routing we will
talk about that as we progress so the
benefits of using route53 it's highly
scalable meaning suddenly let's say the
number of requests the number of people
trying to access your website through
that domain name that you have bought
let's say it has increased ralph 53 is
highly scalable right it can handle even
millions and millions of requests
because it's highly scalable and it's
managed by amazon the same thing it's
reliable it's a highly scalable it can
handle large queries without the users
without you interacting without the user
who bought it interact with it you don't
have to scale up you know when you're
expecting more requests it automatically
scales and it is very reliable in the
sense that
it's very consistent it has the ability
to route the users to the appropriate
application through the logic that it
has it's very easy to use when we do the
lab you're going to see that it's very
easy easy to use you buy the domain name
and then you simply map it to the
application you simply map it to the
server by putting in the ip or if you
you can simply map it to another load
balancer by putting in the load balancer
url you can simply map it to another
s3 bucket by simply putting the s3
bucket name or the sd bucket url it's
pretty straightforward easy to set up
and it's very cost effective in a way
that we only pay for the service that we
have used so no wastage of
money here so the billing is set up in
such a way that you are paying only for
the amount of requests that
you have received right the amount of
traffic the amount of requests that you
have received
and couple of other things the the
number of uh
hosted zones that you have created right
and couple of other things
it's very cost effective in such a way
that you only pay for the service that
you are using and it's secure in a way
that access to route 53 is
integrated with the identity and access
management iam so you only have
authorized users
gain access to route 53 the trainee who
just joined yesterday won't get access
and the contractor or the consultant the
third party consultant you have given
access or who is using your environment
you can block access to that particular
person because he's not the admin or
he's not a privileged user in your
account so only privileged users and
admin gain access to route 53 through
iam now let's talk about the routing
policies so when you create a record in
in route 53 recorder is nothing but an
entry so when you do that you choose a
routing policy right routing policy is
nothing but it determines how route 53
responds to your queries how the dns
queries are being responded right that's
that's a record or that's a routing
policy so the first one is a simple
routing policy so we use simple
routing policy for a single resource in
other words simple routing allows to
configure dns with no special route 53
routing it's kind of one-to-one you use
an single resource that performs a given
function to your domain for example if
you want to simply map an url to a web
server that's pretty straightforward
simple routing so it routes traffic to a
single resource example web server to a
website and with simple routing multiple
records with the same name cannot be
created
but multiple values can be created in
the same record the second type of
routing policy is failover routing so we
would be using failover routing when we
want to configure active passive
failover if something failed right you
want to fail over to the next resource
which was previously the backup resource
now the active resource or which was
previously the backup server now it's an
active server so you would be failing
over to that particular resource or that
particular ip if you want to do that we
use failover routing so failover routing
routes traffic to a resource when the
resource is healthy or to a different
resource when the previous resource is
unhealthy in other words anytime a
resource goes unhealthy i mean it does
all that's needed to shift the traffic
from the primary resource to the
secondary resource in other words from
the unhealthy resource to the healthy
resource and this records can draw
traffic to anything from an
amazon
s3 bucket or you can also configure a
complex tree of uh records now when we
configure the records it will be uh more
clear to you so as of now just
understand that route 53 can route or
this routing policy the failover routing
policy can route traffic to amazon s3
bucket or
to a website that has complex tree of
records geo location routing policy now
geo location routing just like the name
says it takes that routing decision
based on the geographic location of the
user in other words you know when you
want to roll traffic based on the
location of the user that's your primary
criteria for you know sending that
request to the appropriate server we
will be using jio
location routing so it localizes the
content and presents a part or the
entire website in the language of the
user for example a user from us
you would want to direct them to an
english website and a user from german
if you want to send them to the german
website and a user from france you know
you want to send those requests or you
want to show content specific to a
customer who lives in france a french
website so this is if that's your
condition this is the routing policy we
would be using and the geographic
locations are specified by either
continent or by country or by state in
the united states so only in the united
states you can actually split it to
state level and for the rest of the
countries you can do it on a country
level on a high level you can also do it
on a continent level the next type of
routing policy would be job proximity
routing geoproximity routing policy when
we want to route traffic based on the
location of our resource and optimally
shift traffic from resources in one
location to resource in another location
we would be using geoproximity routing
so geoproximity routing routes traffic
to the resources based on the geographic
location of the user and the resources
they want to access and it also has an
option to route
more traffic or less to a given resource
by specifying a value known as a bias
kind of weight but we also have weighted
routing that's different so we've chosen
different name bias you can send more
traffic to a particular resource by
having a bias on that particular routing
condition and a bias expands or shrinks
the size of the geographic region from
which traffic is routed to a resource
and then we have latency based routing
just like the name says we use latency
based routing if we have resources in
multiple aws regions and if you want to
route traffic to the region that
provides the best latency at any given
point of time so
let's say if one single website needs to
be installed and hosted on multiple aws
regions then latency routing policy is
what is being used it improves the
performance of the users by serving the
request from the aws region that
provides the lowest latency so at any
given point if performance is your
criteria and at any given point of time
irrespective of what happens in amazon
infrastructure irrespective of what
happens in the internet if you want to
route your users to the best performing
website best performing region then we
would be using latency based dropping
and for using latency based routing we
should create latency records for the
resources in multiple aws regions and
then the other type of
a routing policy is a multi-value
routing policy where we can make route
53 to respond to dns queries with up to
eight healthy records selected at
random so you're not kind of loading one
particular server we can define eight
records and on a random basis route 53
will respond to queries from these eight
records so it's not one server that gets
all the requests but
eight servers
gets the request in a random fashion so
it's multi-value routing policy and what
we get by this is that we are
distributing the traffic to many servers
instead of just one server so
multi-value routing configures route 53
to return multiple values in response to
a single or multiple dns queries it also
checks the health of
order sources and returns the multiple
values only for the healthy resources
let's say out of the eight servers we
have define one server is not doing
healthy it will not respond to the query
with the details of the unhealthy server
right so now it's gonna treat it as only
seven servers in the list because one
server is unhealthy and it has the
ability to return multiple health
checkable ip addresses to improve
availability and
load balancing the other type of routing
policy is weighted routing policy and in
here we use
to route traffic or this is used to
route traffic to multiple resources in a
proportion that we specify so this is an
weighted routing and weighted routing
routes multiple resources to a single
domain name or a sub domain and control
the traffic that's routed to each
resources so this is very useful when
you're doing load balancing and testing
new versions of the software so when you
have a new version of the software you
really don't want to send 100 of the
traffic to it so you want to get
customers feedback about the new
software that you've launched new
version or new application that you've
launched so you would kind of send only
20 of the traffic to that application
get customer feedback and if all is good
then we would move the rest of the
traffic to that new application so any
software launches application launches
will be using weighted routing now let's
talk about the key benefits or key
features of route 53. some of the key
features of route 53 are a traffic flow
it routes end users to the end point
that should provide the best user
experience that's what we discussed in
the routing policies right it uses a
routing policy a latency based routing
policy and jio based routing policy and
then failover routing policy so it kind
of improves the user experience and the
key feature the other key feature of
route 53 is we can buy domain names
using roth 53 using route 53 console we
can buy it from here and use it in route
53 previously it was not the case but
now we can buy it directly from amazon
through route 53 and we can assign it to
any resources that we want so anybody
browsing that url the connection will be
directed to the server in aws that runs
our website a health checks it monitors
health and performance of the
application so it comes with a health
check attached to it health check are
useful to make sure that the unhealthy
resources are retired right the
unhealthy resources are taken away or
your customers are not kind of hitting
the unhealthy resources and they see an
service down page or something like that
we can have weighted
round robin load balancing that's
helpful in spreading
traffic between several services or
servers we are round robin algorithm so
no one server is fully hit or no one
server kind of fully absorbs all the
traffic you know you can shift you can
split and shift the traffic to different
servers based on the weight that you
would be configuring and also weighted
routing also helps with
a soft launch
soft launch of your new application or
the new version of your website there
are different ways we can access amazon
route 53 so you can access amazon route
53 through aws console you can also
access amazon route 53 using aws sdks
and we can access it using we can
configure it using the apis and we can
also do it through the command line
interface that's linux type linux flavor
aws command line interface we can also
do that using windows command line
windows powershell flavored command line
interface as well now let's look at some
of the companies that are using raw 53
so some of the famous companies that use
ralph 53 are
medium medium is an online publishing
platform and
it's more like a social
journalism it's kind of having hybrid
collection of
professionals people and publications or
exclusive
blogs or publishers on medium it's kind
of an blog website and that uses roth53
for the dns service reddit is an uh
social news aggregation or web content
rating and discussion website that uses
rod 53s so these are some websites that
that are accessed throughout the world
and they are using roth53 and it's
highly scalable suddenly there is a new
news right their website will be
accessed a lot and
they need to keep their service up and
running all the time more availability
otherwise
customers will end up in a broken page
and uh the number of customers who will
be using the website will come down so
it's very critical on these sites these
companies are very critical you know
they're being highly available their
page their site being highly available
and the internet is very critical and
crucial for them and they rely and use
route 53 to meet that particular demand
and airbnb is
another company uh instacart cosr is
another company stripe is another
company that uses route53 to as their
dns uh provider for the dns service they
use route 53 so their customers get best
performance they use rod 53 so their
website is highly available they use
route 53 to kind of shift to the traffic
between the resources so their resources
are properly used with all the weighted
routing the resources are properly used
now let's quickly look at a demo i'm in
my aws console and i'm in route 53 so
let me click on rot53 so in this lab
we're actually going to simulate buying
a domain name and then we're going to
create an s3 static website and we're
going to map that website to this
dns name right so the procedure is the
same for mapping load balancer the
procedure is the same for mapping
cloudfront the procedure is the same for
mapping ec2 instances as well we're
picking s3 for simplicity all right but
our focus is actually on route 53. so
let's go in here and we'll see if we can
but we will buy a domain name here so
let's first check the availability of a
domain name called simply learn hyphen
demo hyphen route 53 let's check its
availability it is available for 12 so
let me add it to cart and then come back
here and then once you continue it'll
ask for personal information once you
give the personal information you
finally check out and then it gets added
to your shopping list once you pay for
it amazon takes like 24 to 40 hours to
make that a dns name available so the
next stage would be contact details and
then the third stage would be verify and
purchase so once we have bought the
domain name it will become available in
our dns portal and i do have a domain
name which i bought some time back and
it's now available for me to use so i
can go to hosted zone and simply start
creating i can go to hosted zone and
then here it's going to list all the
domain names for me right click on the
domain name and then click on the record
set and here i can actually map elastic
load balancer s3 website vpc endpoint
api gateway and cloudfront elastic bean
stock domain names right all that gets
mapped through this portal quite simple
like four or five step
button clicks and then it'll be done so
i have an
domain name bot and then i'm going to go
to s3 and i'll show you what i've done
in s3 so i've created a bucket name
called as
a dns name let me clear the content in
them so i've created a bucket and then
permissions i've turned off public
access blocking and then i've created
and a bucket policy so this bucket is
now publicly accessible and then i went
on the properties and created the static
website hosting right and i've pointed
that this is the file that's my index
file that i'm going to put or name of
the file that's going to be my index
file that i'm going to put in this s3
bucket so put the index file.html saved
it
and
we're going to create a file now we're
going to create an index file so this is
a sample code it says amazon.53 getting
started routing internet traffic to s3
bucket for your website and then a
couple of other information so save it
as an
index.html file in my desktop so let me
upload that from my desktop into this
bucket so that's index.html and it's in
capital i so let me go to properties and
go to static website hosting and make
sure that i spell it properly right it's
case sensitive and then save it so now
this means that my website should be
running through this url and it does
it's running to the static website url
we're halfway through so now let me go
back to route 53 go back to route 53 go
back to hosted zones go into the domain
name and then create a record set and
it's going to be an alias record and
i i see my s3 static website endpoint
there right so click on it and create it
has now created an
record that's pointing my domain name to
the s3 endpoint that i have created and
my static website is running from it so
let me test it so let me go to the
browser put the domain name in there and
sure enough the domain name when my
browser queried for the domain name a
route53 returned a response saying this
domain name is actually mapped to the s3
bucket static website hosting enable s3
bucket and this is the url for that
static website hosting and then my
browser was able to connect to that s3
bucket and download the details and show
it in my browser right so it's that
simple and pretty straight forward in
this section we're going to learn about
why we need a solution called cloud
formation or why we need a product
called cloud formation and we're going
to talk in detail about what is cloud
formation and then how cloud formation
works and the concepts involved in cloud
formation like i know templates and
stacks there are some concepts involved
in cloud formation we're going to talk
about that and how do we maintain access
control over the cloud formation we're
going to talk about that as well in this
video and then we're going to go through
a demo or a lab where we create an lamp
stack environment from a template
through cloud formation and then we're
going to talk about some use cases one
of which include being able to create an
redeployable template using cloud
formation that's a very good use case
we're going to talk about that in this
video so let's talk about why cloud
formation so when the number of products
and services grow more and managing them
and
maintaining them
becomes and tedious work and cloud
formation it sort of eases that
environment now cloud formation is
really an infrastructure as a code and
it sort of solves all the problem that
we discussed some time back and with
cloud formation we can actually create a
perfect clone of the server
configuration at any point in time and
we can also manage the configuration
changes and configuration changes with
cloud formation we can manage the
configuration changes across the
environment and not only that we can
easily ember in the ad hoc changes to
our existing environment so one might
ask why use cloud formation let's look
at the current problem that we have
creating and managing multiple aws
resource in the portal is a big task
especially when you need to replace some
services it becomes a bigger task now
cloud formation eases that work let me
explain it in detail now at the moment
without the cloud formation or
environments that don't use cloud
formation have this problem that is a
lot of time is being spent on building
the infrastructure and less focus and
less time at the moment is being given
on developing that application that runs
on that environment that's because
majority of the time is consumed by
building the environment and if we need
to redeploy the same environment again
and again the same happens in a cycle
again in a new environment we start from
the scratch build environment and then
put application on top of it now that
can be avoided using cloud formation now
without cloud formation still is a
problem because the the resource or the
bandwidth that is needed for the
application development is not provided
because that's taken by developing the
infrastructure and to solve that problem
we can use cloud formation now that
leads to a discussion about what is
cloud formation so let's talk about or
let's try understanding what cloud
formation is cloud formation is a
service that provides users a simple way
to create and manage collection of aws
resources by provisioning and updating
them in a very orderly and in a
predictable way if i need to expand
explanation of cloud formation cloud
formation is an service that really
helps us to model and set up our amazon
web services or resources so we can
spend less time on managing the
resources and show more focus on the
application that runs on top of it we
can simply create a template for an ec2
instance or for an rds instance and
upload it in the cloud formation portal
and cloud formation will provision and
configure those resources based on the
template that we define we really don't
have to sort out the complexities in
dependency between those applications
once the template is vetted and
validated cloud formation takes the
responsibility of handling the
dependencies between the application in
an orderly and a predictable way it
creates those services and makes it
available for us once the template is
fully run so in short the cloud
formation it allows us to create and
model our infrastructure and
applications without we having to
perform the manual action for example
the well-known company called expedia is
able to easily manage and run its entire
front and back end resources they run on
aws in cloudfront what does that mean
they are spending less time on managing
infrastructure and more time on the core
business and the application that runs
on top of it and we're still talking
about what cloud formation is with cloud
formation it enables us to manage our
complete infrastructure or aws resource
in a text file now we're going to see
that in a moment you know it's either a
json or an yml file and that file is
called as the template to begin with the
resources the template provision is
called the stack all right so the
abstract of the code is called the
template and the resource that it
provisions is called the stack and this
stack can be i mean it's going to run
resources obviously and those resources
can be updated as well it's not like
once you create a stack it's done if you
need a change you need to go create
another resource that's not needed this
stack is an updatable stack let's say if
i'm including two more servers if i'm
sort of extending my environment it's
branching out to another application now
i'm including another functionality in
my environment all those can be embedded
in the update and can be updated so like
i said the stack is an updatable one now
let's talk about what the template can
do or some features and functionality of
the template now using a template we can
almost include all the application and
resources that a user might require
let's say you know after the easy to
instance is provision running an
application on top of it and you want to
templatize that and include that in the
template that's possible as well and
these templates are portable ones
meaning i can use the template in one
region and i can use the same template
in another region and that's going to
build a very similar environment in
another region i can also share that
with the customer and when they run it
it's going to run an environment from
the portable template in their account
in their environment of course all the
security is taken care i'm just saying
that if we need to build a resource if
you need to build an architecture if you
need to build an environment which looks
very similar to the other environment
that is possible and and these templates
are usable by the use of some sections
in the template like the parameter
section the mapping section the
condition section within the template is
what makes the templates reusable and we
will talk about parameters mapping and
conditions down the line we're still
talking about aws how aws cloud
formation works and we're going to talk
about how a template becomes an
infrastructure right so to begin with
one requires a template and the template
uh would be in json or yml format so one
would develop a template based on the
requirement based on number of ec2
instances based on whether they want a
load balancer based on what they want
and a windows server based on whether
they want an database server in that
environment and then based on the
applications that will be running on top
of it that can be templatized in the
code itself so one creates a code and
then the code is saved locally or they
can be put in an s3 bucket from which
the cloud formation will call the
template and provision the resource
right so we use cloud formation to
create a stack or create the resource
defined in the template and cloud
formation analyzes the template first
validates template and then it
identifies the
dependencies between them and then it
starts provisioning the resource one
after the other for example if you need
a five servers in a new vpc obviously
it's going to create the vpc first and
servers second and stack all right let's
understand the two major components in
cloud formation by now you might have
guessed it the two major components are
the template and the stack together the
aid or the complement cloud formation
and that's how the resource of provision
that's how the resource are managed and
that eases the job of the administrator
who's managing the environment so let's
talk about template first a template in
cloud formation is an text file or a
formatted text file in json or yml
language and that the code or the
template or the text file that actually
describes how your infrastructure looks
like or will look like once provision
and for us to create the template or for
us to
modify an existing template we can use a
tool available called cloud formation
designer from the console or any text
editing tool that's available but i
would recommend the cloud formation
designer though that has rich graphics
in it and these templates are built off
or they consist of nine main objects the
first of which is the format version and
this really identifies the capabilities
of the template based on the version
number and then the second object in a
template would be description and this
helps us to include any arbitrary
comments about the template for what
reason are we building this template
what's the purpose of it stuff like that
and then we have the object called
metadata in a template and that includes
a details about the template details of
the resources in the template and then
we have the optional parameters section
this really helps us to customize our
template now parameters enable us to
input custom values to our template each
time we create or update and stack and
the mapping object it helps us to match
a key to a corresponding set of named
values for example if you want to set a
value based on region then we get to
create a mapping that uses region name
as the key and then the value that we
want to specify for each specific
regions and then we have conditions
object this is again an optional object
with this we can include statements that
define when a resource is created or
when a property is defined for example
we can compare whether a value is equal
to another value and based on the result
of that condition we can conditionally
create additional resources and then the
object called transform it's it's an
optional object as well and this
transform section specifies one or more
transforms that we can use in our cloud
formation template for example uh aws
cloud formation transforms helps
simplify template authoring by
condensing the expression of the aws
infrastructure as a code or the cloud
formation template and it enables reuse
of template components for example we
can condense multiple line resources
declaring it into a single line in our
template now we will talk about all
these examples in the upcoming slides
and then we have the required
section called resource that declares
the aws resource that you want to
include in the stack for example if you
want to include an ec2 instance if you
want to include a necessary bucket we
would be using the resource object in
our stack and then we have object called
output this output object it's an
optional object in the template and it
helps us to sort of
declare the outputs that we can import
into other stacks or
we can actually show it on the cloud
formation console for example if you
want
the output of the or the name of the s3
bucket that got created in response to a
cloudformation template now we can have
that outputted into an output section in
the cloud formation console itself so
it's sort of easy for us to identify the
resources that the template provisioned
so with all of those objects put
together this is how a full-blown cloud
formation template with all the objects
included is going to look like now this
includes optional and mandatory object
let's talk about those objects in detail
in the upcoming section all right let's
now discuss each and every object of
this template structure and let's begin
our discussion with the format version
the format version it really defines the
capabilities of the template the latest
version format version as of now is the
one that was updated on 2010. now the
value of the template format version it
has to be and
string and if we really don't uh specify
the format version cloudformation
automatically assumes the latest version
talking about description descriptions
are really any comments that help
ourselves that we want to ember in the
template itself that can be a
description and this description in a
template it has to be an string length
of the string can be between
0 to 124 bytes in length the metadatas
are really used in the template to
provide any additional information
using the json and yaml objects and
metadata holds some implementation
details of a specific
resource and parameters are really a way
to customize the template each time we
create or update our stack these
parameters are the ones that helps us to
give some custom value to the template
during runtime in the example shown
below the parameter named instance type
parameter it lets us to specify the ec2
instance type for the stacks to use when
creating or updating the stack by
default as we see
it's picking t2 micro and this is the
value that will get picked if we don't
provision
another value to it and mapping mapping
really enables us to map a key to a
corresponding named value that we
specify in a conditional parameter and
also we can detrive the map or to try
the values in the map using the function
find in map instrict function let's take
this example let's say based on a region
if you want to set values in a template
we can create a mapping that uses a key
and holds the value that you want to
specify for each region and the object
conditions can be used when we want to
reuse the templates by creating
resources in a totally different context
for example in a template during stack
creation all the conditions that we
mentioned in the template are evaluated
and any resources that are associated
and that come up to be true are created
and any condition that fails or invalid
are kind of ignored automatically and
the check moves forward to the next
condition and conditional is an optional
object and it includes statement that
define when a resource is created or
when a property is actually defined for
example you can create whether for
example you can compare whether a value
is equal to another value and based on
the result of that condition we can
conditionally create resources if you
have multiple conditions then they are
generally separated with commands
sometimes conditions are very helpful
when we want to create
templates and we want to reuse those
templates which was created for one
environment to another environment for
example if you want to use a template
that was created in a test environment
in a dev environment conditions would be
helpful for example in a production
environment we might want to include
instances with certain capabilities and
in a test environment we might want to
include instances with some reduced
capability in them for saving money and
condition helps us to sort of create
resources based on the environment it
will be used in we can also use
intrinsic functions to define conditions
like equals we can also use r conditions
we can use not functions intrinsic
functions in a condition and when put
together the syntax is going to look
like the one that you see on the screen
now the optional object called transform
it specifies one or more transforms that
the cloud formation uses to process our
template now these transform sections
are built on a simple
declarative language of aws cloud
formation with a powerful macro system
that helps us to
reuse the templates or the template
components and they really help us to
condense or simplify our codes by
enabling reuse of the template
components for example condense a
multiple line resource declaration into
a single line in our template the
resource section it really declares the
aws resource that you want to include in
the stack such as ec2 instance such as
s3 bucket and some of the resource
fields are the logical id the resource
type and the properties let's talk about
them in brief the logical id is unique
within the template and the logical id
name it actually reference the resource
in other parts of the template in this
case it's my bucket for example i know
if you want to map an elastic block
store volume or if you want to map and
name of the bucket in another place in
the template now then we would use the
logical id and again in this case it is
my bucket a logical name has the
physical id with which we actually
assign the resource for example in this
case mys3 bucket was named as mybucket
to begin with and the resource type in
the template it identifies that the type
of the resource is an s3 bucket and the
properties are the additional optional
information that we can specify to our
resource for example if it is an ec2
instance let's say we would like to know
which ami it used then property section
really defines the ami that was used or
ami as the property of the instance so
this section describes the output value
that needs to be imported to other
stacks or the output value that needs to
be shown in the console for the user to
easily navigate to the resource that are
being created for example for a s3
bucket name we can declare an output and
once the bucket is created we can
actually
declare the output and sort of
import the name of the bucket in a
different place in the console so it's
it's easy to view instead of you know
the user getting confused and
going to s3 and searching for the bucket
name this can be made available in the
cloud formation console itself and the
output fields it can include some of
these followings like the logical id uh
it's actually the identifier of the
current output and it's very unique
within the template and it can also
include a description description is
really a string type that describes the
output value and it can also include
value and value is the property that was
returned by the aws cloud formation
describe stacks command all right let's
talk about template
resource attribute in this section we're
going to
talk about
attributes that you can add to a
resource to control additional behavior
and relationships so let's talk there
are many resource attributes available
out of which we have i mean if we need
to name them we have a creation policy
and then we have deletion policy it
depends on metadata attribute update
policy attribute let's talk about each
of them separately when we associate the
create policy attribute with the
resource it actually delays the resource
configuration actions before proceeding
with the stack creation i mean the
attribute stack creation is delayed till
the time the cloud formation receives
some number of success signals back i
mean this is a very good use case when
we do auto scaling
and this creation policy can be used
only with a
limited number of services like auto
scaling and ec2 instances
some of the use cases would be if you
want to install and software application
on an ec2 instance you might want the
applications to be running before it
proceeds further so in this case we
would use the creation policy attribute
to the instance and then send the
success signal after the applications
are installed and configured then cloud
formation goes to the next step here in
the syntax that we're looking at the
auto scaling creation policy and the
minimum successful instance percentage
it's actually a number of signals that
it will have to reply back before it can
move forward using deletion policy it
preserves backing up of resources when
the stack is getting
deleted and by default if you don't have
a delete policy the uh data gets deleted
just like that but if you use an
deletion policy we would be able to
preserve the data by taking a snapshot
of it or
just letting the resource and moving on
with deleting the other resources in the
stack and we specify the delete policy
attribute for each resource specifically
that we want to control and if there are
no deletion policy mentioned for a
particular resource the cloud formation
simply deletes the resources as that's
its default behavior and if you want to
keep the resource when the stack is
deleted we use we we mention retain in
the delete policy and that simply
retains the resource from getting
deleted so in this example we're
actually retaining a dynamodb table rest
of the resources in the stack will get
deleted and using that depends on
attribute
we actually
create a an order in which the resource
gets deleted for example if i map one
resource to another resource and say
that this resource depends on the other
resource the other resource gets created
first then followed by this instance or
this resource so with the depends on
attribute we can specify that the
creation of specific resource is
actually followed by an another when we
add the depends on attribute to a
resource the resource is created only
after the creation of the resource
specified by the depends on attribute
let's take this example in this example
we're saying that the resource x
depends on y we've said that x depends
on y so in this case when cloud
formation is executing it's going to
deploy y first because it has some
resources that depends on it so it's
going to create y first and then it's
going to create the resource called x on
the same context let's say in the
template we say that an ec2 is going to
depend on s3 and when the cloud
formation is executing it's going to
create an s3 bucket first and then the
ec2 instant that's probably because the
codes needed for the ec2 instance are
stored in the s3 bucket and and what
we're looking at is the syntax of how
the depends on template resource
attribute will look like this is how it
actually will look like when we put it
in the cloud formation the instance
depends on the bucket the other template
resource attribute is metadata metadatas
are the one that really helps us to
associate our resources with the the
structured data and by including this
attribute in our template or by
including this attribute to a resource
we can specify the data in json or in
yaml language for example in this
section of the template we're creating a
vpc and the metadata explains or
metadata defines that the vpc is part of
the region us east one and the update
policy template resource attribute and
cloud formation we can manage and
replace the updates of the instance in
an auto scaling group for example you're
looking at this uh sample where it says
that the update policy will it replace
the instance in an auto scaling group or
not so depending on what the value is
for the will replace section whether
it's true or false depending on that the
update policy will replace the instance
or will replace the auto scaling group
itself when it's doing and rolling
deployment now that we've discussed
about templates let's talk about aws
stacks as well now we know that aws
stacks are the actual resources that
gets generated or that gets created
because we ran a template right so stack
is a collection of aws results that we
can manage in a single unit in other
words you know we can create a stack
update a stack or delete a stack and
that would actually create update delete
the collection of resources within the
stack and all the resources in the stack
are really defined by the cloud
formation template and a stack for
instance can include all the resources
required to run a web application such
as a web server a database server and
some networking rules that come along
with it all that gets embedded in a
stack and let's say if we want to delete
all the resources that were created by
template that is in a separate stack we
can simply delete the stack and that
would sort of delete all the resources
that is in the stack so it sort of helps
us to manage all the resources in a
single unit or as a single unit so to
summarize stack is a collection of aws
resource and it can be managed as a
single unit and the cloud formations
template defines a stack in which the
resource can be created deleted or
updated in a very predictable way and a
stack can have all the resources like
web server database server vpc the
network and the security configurations
in a vpc all that is required to run a
web or a database application now stack
could be nested as well with cloud
formation we can actually
nest a stack with another stack and
that's going to create an hierarchy of
the stacks for example i mean this is a
very good picture that explains how the
stacks are nested in a hierarchical way
let's say stack p is the uh root stack
and that could be apparent stack for the
stack called r and the stack call cube
and the same way the the stack called r
is a parent stack for the stack s and
the stack s is the pattern stack for d
and q you get that right so stacks can
always be nested it's possible
cloudformation allows us to create a
microsoft windows stack based on amazon
ec2 windows amis and provide us with the
ability to install software and use
remote desktop to access our stack and
update the configuration of our stack
and these stacks can be run on windows
server instances there are a number of
pre-configured templates available and
it's directly available to use from the
aws website itself to name a few we have
templates available for sharepoint
running on an uh windows server 2008 r2
we also have templates that create a
single server installation of active
directory running on a windows server
and in fact we have templates available
for elastic bean stock and some sample
applications that runs from an windows
server 2008 r2 let's talk about stack
sets stack sets actually has taken the
stack level implementation to the next
level using the aws cloud formation
template we can define a stack set that
lets us to create stack in aws account
across the globe by using just a single
template and after we create the stack
or after the stack set is defined
creating updating or deleting the stack
in the target account and the regions
can also be specified by us so the stack
said it really extends the functionality
of the stacks by allowing us to create
update and delete stack across multiple
accounts regions in just a single
operation and using an administrator
account we can define and manage an aws
cloud formation template and use the
template as the basis for provisioning
stacks into you know some selected
target accounts across a specified
region let's talk about cloud formation
access control with im i can specify the
list of users or list of privileged
users who would have access to the
cloudformation template who can create
update and delete stack so that's how im
helps me with having or putting a layer
of control over the cloud formation
service and we can also use service
roles service roles are the one that
allows aws cloud formation to make a
call to a resource in a stack on the
user's behalf and i can also have stack
policies and these stack policies are
applied to the users who already have
access to the cloud formation service
and these policies are the ones that
help the users who attempt to update the
stack in this session we would like to
talk about some basics about aws and
then we're going to immediately dive
into why amazon ecs
and what is amazon ecs in general and
then it uses a service called docker so
we're going to understand what docker is
and there are competitive services
available for ecs i mean you could ecs
is not the on and only service to manage
docker containers but why ecs advantage
of ecs we will talk about that and the
architecture of ezs so how it functions
what are the components present in it
and
what are the functions that it does i
mean each and every component what are
all the functions that it does all those
things will be discussed in the
architecture of amazon acs and how it
works how it all connects together
that's something we will discuss and
what are the companies that are using
ecs what were the challenge and how ecs
helped to fix the challenge that's
something we will discuss and finally we
have a wonderful lab that talks about
how to deploy docker containers on an
amazon ecs so let's talk about what is
aws
amazon web service in short called as
aws is an web service in the cloud that
provides a variety of services such as
compute power database storage content
delivery and a lot of other resources so
you can scale your business and grow not
focus more on your it needs and the rest
of the id demands rather you can focus
on your business and let amazon scale
your it or let amazon take care of your
it so what is that you can do with aws
with aws we can create deploy any
application in the cloud so it's not
just deploying you can also
create your application in the cloud it
has all the tools and services required
the tools and services that you would
have installed in your laptop or you
would have installed in your on-premises
desktop machine for your development
environment you know the same thing can
be
installed and used from the cloud so you
can use cloud for creating and not only
that you can use the same cloud for
deploying and making your application
available for your end user the end user
could be internal internal users the end
user could be the could be in the
internet the end user could be kind of
spread all around the world it doesn't
matter so it can be used
to create and deploy your applications
in the cloud and like you might have
guessed now it provides service over the
internet that's how your users worldwide
would be able to use the service that
you create and deploy right so it
provides service
over the internet so that's for the end
customer and how will you access those
services that's again through the
internet
it's like the extension of your data
center in the internet so it provides
all the services in the internet it
provides compute service through the
internet so in other words you access
them through the internet it provides
database service through the internet
over the internet in other words you can
securely access your database through
the internet and lot more and the best
part is this is
a pay as you go or pay only for what you
use there is no long term or you know
beforehand commitment uh here most of
the services does not have any
commitment so there is no long-term and
beforehand commitment you only pay
exactly for
what you use there's no overage there's
no overpaying right there's no buying in
advance right you only pay for what you
use let's talk about what ecs is so
before ecs before containers right ecs
is a service that manages docker
containers right it's not a product or
it's not a feature all by itself it's a
service that's dependent on docker
container so before docker containers
all the applications were running on vm
or on a host or on a physical machine
right and that's memory bound that's
latency bound the server might have
issues on and on right so let's say this
is alice and she's trying to access her
application which is running somewhere
in her on premises and the application
isn't working what could be the reason
some of the reasons could be memory full
the server is currently down at the
moment we don't have another physical
server to launch the application a lot
of other reasons so a lot of reasons why
the application wouldn't be working in
on premises some of them are memory full
issue and server down issue very less
high availability or in fact single
point of failure and no high
availability if i if i need to tell it
correctly with easiest the services can
kind of breathe free right the services
can run seamlessly now how how is that
possible those thing we will discuss in
the upcoming sessions so because of
containers and ecs managing containers
the applications can run in a high
available
mode they can run in a high available
mode meaning if something goes wrong
right there's another container that
gets spun up and
your application runs in that particular
container very less chances of your
application going down that's what i
mean this is not possible with
a physical
host this is very less possible with an
vm or at least it's going to take some
time for another vm to get spun up so
why ec is or what is ecs amazon ecs
maintains the availability of the
application and allows every user to
scale containers when necessary so it
not only meets the availability of the
application meaning one container
running your application or one
container hosting your application
should be running all the time so to
meet that high availability availability
is making sure your service is running
24 7. so container makes sure that your
services run 24 bar 7 not only that not
only that suddenly there is an increase
in demand how do you meet that demand
right let's say you have like thousand
users suddenly the next week there are
like 2000 users all right so how do you
meet that demand container makes it very
easy for you to meet that demand in case
of vm or in case of physical host you
literally will have to go buy another
physical host or
add more ram add more memory add more
cpu power to it all right or kind of
club two three hosts together clustering
you would be doing a lot of other things
to meet that high availability and also
to meet that demand but in case of
ecs it automatically scales the number
of containers it automatically scales
the number of containers needed and it
meets your demand for that particular r
so what is amazon
ecs the full form of ecs is elastic
container service right so it's
basically a container management service
which can quickly launch and exit and
manage docker containers on a cluster so
it's the function of ecs it helps us to
quickly launch and quickly exit and
manage docker container so it's kind of
a management service for the docker
containers you will be running in
amazon or running in the aws environment
so in addition to that it helps to
schedule the placement of container
across your cluster so it's like this
you have two physical hosts you know
joined together as a cluster and ecs
helps us to place your containers now
where should your container be placed
should it be placed in host 1 should be
placed in host 2. so that logic is
defined in ecs we can define it you can
also let ecs
take control and define that logic most
cases you will be defining it so
schedule the placement of containers
across your cluster let's say two
containers want to interact heavily you
really don't want to place them in two
different hosts right you would want to
place them in one single hole so they
can interact with each other so that
logic is defined by us and these
container services you can launch
containers using aws management console
and also you can launch containers using
sdk kits available from amazon you can
launch through a java program you can
launch container using n.net program you
can launch container using an node.js
program as in when the situation demands
so there are multiple ways you can
launch containers through management
console and also programmatically and
ecs also helps to migrate application to
the cloud without changing the code so
anytime you think of migration the first
thing that comes to your mind is that
how will that environment be based on
that i'll have to alter my code what's
what's the ip what is the storage that's
being used what what are the different
parameters i'll have to include the
environment parameters of the new
environment with containers now that
worry is already taken away because we
can create and pretty exact environment
that the one that you had an on-premises
the same environment gets created in the
cloud so
no worries about changing the
application parameter no worries about
changing the code in the application
right you can be like if it ran in my
laptop a container that i was running in
my laptop it's definitely going to run
in the cloud as well because i'm going
to use the same container in the laptop
and also in the cloud in fact you're
going to ship it you're going to move
the container from your laptop to amazon
ecs and make it run there so it's like
the same the very same image the very
same container that was running in your
laptop will be running in the
cloud or production environment so what
is docker we know that it ecs helps to
quickly launch exit and manage docker
containers what is docker let's let's
answer that question what is docker now
docker is a tool
that helps to automate the development
of an application as a lightweight
container so that the application can
work efficiently in different
environments this is pretty much what we
discussed right before the slide i can
build an application in my laptop or in
on premises in a container environment
docker container environment and anytime
i want to migrate right i don't have to
kind of rewrite the code and then rerun
the code in that new environment i can
simply create an image a docker image
and move that image to that production
or the new cloud environment and simply
launch it there right so no compiling
again no relaunching the application
simply pack all your code in a docker
container image and ship it to the new
environment and launch the container
there that's all so docker container is
a light weight package of software that
contains all the dependencies so because
you know when packing you'll be packing
all the dependencies you'll be packing
the code you'll be packing the framework
you'll be packing the libraries that are
required to run the application so in
the new environment you can be pretty
sure you can be guaranteed that it's
gonna run because it's the very same
code it's the very same framework it's
the very same libraries that you have
shipped right there's nothing new in
that new environment it's the very same
thing that's gonna run in that container
so you can be rest assured that they are
going to run in that new environment and
these docker containers are highly
scalable and they are very efficient
suddenly you wanted like 20 more docker
containers to run the application think
of adding 20 more hosts 20 more vms
right how much time would it take and
compared to that time the amount of time
that docker containers would require to
kind of scale to that amount like 20
more containers it's very less or it's
minimal or negligible so it's an highly
scalable and it's a very efficient
service you can suddenly scale number of
docker containers to meet any additional
demand very short boot up time because
it takes a it's not going to load the
whole operating system and these docker
containers you know they use the
linux kernel and features of the kernel
like c groups and name spaces to kind of
segregate the processors so they can run
independently any environment and it
takes very less time
to boot up and the data's that are
stored in the containers are kind of
reusable so you can have an external
data volume and i can map it to the
container and whatever the
space that's occupied by the container
and the data that the container puts in
that volume they are kind of reusable
you can simply remap it to another
application you can kind of remap it to
the next successive container you can
kind of remap it to the next version of
the container next version of the
application you'll be launching and you
don't have to go through building the
data again from the scratch whatever
data the container was using previously
or the previous container was using that
data is available for the next container
as well so the volumes that the
containers uses are very
reusable volumes and like i said it's
isolated application so it kind of
isolates by its nature it kind of by the
way it's designed by the way it is
created it isolates one container from
another container meaning anytime you
run applications on different containers
you can be rest assured that they are
very much isolated though they are
running on the same host though they are
running on the same laptop let's say
though they are running on the same
physical machine let's say running 10
containers 10 different applications you
can be sure that they are
well disconnected or well isolated
applications now let's talk about the
advantages of ecs the advantage of ecs
is improved security its security is
inbuilt in ecs with ecs we have
something called as a container registry
you know that's where
all your images are stored and those
images are accessed only through https
not only that those images are actually
encrypted and access to those images are
allowed and denied through identity and
access management policies iam and in
other words let's say two container
running on the same instance now one
container can have access to s3 and the
others or the rest of the others are
denied access to s3 so that kind of
granular security can be achieved
through containers when we mix and match
the other security products available in
amazon like iam encryption accessing it
using https these containers are very
cost efficient like i've already said
these are lightweight
processes right we can schedule multiple
containers on the same node and this
actually allows us to achieve high
density on an ec2 instance
imagine an ec2 instance that that's very
less utilized that's not possible with a
container because you can actually dens
or crowd an ec2 instance with more
container in it so to best use those
resources in ec2 straightforward you can
just launch one application but with
when we use containers you can launch
like 10 different applications on the
same ec2 server that means 10 different
applications can actually feed on those
resources available and can benefit the
application and ecs not only deploys the
container it also maintains the state of
the containers and it makes sure that
the minimum a set of containers are
always running based on the requirement
that's another cost
efficient way of using it right and
anytime an application fails and that
has a direct impact on the revenue of
the company and is just make sure that
you're not losing any revenue because
your application has failed and easies
and pretty extensible services it's like
this in many organizations there are
majority of unplanned work
because of environment variation a lot
of firefighting happens when we kind of
deploy the code from one or kind of move
the core or redeploy the code in a new
environment a lot of firefighting
happens there right this docker
containers are pretty extensible like we
discussed already environment is not a
concern for containers because
it's going to kind of shut itself inside
a docker container and anywhere the
docker container can run the application
will run exactly the way it performed in
the past so
environment is not a concern for the
docker containers in addition to that
ecs is
easily scalable we have discussed this
already and it improves
it has improved compatibility we have
discussed this already let's talk about
the architecture of ecs like you know
now the architecture of ecs is the ecs
cluster itself that's group of servers
running the ecs service and it
integrates with docker right so we have
a docker registry docker registry is a
repository where we store all the docker
images or the container images so it's
like three components ecs is of three
components one is the ecs cluster itself
right when i say easy as itself i'm
referring to easiest cluster cluster of
servers that will run the containers and
then the repository where the images
will be stored
right the repository where the images
will be stored and the image itself so
container image is the template of
instructions which is used to create a
container right so it's like what's the
os what is the version of node that
should be running and any additional
software do we need so those question
gets answered here so it's the template
template of instructions which is used
to create the containers and then the
registry is the service where the docker
images are stored and shared so many
people can store there and many people
can access or if there's another group
that wants to access they can access the
image from there or one person can store
the image and rest of the team can
access and the rest of the team can
store image and this one person can pick
the image from there and kind of ship it
to the customer or ship it to the
production environment all that's
possible in this container registry and
amazon's version of the container
registry is ecr and there's a third
party docker itself has a container
registry that's docker hub ecs itself
which is the the group of servers that
runs those containers so these two the
container image and the container
registry they kind of handle docker in
an image format just an image format and
in ecs is where the container gets live
and then it becomes and compute resource
and starts to handle requests and starts
to serve the page and starts to do the
batch job you know whatever your plan is
with that container so the cluster of
servers ecs integrates well with the
familiar services like vpc vpc is known
for securing vpc is known for
isolating the whole environment from
rest of the customers or isolating the
whole environment or the whole
infrastructure
from the rest of the clients in your
account or from the rest of the
applications in your account on and on
so vpc is a service that provides or
gives you the network isolation ecs
integrates well with vpc and this vpc
enables us to launch aws resources such
as amazon ec2 instance in a virtual
private network that we specify this is
basically what we just discussed now
let's take a closer look at
the ecs how does ecs work let's find
answer for this question how does ecs
work ecs has got a couple of components
within itself so these ecs servers can
run across availability zone as you can
see there are two availability zones
here they can actually run across
availability zones and ecs has got two
modes fargate mode and ec2 mode right
here we're seeing forget mode and then
here we're seeing nothing that means
it's an ec2 mode and then it has got
different network interfaces attached to
it because they need to be running in an
isolated fashion right so anytime you
want network isolation you need separate
ip and if you want separate ip you need
separate network interface card and
that's what you have elastic network
interface card separate elastic network
interface card for all those tasks and
services and this runs within an vpc
let's talk about the far gate service
tasks are launched using the far gate
service so we will discuss about task
what is fargate now fargate is a compute
engine in ecs that allows users to
launch containers without having to
monitor the cluster ecs is a service
that manages the containers for you
right otherwise managing containers will
be and full-time job so easy manages it
for you and if you and you get to manage
ecs that's the basic service but if you
want amazon to manage ecs and the
containers for you we can go for fargate
so farget is a compute engine in ecs
that allows users to launch containers
without having to monitor the ecs
cluster and the tasks the tasks that we
discussed the tasks has two components
you see
task right here so they have two
components we have
ecs container instance
and then the container agent so like you
might have guessed right now ecs
container instance is actually an ec2
instance right capable of running
containers not all ec2 instances can run
containers so these are like specific
ec2 instances that can run containers
they are ecs container instances and
then we have container agent which is
the agent that actually binds those
clusters together and it does a lot of
other housekeeping work right kind of
connects clusters makes sure that
the version
needed is present so it's all part of
that agent or it's all job of that agent
container instances container instances
is part of amazon ec2 instance which run
amazon ecs container agent pretty
straightforward definition and then a
container agent is responsible for
communication between ecs and the
instance and it also provides the status
of the running containers kind of
monitors the container monitors the
state of the container make sure that
the content is up and running and if
there's anything wrong it kind of
reports it to the appropriate service to
fix the container on and on it's a
container agent when we don't manage
container agent it runs by itself and
you really don't have to do anything to
make the container agent better it's
already better you really won't be
configuring anything in the agent and
then elastic network interface card is
in virtual interface network that can be
connected to an instance in vpc so in
other words elastic network interface is
how the container interacts with another
container and that's how the container
interacts with the ec2 host and that's
how the container interacts with the
internet external world and a cluster a
cluster is a set of
ecs container instances it's not
something that's very difficult to
understand it's simply a group of ec2
instances that runs that ecs agent and
this cluster in cluster handles the
process of scheduling monitoring and
scaling the request we know that ecs can
scale the containers can scale how does
it scale that's all monitored and
managed by this ecs cluster let's talk
about the companies that are using
amazon ecs there are a variety of
companies that use
ecs clusters to name a few octa users
easiest cluster and octa is a product
that use identity information to grant
people access to applications on
multiple devices at any
given point of time they make sure that
they have a very strong security
protection so okta uses amazon ecs to
run their octa application and serve
their customers and abima abhima is an
uh tv channel and they chose to use
microservices and
docker containers they already had
microservices and docker containers and
when they thought about a service that
they can use in aws ecs was the only
service that they can immediately adapt
to and because in abima tv the engineers
have already been using docker and
docker containers it was kind of easy
for them to adapt themselves to ecs and
start using it along with the benefits
that ecs provides previously they had to
do a lot of work but now ecs does it for
them all right similarly remind and
ubisoft gopro are some of the famous
companies that use amazon ecs and get
benefited from its scalability get
benefited from its cost gets benefited
from its amazon managed services get
benefited from the portability that ecs
and the migration option that ecs
provides let's talk about how to deploy
a docker container on amazon acs the way
to deploy docker container on ecs is
first we need to have an aws account and
then set up and run our first ecs
cluster so in our lab we're going to use
the launch wizard to run an ecs cluster
and run containers in them and then task
definition task definition tells the
size of the container the number of the
container and when we talk about size it
tells how much of cpu do you need how
much of memory do you need and talking
about
numbers you know it requires how many
numbers of container you're going to
launch you know is it 5 is it 10 or is
it just one running all the time now
those kind of information goes in the
task definition file and then we can do
some advanced configuration on ecs like
load balancers and you know what port
number you want to allow and you don't
want to allow you know who gets access
who shouldn't get access and what's the
ip that you want to allow and deny
requests from on and on and this is
where we would also mention the name of
the container so to differentiate one
container from the other and the name of
the service you know is it and a backup
job is it a web application is it a data
container
is it going to take care of your data
data backend and the desired number of
tasks that you want to be running all
the time those details go in when we try
to configure the ecs service right and
then you configure cluster you put in
all the security in the configure your
cluster step or configure cluster stage
and finally we will have an
instance and bunch of containers running
in that instance all right let's do a
demo so here i have logged in to my
amazon portal and let me switch to the
appropriate region i'm going to pick not
virginia north virginia look for ecs and
it tells ecs as a service that helps to
run and manage docker containers well
and good click on it i'm in north
virginia just want to make sure that i'm
in the right region and go to clusters
and here we can create cluster this is
our far gate and this is our ec2 type
launching for linux and windows
environment but i'm going to launch
through this
walkthrough portal right this gives a
lot of information here so the different
steps involved here is creating a
container definition which is what we're
going to do right now and then a task
definition and then service and finally
the cluster it's a four step process so
in container definition we define the
image the base image we are going to use
now here i'm going to launch an
httpd or a simple http web page right so
a simple httpd 2.4 image is fair enough
for me and it's not a heavy application
so 0.5 gigabit of memory is enough and
again it's not a heavy application so
0.25 virtual cpu is enough in our case
right you can edit it based on the
requirement you can always edit it and
because i'm using httpd the port mapping
is already port 80 that's how the
container is going to receive the
request and there's no health check as
if now when we want to design critical
and complicated environments
we can include health check right and
this is the cpu that we have chose we
can edit it and i'm going to use some
bash commands to
create an html page right this page says
that you know amazon ecs sample app
right and then it says amazon ecs sample
app your application is running on a
container in amazon ecs so that's the
page the html page that i'm going to
create or index.html so i'm going to
create and put it in an appropriate
location so those pages can be served
from the container right if you replace
this with any of your own content then
it's going to be your own content ecs
comes with some basic
logs and these are the places where they
get stored that's not the focus as of
now all right so i was just saying that
you can edit it and customize it to your
needs we're not going to do any
customization now we're just getting
familiar with ecs now and the task
definition
name of the task definition is uh first
one task definition and then
we are running it in a vpc and then this
is an far gate mode meaning the servers
are completely handled by amazon and the
task memory is 0.5 gigabit and the tar
cpu is 0.25 virtual cpu name of the
service
is it a batch job is it an you know a
front end is it a back end or is it a
simple copy job what's the service name
of the service goes here again this you
can edit it and here's a security group
as of now i'm allowing 480 to the whole
world if i want to restrict to a certain
ip i can do that the default option for
load balancing is a no load balancer but
i can also choose to have a load
balancer and use port 80 to map that 480
to the container port 80 right i can do
that the default is no load balancer all
right let's do one thing let's use load
balancer let's use load balancer and
port 80 as it receives information on
port 80 http uh what's going to be the
cluster name we're in the last step what
is the cluster name cluster name can be
simply learn ecs demo next we done and
we can create so it's launching a
cluster as you can see and it's picking
the task definition file that we've
created and it's using that to launch
and service and then these are the log
groups that we discussed and it's
creating your vpc remember ecs clubs
well with the vpc it's creating a vpc
and it's creating two subnets here for
high availability it's creating that
security group port 80 allowed to the
whole world and then it's putting it
behind and load balancer it generally
would take like five to ten minutes so
we just need to be patient and let it
complete its creation and once this is
complete we can simply access the
servers using the load balancer url and
when this is running let me actually
take you to
the other products or the other services
that are integrated with the ecs it's
getting created our service is getting
created as of now ecr repository this is
where all our images are stored now as
of now i'm not pulling my image from ecr
i'm pulling it directly from the
internet docker docker hub but all
custom images all custom images they are
stored in this repository so you can
create a repository call it app1 create
a repository so here's my repository so
any image that i create
locally or any docker image that i
create locally i can actually push them
push those images using these commands
right here and they get stored here and
i can make my ecs connect with ecr and
pull images from here so they would be
my custom images and as of now because
i'm using a default image it's directly
pulling it from the internet let's go to
ec2 and look for a load balancer because
we wanted to access the application from
behind
a load balancer right so here is a load
balancer created for us
and anytime i put the url so cluster is
now created you see there's one service
running all right let's click on that
cluster here is the name of our
application and here is the
tasks the different containers that
we are running and if you click on it we
have an ip right ip of that container
and it says it's running it was created
at such and such time and started at
such and such time and this is the task
definition file that it this container
uses meaning the template the details to
all the version details they all come
from here and it belongs to the cluster
called
simply learn ecs demo right and you can
also get some logs container logs from
here so let's go back and there are no
ecs instances here because remember this
is forget you're not managing any ecs
instance all right so that's why you're
not seeing any ecs instance here so
let's go back to tasks and
go back to
the same page where we found the ip pick
that ip put it in the browser and you
have this sample html page running from
an
container so let me go back to load
balancer ec2 and then under ec2 i'll be
able to find a load balancer find that
load balancer pick that dns name put it
in the browser and now it's accessible
to the load balancer url right now this
url can be mapped to other services like
dns this url can be embedded in any of
your application if you want to make
that application connect with this
container now using ip is not all that
advisable because these containers can
die and then a new container gets
created and when a new container gets
created it gets a new ip right so a hard
coding ip is
not hardcoding dynamic ips are not
advisable so you would be using load
balancer and putting that url in that
application that you want to make it
interact with this container instance it
was a wonderful experience in walking
you through this ecs topic and in here
we learn about what aws is and why we're
using ecs
and what is easiest in general what is
docker in specific and we also learn
about the advantages of ecs the
architecture the different components of
ecs and how ecs works
when they're all connected together and
we also looked at the companies that use
ecs and their use cases and finally a
lab how we can launch ecs fargate
through the portal
in this section we're going to take a
look at amazon dynamodb
amazon dynamodb is a fast flexible nosql
database service for all applications
that need consistent single-digit
millisecond latency at any scale
so basically it's a fully managed nosql
database that's suitable for document
and key value store models
it's perfect for mobile web gaming ad
tech etc
let's take a look at some of the
benefits of dynamodb
firstly it's always stored on ssd
storage
so you get great disc throughput
it's also spread across three
geographically distinct data centers so
you get high availability built in
it's fast and flexible
and it's suited for read heavy
applications and it's worth remembering
that because you might see questions
saying i have a read intensive
application with a database what should
i use and dynamodb would be the answer
dynamodb offers two different
reconsistency types
the first is eventually consistent reads
which is the default and then they're
strongly consistent reads
so what does this mean
well when you write something to your
dynamodb
the changes have to be replicated to the
three geographically distinct data
centers on which dynamodb is being
stored and obviously this isn't instant
i mean it takes a couple of seconds or
less but it takes some time
so you can choose your read consistency
depending on whether you want users to
be guaranteed to have the correct data
or whether on occasions when they run a
query they might not get the latest
up-to-date version
eventually consistent reads which is the
default
means that consistency is usually
reached within one second and repeating
a read after a short time should return
the correct data
and it gives the best read performance
but there is the danger of something
called dirty reads which is where you
might request a read and you might not
get the latest up-to-date data if it's
essential that your application gets the
latest and correct data then you can
enable strongly consistent reads and
this guarantees that all rights have
committed prior to the read taking place
so it could result in a delay to your
results being returned
dynamodb is charged using something
called provisioned throughput capacity
when you create a dynamodb table you
define the capacity that you want to
reserve for reads and writes for right
throughput there's a charge per hour for
every 10 units of write capacity
and this equates to 36 000 writes per
hour
for read throughput there's a charge per
hour for every 50 units of read capacity
and this equates to 180 000 strongly
consistent reads or 360 000 eventually
consistent reads
what this shows is that dynamodb can be
expensive for rights but cheap for reads
so if your application has lots of reads
little rights and wants to be scalable
then you should be looking at dynamodb
rather than rds
there's also a storage cost per gigabyte
for the amount of data you use with
dynamodb
and here's a very brief real-life case
study
duolingo the online language learning
site uses dynamodb to store 31 billion
items for their online learning site
and they deliver lessons in 80 different
languages
and their application hits 24 000 read
units per second and 3 300 right units
per second so you can see this is a very
read heavy application and is perfect
for dynamodb
in this demonstration we're going to
take a very quick look at dynamodb
so we go to the database section and
we'll find dynamodb which is the manage
nosql database provided by aws
so we'll click on that we're taken to
the dashboard i have no dynamodb tables
so we need to create a new table
and we need to give it a name so let's
call this
simply learn
underscore
users that's going to be the name of our
table we have to give it a key so a
primary key so i'm going to put in last
name
because that's going to be the primary
key for this particular table and that's
going to be a string
now down here we have table settings so
we can use the default settings and it
says no secondary indexes his provision
capacity is set to five reads and five
rights and has basic alarms with 80
other thresholds so if an alarm if one
of your read or write capacities is
greater than 80 of what you've set then
you'll get an alert
so if we untick this you can see
we're not going to take a look at
secondary indexes but the thing that's
important is here we can change to read
and write capacity units
so if we set it both to one we'll get an
estimated cost of just 59 cents a month
there conversely if we push this way up
let's push it up to a thousand then you
see it's 580 dollars a month so it's
fully scalable and you just will pay for
what you need so let's just set this to
one and one because this is just a
demonstration
and we'll click on create table
okay so the table's being created
okay so our table has been created
so here we can see the details of it and
its creation date
so what we now need to do is we can add
items to our table so we click on the
items tab
okay and we need to create an item so
you see this is now this should look
familiar to you because we're basically
doing json code which is the same as for
the policies in the i am lesson so we
get to stick in a last name so let's put
let's put me in so stick weaver and then
we can add
more values to append let's append a
string and we'll put a
first name
and we'll put my name in there
and we could put more information if we
wanted but we're just going to leave it
as that so we click on save
and there we are so now i'm in there so
i'll click on create item
and let's add a new user in here so
we'll call the last name smith
let's add another string so i'll have a
new field called first name
and we'll call this person
wendy
and
we'll add another row let's put a string
in there and we'll call this uh position
so this shows what you can do with nosql
you can basically just keep
changing things and each row can be
different so we're going to enter the
position of manager and we'll click save
so now we can see that
it's different so you can do whatever
you want basically you can add as much
or as little information to each row as
you wanted
now you can also do a search so if we
wanted to add a filter we could say
search for last name
we have a string that equals
and there we are so we have weaver mark
and just to clear that we just remove
that and click on start search again so
that gives you a very basic overview of
what you can do with nosql there's
unstructured data and you can add as
much or as little as you want some other
things to look at the metrics tab
here you can see
your read and write capacity what's
actually happening so you can see
whether you're paying too much or if you
need to be paying too much more
as the alarms alarms that we talked
about so they were set up for us some
basic alarms if the threshold goes over
0.08 reads or writes
for a 12 minute period will get notified
and here's the capacity so this is the
thing that you'll see in the exam
is that dynamodb you can just change
your capacity and as and when you want
on the fly so
our table is up and running but we could
just say we want five read capacity
units and five right capacity units
click save and we're done it's up and
running straight away
and if you knew how much you wanted and
you had a table that you were going to
be using for a prolonged period like a
couple of years you can click on reserve
capacity on the left hand side
and you can purchase reserve capacity
and you'll get some significant
discounts by doing that so if you know
you have a table that's going to have
some heavy reads and writes going
forward you would purchase reserve
capacity
okay so it's a very basic overview of
dynamodb you just need to remember that
it's instantly scalable
and it's a nosql database
so today's session is on aws elastic
beanstalk so what's in it for you today
we'll be discussing about what is aws
why we require aws elastic bean stock
what is aws elastic bean stock the
advantages disadvantages the components
of uh mean stock along with that the
architecture and the companies that are
primarily using the aws bean stock so
let's get started and first understand
what is aws aws stands for amazon web
services uh it's a cloud provider and
that offers a variety of services such
as compute power database storage
content delivery and many other
resources so we know that aws is the
largest cloud provider in the market and
so many services are available in the
aws where you can apply the business
logics and create the solutions using
the cloud platforms now why aws elastic
bean stock now what happened earlier and
uh that whenever the developer used to
create the software or the modules
related to the softwares it has to be
joined together to create a big
application now one developer creates a
module that has to be shared with
another developer and if the developers
are geographically separated then it has
to be shared over a medium probably an
internet so that is going to take some
time uh it would be a difficult process
and in return it makes the application
or a software development a lender
process the building of the software
development lender process so there were
challenges which the developers were
facing earlier and to overcome that
we have the beanstalk as a service
available in the aws so why aws elastic
bean stock is required
aws elastic being stock has made the
life of the developers quite easy
in terms of that they can share the
applications across different devices at
a shorter time duration now let's
understand what is aws elastic bean
stock
aws elastic bean stock is a service
which is used to deploy and scale web
applications by developers not only web
application any application that is
being developed by the developers this
is a simple representation of the aws
elastic bean stock now along with that
the aws elastic bean stock supports the
programming language the runtime
environments that are java.net php
nodejs python rubygo and docker and in
case if you're looking for any other
programming language or a runtime
environment then you can make a request
with aws to arrange that for you now
what are the advantages associated with
the elastic bean stock first advantage
is that it's a highly scalable service
now when we talk about the scalability
it means that whenever we require the
resources in demand we can scale up the
resources or we can scale down the
resources so that is kind of a
flexibility we get in terms of changing
the type of resources whenever we need
it and in that case the elastic bean
stock is a highly scalable service now
that is something which is very
difficult to achieve in case of an
on-prem environments because you have to
plan for the infrastructure and in case
if you're short of the resources within
that infrastructure then you have to
procure it again the second advantage
associated with the beanstalk is that
it's a fast and simple to begin now when
we say it's fast and simple that means
that you just have to focus on the
development of an application building
an application and then you can just
deploy the application directly using
the beanstalk what the beanstalk is
going to do that every networking aspect
is being taken care by the stock it
deploys your application in the back end
on the servers and then you can directly
access your application using the url or
through the ip address the third
advantage is that it offers the quick
deployment that is what we discussed in
the fast and simple to begin as well so
why it offers a quick deployment you
don't have to bother about the
networking concepts you just have to
focus on the application development and
then you can just upload your
application deploy that and then you're
good to go the other advantage is that
it supports multi-tenant architecture
when we talk about tenants or
multi-tenants that means we can have a
virtual environments for separate
organizations or the divisions within
the organizations that will be virtually
isolated so likewise you can have uh
virtually isolated environments created
on the bean stock and they can be
separated used as a separate entities or
a separate divisions within the
organization and we know that it's a
flexible service since it's a scalable
then it is a flexible also now coming to
the simplifies operations as an
advantage now once the application is
deployed using the beanstalk then it
becomes very easy to maintain and
support that application using the
beanstalk services itself and the last
advantage that we can have from the
beanstalk is that it's a cost efficient
service the cost efficient as we know
that many of the aws services are cost
effective the cost optimization can be
better managed using the aws mean stock
as compared to if you are developing or
if you are deploying any kind of an
application or a solution on the on-prem
servers now there are some components
that are associated with the aws
beanstalk and it has to be created in
the form of a sequence manner so aws
elastic bean stock consists of few
important components which are required
while developing an application now what
are these components these are four
components one is application the second
is application version the third is
environment and the fourth one is the
environment tier and we have to progress
while deploying our applications or the
softwares using the same sequence now
let's understand what are the different
components of the beanstalk are the
application it refers to a unique label
which is used as a deployable code for a
web application so generally you deploy
your web application or you create your
application and that is something which
is basically uh used as a unique label
then the second component is application
versions so it resembles a folder which
stores a collection of components
such as environments versions and
environment configurations so all these
components are being stored using the
application version the third most
important component is the environment
in the environment only the current
versions of the applications runs now
remember that elastic means stock
supports multiple versions as well and
using the environment you can only run
the current version of the application
for if you wanted to have another
version of an application to be running
then you have to create an another
environment for that then comes the
environment here and in the environment
here it is basically it designates the
type of application that the environment
runs on now generally there are two
types of environment here one is the web
and the other one is the worker node and
that's something which we'll be
discussing later as well now let's
understand how does elastic beam stock
in aws works so first we have to create
an application and this is a task that
would be done by the developers and for
that you can actually select any runtime
environment or a programming language
like java docker ruby gopal or python as
well and once you select that
environment
you can
develop your application using that
runtime environments now after that once
the application is created then you have
to upload the version of an application
on the aws and after that
once the version is uploaded and then
you have to launch your environment so
just have to click on the buttons that's
it nothing more you have to do once the
environment is
launched then you can actually view that
environment using a web url or using the
ip address now what happens in that case
is when you launch an environment in the
back end the elastic bean stock runs
automatically runs an ec2 instance and
using a metadata the mean stock deploys
our application within that ec2 instance
that is something which you can look
into the ec2 dashboard as well so you
don't have to take care of the security
groups you don't have to take care of
the ip addressing and even you don't
have to log into the instance and deploy
your application it would be done
automatically by the bean stock it's
just that you just have to monitor the
environment and the statistics will be
available there itself in the bin stock
dashboard otherwise you can view those
statistics in the
cloud watch logs as well now in case if
you wanted to update any kind of a
version then you just upload a new
version and then just deploy that and
then monitor your environment so these
are the essentials to create a local
applications for any platform whether
it's a node.js python etc these are the
things that you have to actually take
care and this is the sequence you have
to follow while creating an environment
so you can say that it's a four steps
creation of a deployment of your
application that's it now after users
upload their versions the configuration
is automatically deployed with a load
balancer yes and with the load balancer
that means you can access the
applications using the load balancer dns
also and apart from load balancer if you
wanted to put any other feature that
includes the auto scaling for example if
you wanted to create your ec2 instances
where the application will be deployed
within the virtual private cloud or in a
particular subnet within the vpc all
those features that are available and
you can select them using the mean stock
itself you don't have to move out to the
vpc you don't have to actually go to the
ec2 dashboard and select all those
separately everything would be available
within the beanstalk dashboard so that's
what it says in the presentation that
after creating an application the deploy
service can be specifically accessed
using the url so once the environment is
created there will be a url defined now
you can put a url name also that is
something which you wanted to put for
your application you can define that you
can check for the availability of that
url and then you have to use that url to
access your application or the browser
now once it is done then in the monitor
environment it says the environment is
monitored provided capacity provisioning
load balancing auto scaling and multi
features all those features are
available there itself in the mean stock
now let's understand the architecture of
aws elastic bean stock now there are two
types of environments that you have to
select you can select one is the web
server environment and the other one is
the worker environment so based on the
client requirement beanstalk gives you
two different types of environment that
you have to select generally the web
server environment is the front end
facing that means the client should be
accessing this environment directly
using a url so mostly web applications
are deployed using that environment the
worker environment is the backend
applications or on the micro apps which
are basically required to support the
running of the web applications now it
depends on the client requirement what
kind of an environment you wanted to
select now in the web server environment
it only handles the http request from
the client so that's why we use the web
server environment mostly for the web
applications or any application which
works on the http https requests so it's
not only the http you can use the https
as well the worker environment it
process background task and minimizes
the consumption of resources so again it
is just like a kind of a micro service
or an application services that are
running in the back end to support the
web server environment now coming to the
understanding of the aws main stock so
this is how the architecture of the aws
beanstalk is designed and you can refer
to that image also now in the web server
environment let's say if we select a web
server environment and it says that if
the application receives client request
the amazon route 53 sends these requests
to the elastic load balancer now
obviously we discussed here that the web
server environment is primarily an
environment which receives the http
request it's a kind of a client-facing
environment now if the application
receives a client request amazon from
the amazon route 53 this route 53 is a
service which is primarily used for dns
mapping it's a global service and it may
route you can route the traffic from the
route 53 matching your domains towards
the load balancer and from the load
balancer you can point that traffic to
the web server environment obviously the
web server environment is nothing it's
just the ec2 instances that would be
running in the back end now here in the
diagram you can see that there are two
web server environments and they are
created in the auto scaling group that
means there is some kind of scaling
options that are defined as well and
these instances are created in an
availability zone or they can be created
in a different availability zone also
for the redundancy as well and these web
application servers are further
connected to your databases which
primarily will be in a different
security groups probably it can be an
rds database also so all these
functionalities all these features are
basically available on the elastic mean
stock dashboard itself now what happens
in that case is if the application
receives client requests amazon route 53
send these requests to the load balancer
later the load balancer shares those
requests among the ec2 instances how
does that happen it happens using a
predefined algorithm the equal
distribution of a load is distributed to
both the ec2 instances or n number of
ac2 instances running in the
availability zone now in the
availability zones every ec2 instance
would have its own security group they
can have a common security group also
they can have their own security group
as well now after the security group the
load balancer is then connected to the
amazon ec2 instance which are part of
the auto scaling group so that's
something which we have discussed
already now this auto scaling group is
would be defined from the bean stock
itself and there will be some scaling
options that will be created it could be
a possibility that it might be the
minimum number of instances that would
be running as of now and based on the
threshold defined it may increase the
number of ec2 instance and the load
balancer will keep on distributing the
load to as many instances that will be
created inside the availability resource
obviously there will be an internal
health check that the load balancer will
be first doing before distributing the
real time traffic to this instances
created by the mean stock now what does
auto scaling group does it automatically
starts the additional ec2 instance to
accommodate increasing load on your
application that's something which we
know that and also it monitors and
scales instances based on the workload
as well so depends on what kind of a
scaling threshold you have defined in
the auto scaling groups and when the
load of an application decreases the ec2
instance will also be decreased so
whenever we talk about the auto scaling
generally it comes in our mind is that
we scale up the resources that means we
it increases the ec2 instances in the
auto scaling you might have the scaled
down option also scaled down policy also
created in which if the load minimizes
it can terminate the additional ec2
instances as well so that is something
which will be automatically managed all
these features can be achievable using
the elastic bean stock and with this
feature accommodated it gives you the
better cost optimization in terms of
managing your resources now it says that
elastic bean stock has a default
security group and the security group
acts as a firefall for the instances now
here in this diagram it says about the
security group auto scaling also you
might create it in a default vpc also
you might create it in your custom epc
also where you can have the additional
level of security is also created you
can have the nacls knuckles also defined
here before the security groups so that
would give you the additional filtering
option or the firewall option now it
says that with these groups with these
security groups it allows establishing
security groups to the database server
as well so every database would also
have its own security group and the
connection can be created between the
web servers environment that is created
by the beanstalk to the database
security groups as well now let's
discuss about the worker environment now
understanding the worker environment
what happens is that the client the web
server environment is the client facing
the client sends a request for an access
to the web server and in this diagram
the web server further sends it to the
sqs which is a simple queue service and
the queue service sends it to the worker
environment and then whatever the worker
environment is created for doing some
kind of a processing or some kind of an
application that is running in the back
end that environment initiates and uh
then send back uh the results to this
sqs and vice versa so let's understand
the architecture of a aws elastic bean
stock with the worker environment so
when a worker environment here is
launched aws elastic beam stock installs
the server on every ec2 instance so that
is in the case of a web server
environment also and later the server
passes the request to the simple queue
service now this service is an
asynchronous service instead of a simple
queue service you can have other
services also it is not necessary that
you need to have the sqs also this is an
example that we are discussing about and
the sqs shares those message via a post
request to the http path over the booker
environment and there are many case
studies also with respect to this kind
of an environment that is being created
that has been done on many customers
and you can search for these kind of a
case studies available on the internet
now the worker environment executes the
task given by the sqs with the http
response after the operation is
completed now here what happens is a
quick recap the client request for an
access of an application to a web server
using an http request the web server
passes that request to the queue service
the q service shares the message with
the worker probably a worker might be
the manual worker and generally it's an
automated worker so it would be shared
by the worker environment only and the
worker sends back the response with the
http response back to the queue that
response can be viewed directly from the
queue service by the client using the
web server so this is one of the example
likewise as i said that there can be
many other examples also where you can
have the worker environments defined now
what are the companies that are using
the elastic bean stock these are few of
the companies that are primarily using
on a zillow jelly button games
then you have league of women voters
ebury
these are some of the few listed
companies and obviously you search on
the aws site and you'll find many more
organizations that are using the elastic
bean stock primarily for
deploying their applications now the
next thing is to go with the practicals
that how actually we use the elastic
bean stock so let's look into the demo
using the aws elastic bean stock now
first you have to login into the aws
console and i'm sure that you might be
having the accounts created or you can
use the im credentials as well and then
you have to select the region also now i
am in the north virginia region likewise
you can select any of the regions that
are listed here now click on the
services and you have to search for the
elastic bean stock you can find the
elastic bean stock under the compute
section so here itself you'll find the
elastic bean stock as a service now open
this service and there it will give you
an option to create an environment you
have to specifically select an
environment probably a worker
environment or a web service environment
so let's wait for the service to open so
we have the dashboard now available with
us this is how the elastic bean stock
looks and this is the symbol
representation of a bean stock now what
you have to do is we have to click on
get started and that will load and you
have to create a web app so instead of
creating a web app what we'll do we'll
create a new application so just click
on create a new application put an
application name let's say we put
something like x y z you can put any
description to your application let's
say it's a demo app and click on create
now it says you have to select an
environment
now the environment the application name
xyz is created you just have to select
an environment so click on create one
now and it is going to ask you that what
kind of an environment here you wanted
to select so as we discussed that there
are two types of environments one is the
web server and the other one is the
worker in one let's look into it what is
defined by the aws aws says that it has
two types of environment tiers to
support different types of web
applications web servers are standard
applications that listen for and then
process http request typically over port
number 80. workers are specialized
application that have a background
processing task that listens for message
on an amazon sqs queue workers
application post those messages to your
application by using the http response
so that's what we saw in the case of the
beanstalk slides also now the usability
of a worker environment can be anything
now we'll do a demo for creating a web
server environment so just click on
select and you we have the environment
name created now we can define our own
domain it ends with the region dot
elastic
let's say i look for a domain which is
xyz only that's the environment name now
i'll check for the availability whether
that domain name is available with us or
not and it says we don't have that
domain name so probably i'll try to make
it with some other name and let's look
for the availability xyz abc and it says
yes it is available now once i deploy my
application i would be able to access
the application using this complete dns
so you can put a description uh it's a
demo app that we are creating and then
you have to define a platform as well
now these are the platforms that are
supported by the aws let's say i wanted
to run a node.js environment so i'll
just click on the node.js platform the
application codes is something which is
basically developed by the developers
and you can upload the app application
right now or you can do that later as
well once the environment is ready now
either you can select to create an
environment if you wanted to go with all
the default settings otherwise if you
wanted to customize it more you can
click on configure more options so let's
click on configure more options and here
you would be able to define various
different features like the type of an
instance for example what kind of an ec2
instance or a server that should be
running so that the beanstalk can deploy
our applications over it if you wanted
to modify just click on a modify button
and here you can modify your instances
with respect to the storage as well now
apart from that if you wanted to do some
modification in the case of monitoring
in the case of databases in the case of
security or in the case of a capacity
let's look into the capacity so here you
can actually do the modification so in
the capacity you can select the instance
type also by default it is t2.micro but
in case if your application requires a
larger type of an instance then you can
actually go for the instance type as
well similarly you can define your emi
ids also because obviously for the
application to run you would require the
operating system also so you can select
that particular ami id for your
operating system as well let's cancel
that likewise you have many other
features
that you can actually define here from
the dashboard and you don't have to go
to the ec2 dashboard to do the
modifications now let's go and create an
environment let's assume that we are
going with the default configuration so
this is going to create our environment
the environment is being created and you
can get the environment and the
logs defined in the dashboard itself so
you'll see that the beanstalk
environment is being initiated the
environment is being started and in case
if there would be any errors or if it is
deployed correctly you will get all the
logs here itself now the environments
are basically color coded so there are
different color codings that are defined
if you get the environment in a green
color that means everything is good to
go so here you can see that
it has created an elastic ip it has
checked the health of the environment
now it has created the security groups
and that would be an auto security
groups created by the bean stock and the
environment
creation has been started you can see
that
elastic bean stock as amazon s3 storage
bucket for your environment data as well
this is the url through which you will
be accessing the environment but right
now we cannot do that since the
environment is being created let's click
on the application name and here you can
see that it is in a gray color that
means right now the build is being done
it is being created once it will be
successfully created it should change to
the green color and then we will be able
to access our environment using the url
now if i move to the ec2 instances and
see in the ec2 dashboard if i see
whether the instance is being created by
the beanstalk or not so let's see and
let's see what are the differences in
terms of creating an instance manually
and getting it created from the bean
stock so click on the easy to let's go
to the old ec2 experience that's what we
are familiar with and let's see what's
there in the dashboard so here you can
see one a running instance let's open
that and the xyz environment which was
created from the bean stock is being
initiated the instance is being
initiated and that is something which is
being done by the mean stock itself we
have not gone to the dashboard and
created it manually now in the security
groups if you see that here the aws mean
stock security groups are defined it has
the elastic ips also defined so
everything is being created by the
beanstalk itself right now let's go back
to the beanstalk and let's look into the
status of our environment whether the
color coding has been changed from gray
to green or not and here you can see the
environment is successfully created and
we have that environment colored in
green we we'll access the environment
and it says it's a web server
environment its platform is node.js
running on 64-bit amazon linux ami and
it says
app sample application health status is
ok now the other thing is that if you do
not want to use the web console the
management console to access the main
stock then the beanstalk offers you the
elastic beanstalk cli as well so you can
install the command line interface and
then you have the command references cli
command references that you can actually
play with and get your applications
deployed using the bean stock itself so
this is one of the sample cli commands
that you can actually look into now
let's look into the environment let's
click on the environment and we'll be
represented with the url it says health
is okay
these are the logs that you have to
follow in case if there are any issues
the platform is nodejs that is what we
selected now the next thing is you just
have to upload and deploy your
applications so just click on upload and
deploy select the version label or the
name select file and wherever your
application is hosted at just select
that upload it and deploy your
application you'll see that the like
your environment is created similarly
your application will be deployed
automatically on the instance and from
this url you will be able to view the
output it is as simple as just like you
have to follow these four steps now
let's see whether the nodejs environment
is running on our instance before
deploying an application
so we'll just click on this url since
the beanstalk has already opened up the
security groups or http port 80 for all
we can actually view that output
directly from the url so we have the
node.js running that's visible here and
after that you just have to upload and
deploy your application and then from
that url you can get the output now this
url you can map it with the root 53
service so using the root 53 dns
services the domain names can be pointed
to the elastic bean stock url and from
there it can be pointed to the
applications that are running on the ec2
instance whether you wanted to point it
to the url directly using the mean stock
you can do that otherwise as we saw in
the slides you can use the route 53
pointed to the load balancer and then
point it to the instances directly also
once it is created by the mean stock so
that was the demo guys with respect to
the bean stock and how we can actually
run the environments apart from that the
operational task like system operations
you can manage all these things from the
environment dashboard itself so you have
the configurations you have the logs you
can actually check the health status of
your environment you can do the
monitoring and you can actually get the
alarms and the events here so let's say
if i wanted to if i wanted to see the
logs i can request for the locks here
itself and i'll be represented with the
full log report and i can now download
that log file and i can view the logs so
it's in the so we have this bundle locks
in the zip file all right so if you want
to see some kind of
logs with respect to elastic bean stock
activity it's in the form of a notepad
and here you can see what all
configurations the beanstalk has done on
your environment on your instance
similarly you can go for the health
monitoring alarms events and all those
things
these questions are practical scenario
based questions that tests the depth of
the knowledge of a person in a
particular aws product or in a
particular aws architecture so why wait
let's move on all right so in an
interview you would find yourself with a
question that might ask you define and
explain the three basic types of cloud
services and the aws products that are
built based on them see here it's a very
straightforward question just explain
three basic types of cloud service and
when we talk about basic type of cloud
service it's compute obviously that's a
very basic service storage obviously
because you need to store your data
somewhere and networking that actually
connects a couple of other services to
your application these basic will not
include monitoring these basic will not
include analytics because they are
considered as optional they are
considered as advanced services you
could choose a non-cloud service or a
product for monitoring of and for
analytics so they're not considered as
basic so when we talk about basics they
are compute storage and networking and
the second part of the questions is
explain some of the aws products that
are built based on them of course
compute ec2 is a major one that's that's
the major share of the compute resource
and then we have platform as a service
which is elastic bean stock and then
function as a service which is lambda
auto scaling and light cell are also
part of compute
services so the compute domain it really
helps us to run any application and the
compute service helps us in managing the
scaling and deployment of an application
again lambda is a compute server so the
compute service also helps in running
event initiated stateless applications
the next one was storage a lot of
emphasis is on storage these days
because if there's one thing that grows
in a network on a daily basis that
storage every new day we have new data
to store process manage so storage is
again a basic and an important cloud
service and the products that are built
based on the storage services are s3
object storage glacier for archiving ebs
elastic block storage as a drive
attachment for the ec2 instances and the
efs file share for the ec2 instances so
the storage domain helps in the
following aspects it holds all the
information that the application uses so
it's the application data and we can
also archive old data using storage
which would be glacier and any object
files and any requirement for block
storage can be met through elastic block
store and s3 which is again an object
storage talking about networks it's just
not important to answer the question
with the name of the services and the
name of the product it'll also be good
if you could go in depth and explain how
they can be used right so that actually
proves you to be a person knowledgeable
enough in that particular service or
product so talking about networking
domain vpc networking can't imagine
networking without vpc in in a cloud
environment especially in aws cloud
environment and then we have route 53
for domain resolution or
for dns and then we have cloudfront
which is an edge caching service that
helps customers get our customers to
read their application with low latency
so networking domain helps with some of
the following use cases it controls and
manages the connectivity of the aws
services within our account and we can
also pick an ip address range
if you're a network engineer or if you
are somebody who works in networks or
are planning to work a network you will
soon realize the importance of choosing
your own ip address for easy remembering
so having an option to have your own ip
address in the cloud on the range of ip
address in the cloud it really helps
really really helps in cloud networking
the other question that get asked would
be the difference between the
availability zone and the region
actually the question generally gets
asked
so to test how well you can actually
differentiate and also correlate the
availability zone and the region
relationship
right so a region is a separate
geographic area like the us west one
i mean which represents uh north
california
or the ap south which represents mumbai
so regions are a separate geographic
area on the contrary availability zone
resides inside the region you shouldn't
stop there you should go further and
explain about availability zones and
availability zones are isolated from
each other and some of the services will
replicate themselves within the
availability zone so availability zone
does replication within them but regions
they don't generally do replication
between them the other question you
could be asked is what is auto scaling
what do we achieve by auto scaling so in
short auto scaling it helps us to
automatically provision and launch new
instances whenever there is an demand it
not only helps us meeting the increasing
demand it also helps in reducing the
resource usage when there is low demand
so auto scaling also allows us to
decrease the resources or resource
capacity as per the need of that
particular r now this helps business in
not worrying about
putting more effort in managing or
continuously monitoring the server to
see if they have the needed resource or
not because auto scaling is going to
handle it for us so business does not
need to worry about it and auto scaling
is one big reason why people would want
to go and pick a cloud service
especially in aws service the ability to
increase and shrink based on the need of
that r that's how powerful is auto
scaling
the other question you could get asked
is what's your targeting in cloud front
now we know that cloudfront is caching
and it caches content globally in the
amazon caching servers global wide the
whole point is to provide users
worldwide access to the data from a very
nearest server possible that's the whole
point in using or going for cloudfront
then what do you mean by geotargeting
geotargeting is showing customer and
specific content based on language we
can customize the content based on
what's popular in that place we can
actually customize the content the url
is the same but we could actually change
the content a little bit not the whole
content otherwise it would be dynamic
but we can change the content a little
bit a specific a file or a picture or a
particular link in a website and show
customized content to users who will be
in different parts of the globe so how
does it happen cloudfront will detect
the country where the viewers are
located and it will forward the country
code to the origin server and once the
origin server gets the specialized or
specific country code it will change the
content and it will send to the caching
server and it get cached there forever
and the user gets to view a content
which is personalized for them for the
country they are in the other question
you could get asked is the steps
involved in using cloud formation or
creating a cloud formation or backing up
an environment within cloud formation
template we all know that if there is a
template we can simply run it and it
provisions the environment but there is
a lot more going into it so the first
step in moving towards infrastructure as
a code is to create the cloud formation
template which as of now supports json
and yaml file format so first create the
cloud formation template and then save
the code in an x3 bucket s3 bucket
serves as the repository for our code
and then from the cloud formation call
the file in the s3 bucket and create a
stack and now cloud formation uses the
file reads the file understands services
that are being called understands the
order understands how they are connected
with each other cloud formation is
actually an intelligent service it
understands the relation based on the
code it would understand the
relationship between the different
services and it would set an order for
itself and then would provision the
services one after the other let's say a
service has a dependency and the
dependent service the other service
which this service let's say service a
and b service b is dependent on service
a let's say cloud formation is an
intelligent service it would provision
the resource a first and then would
provision resource b what happens if we
inverse the order if we inverse the
order resource b first gets provision
and because it does not have dependency
chances that the cloud formation's
default behavior is that if something is
not provisioned properly something is
not healthy it could roll back chances
that the environment provisioning will
roll back so to avoid that cloud
formation first provisions all the
services that has or that's dependent on
that's depended by another service so it
provisions those service first and then
provisions the services that has
dependencies
and if you are being hired for
a devops or you know if the interviewer
wanted to test your skill on
systems side this definitely would be a
question in his list how do you upgrade
or downgrade a system with near zero
downtime now everybody's moving towards
zero downtime or near zero downtime all
of them want their application to be
highly available so the question would
be how do you actually upgrade or
downgrade a system with near zero
downtime now we all know that i can
upgrade an ec2 instance to a better ec2
instance by changing the instance type
stopping and starting but stopping and
starting is going to cause a downtime
right so that's you should be answering
or you shouldn't be thinking in those
terms because that's the wrong answer
specifically the interviewer wants to
know how do you upgrade a system with
zero downtime so upgrading system with
zero downtime it includes launching
another system parallelly with the
bigger ec2 instance type with the bigger
capacity and install all that's needed
if you're going to use an ami of the old
machine well and good you don't have to
go through installing all the updates
and installing all the application from
the ami once you have launched it in a
bigger instance locally test the
application to see if it is working
don't put it on production yet test the
application to see if it is working and
if the application works we can actually
swap if your server is behind and
behind
route 53 let's say all that you could do
is go to rot 53 update the
information with the new ip address new
ip address of the new server and that's
going to send traffic to the new server
now so the cut over is handled or if
you're using static ip you can actually
remove the static ip from the old
machine and assign it to the new machine
that's one way of doing it or if you are
using elastic nic card you can actually
remove the new card from the old machine
and attach the new card to the new
machine so that way we would get near
zero downtime if you're hired for an
architect level
you should be worrying about cost as
well along with the technology and this
question would test how well you manage
cost so what are the tools and
techniques we can use in aws to identify
and correct identify and know that we
are paying the correct amount for the
resources that we are using or how do
you get a visibility of your aws
resources running
one way is to check the billing there is
a place where you can check the top
services that were utilized it could be
free and it could be paid service as
well top services that can be utilized
it's actually in the dashboard of the
cost management console so that table
here shows the top five most used
services so looking at it you can get it
all right so i'm using a lot of storage
i'm using a lot of ec2 why is storage
high you can go and try to justify that
and you will find if you are storing
things that should be storing and then
clean it up why is compute capacity so
high why is data transfer so high so if
you start thinking in those levels
you'll be able to dig in and clean up
unnecessary and be able to save your
bill and there are cost explorer
services available which will help you
to view your usage pattern or view your
spending for the past 13 months or so
and it will also forecast for the next
three months now how much will you be
using if your pattern is like this that
will actually help and will give you a
visibility on how much you have spent
how much you will be spending if the
trend continues budgets are another
excellent a way to control cost you can
actually set up budget alright this is
how much i am willing to spend for this
application for this team or for this
month for this particular resource so
you can actually put a budget mark and
any time it exceeds any time it's
nearing you would get an alarm saying
that well we're about to reach the
allocated budget amount stuff like that
that way you can go back and know and
you know that how much the bill is going
to be for that month or you can take
steps to control bill amount for that
particular month so aws budget is
another very good tool that you could
use cost allocation tags helps in
identifying which team or which resource
has spent more in that particular month
instead of looking at the bill as one
list with no specifications into it and
looking at it as an expenditure list you
can actually break it down and tag the
expenditure to the teams with cost
allocation tax the dev team has spent so
much the
production team has spent so much the
training team has spent more than the
dev and the production team why is that
now you'll be able to you know think in
those levels only if you have cost
allocation tax now cost allocation tax
are nothing but the tax that you would
put when you create a resource so for
production services you would put as a
production tag you would create a
production tag and you would associate
that resources to it and at a later
point when you actually pull up your
bill that's going to show a detailed a
list of this is the owner this is the
group and this is how much they have
used in the last month and you can move
forward with your investigation and
encourage or stop users using more
services with the cost allocation tax
the other famous question is are there
any other tools or is there any other
way of accessing aws resource other than
the console console is gui right so in
other words other than gui how would you
use the aws resource and how familiar
are you with those tools and
technologies the other tools that are
available that we can leverage and
access the aws resource are of course
hoodie you can configure puri to access
the aws resources like login to an ec2
instance and ec2 instance does not
always have to be logged in through the
console you could use putty to log into
an ec2 instance like the jump box like
the proxy machine and like the gateway
machine and from there you can actually
access the rest of the resources so this
is an alternative to the console and of
course we have the aws cli in any of the
linux machines or windows machines we
can install so that's point two three
and four we can install aws cli for
linux windows also for mac so we can
install them and from there from your
local machine we can access run aws
commands and access provision monitor
the aws resources the other ones are we
can access the aws resource
programmatically using aws sdk and
eclipse so these are a bunch of options
we have to use the aws resource other
than the console if you're interviewed
in a company or by a company that
focuses more on security and want to use
aws native services for their security
then you would come across this question
what services can be used to create a
centralized logging solution the basic
services we could use our cloud watch
logs store them in s3 and then use
elasticsearch to visualize them and use
kinesis to move the data from s3 to
elasticsearch right so log management it
actually helps organizations to track
the relationship between operational and
security changes and the events that got
triggered based on those logs
instead of logging into an instance or
instead of logging into the environment
and checking the resources physically i
can come to a fair conclusion by just
looking at the logs every time there's a
change the system would scream and it
gets tracked in the cloud watch and then
cloud watch pushes it to s3 kinesis
pushes the data from s3 to elasticsearch
and i can do a time-based filter and i
would get an a fair understanding of
what was going on in the environment for
the past one or whatever the time window
that i wanted to look at so it helps in
getting a good understanding of the
infrastructure as a whole all the logs
are getting saved in one place so all
the infrastructure logs are getting
saved in one place so it's easy for me
to look at it in an infrastructure
perspective
so we know the services that can be used
and here are some of the services and
how they actually connect to each other
it could be logs that belongs to a one
account it could be logs that belongs to
multiple accounts it doesn't matter you
know those three services are gonna work
fairly good and they're gonna inject or
they're gonna like suck logs from the
other accounts put it in one place and
help us to monitor so as you see you
have cloud watch here that actually
tracks the metrics you can also use
cloud trail if you want to log api calls
as well push them in an s3 bucket so
there are different types of blog flow
logs are getting captured in an instance
application logs are getting captured
from the same vpc from a different vpc
from the same account from a different
account and all of them are analyzed
using elasticsearch using the kibana
client
so step one is to deploy the ecs cluster
step two is to restrict access to the
ecs cluster because it's valid data you
don't want anybody to put their hands
and access their data so resting access
to the ecs dashboard and we could use
lambda also to push the data from cloud
watch to
the elasticsearch domain and then kibana
is actually the graphical tool that
helps us to visualize the logs instead
of looking at log as just statements or
a bunch of characters a bunch of files
kibana helps us to analyze the logs in a
graphical or a chart or a bar diagram
format again in an interview the
interview is more concerned about
testing your knowledge on aw security
products especially on the logging
monitoring even management or incident
management then you could have a
question like this what are the native
aws security logging capabilities now
most of the services have their own
logging in them like have their own
logging like s3 s3 has its own login and
cloudfront has its own logging ds has
its own logging vpc has its own logging
in additional there are account level
logins like a cloudtrail and aws config
services so there are variety of logging
options available in the aws like cloud
trail config cloudfront redshift logging
rds logging vpc flow logs s3 object
logging s3 access logging stuff like
that so we're going to look at two
servers in specific cloud trail now this
cloud trail the very first product in
that picture we just stopped the cloud
trail provides an very high
level history of the api calls for all
the account and with that we can
actually perform a very good security
analysis a security analysis of our
account and these logs are actually
delivered to you can configure it they
can be delivered to s3 for long time
archivals and based on a particular
event it can also send an email
notification to us saying hey just got
this error thought i'll let you know
stuff like that the other one is config
service a config service helps us to
understand the configuration changes
that happened in our environment and we
can also set up notifications based on
the configuration changes so it records
the cumulative changes that are made in
a short period of time so if you want to
go through the lifetime of a particular
resource what are the things that happen
what are the things it went through they
can be looked at using aws config
all right the other question you could
get asked is if
you know your role includes taking care
of cloud security as well then the other
question you could get asked is the
native services that amazon provides
to mitigate ddos which is denial of
service now not all companies would go
with amazon native services but there
are some companies which want to stick
with amazon native services just to save
them from the headache of managing the
other softwares or bringing in another
tool a third-party tool into managing
ddos they simply want to stick with
amazon proprietary amazon native
services and a lot of companies are
using amazon service to prevent ddos
denial of service now denial of service
is if you already know what denial of
service is well and good if you do not
know then let's know it now denial of
service is a user trying to or
maliciously making attempt to access a
website or an application the user would
actually create multiple sessions and he
would occupy all the sessions and he
would not let legitimate users access
the servers so he's in turn denying the
service for the user a quick picture
review of
what denial of services now look at it
these users instead of making one
connection they are making multiple
connections and there are cheap software
programs available that would actually
trigger connections from different
computers in the internet with different
mac addresses so everything kind of
looks legitimate for the server and it
would accept those connections and it
will keep the sessions open the actual
users won't be able to use them so
that's denying the service for the
actual users denial of service all right
and distributed denial of service is
generating attacks from multiple places
you know from a distributed environment
so that's distributed denial of service
so the tools the native tools that helps
us to prevent the denial of service
attacks in aws is cloud shield
and web access firewall aws
now they are the major ones they are
designed to mitigate a denial of service
if your website is often bothered by
denial of service then we should be
using aws shield or aws waff and there
are a couple of other tools that also
does when i say that also does denial of
service is not their primary job but you
could use them for denial of service
route 53's purpose is to provide dns
cloudfront is to provide caching elastic
load balancer elbs work is to provide
load balancing vpc is to create and
secure a virtual private environment but
they also support mitigating denial of
service but not to the extent you would
get in aws shield and aws web so aw
shield and waff are the primary ones but
the rest can also be used to mitigate
distributed denial of service the other
tricky question is
this actually will test your familiarity
with the region and the services
available in the region so when you're
trying to provision a service in a
particular region you're not seeing the
service in that region how do we go
about fixing it or how do we go about
using the service in the cloud it's a
tricky question and if you have not gone
through such situation you can totally
blow it away you really need to have a
good understanding on regions the
services available in those regions and
what if a particular service is not
available how to go about doing it the
answer is not all services are available
in all regions anytime amazon announces
a new service they don't immediately
publish them on all regions they start
small and as in when the traffic
increases as and when it becomes more
likeable to the customers they actually
move the service to different regions so
as you see in this picture within
america not virginia has more services
compared to ohio or compared to north
california so within not america itself
north virginia is the preferred one so
similarly there are preferred regions
within europe middle east and africa and
preferred regions within asia pacific so
anytime we don't see a service in a
particular region chances that the
service is not available in that region
yet we got to check the documentation
and find the nearest region that offers
that service and start using the service
from that region now you might think
well if i'm looking for a service in
asia let's say in mumbai and if it is
not available why not simply switch to
north virginia and start using it you
could but you know that's going to add
more latency to your application so
that's why we need to check for
application which is check for region
which is very near to the place where
you want to serve your customers and
find nearest region instead of always
going back to north virginia and
deploying an application in north
virginia again there's a place there's a
link in aws.com
that you can go and look for services
available in different region and that's
exactly what you're seeing here and if
your service is not available in a
particular region switch to the other
region that provides your service the
nearest other region that provides that
service and start using service from
there
with the
coming up of cloud a lot of companies
have turned down their monitoring team
instead they want to go with the
monitorings that cloud provides you know
nobody wants to or at least many people
don't want to go through the hassle of
at least new startups and new companies
that are thinking of having a monitoring
environment that they don't want to go
with traditional knock monitoring
instead they would like to leverage aws
monitorings available because it
monitors a lot of stuff not just the
availability but it monitors a lot of
stuff like failures errors it also
triggers emails stuff like that so how
do you actually set up a monitor to
website how to set up a monitor to
monitor the website metrics in real time
in aws the simple way anytime you have a
question about monitoring cloudwatch
should strike your mind because
cloudwatch is meant for monitoring is
meant for collecting metrics is meant
for providing graphical representation
of what's going on in a particular
network at a particular point of time so
cloudwatch cloudwatch helps us to
monitor applications and using
cloudwatch we can monitor the state
changes not only the state changes the
auto scaling life cycle events anytime
there are more services added there is a
reduction in the number of servers
because of less usage and very
informative messages can be received
through cloud watch any cloud watch can
now support scheduled events if you want
to schedule anything cloudwatch has an
event that would schedule an action
right schedule a trigger time based not
incident based you know anything
happening and then you get an action
happening that's incident based on the
other hand you can simply schedule few
things on time based so that's possible
with cloud watch so this cloud watch
integrates very well with a lot of other
services like notifications for
notifying the user or for notifying the
administrator about it and it can
integrate well with lambda so to trigger
an action anytime you're designing an
auto healing environment this cloud
watch can actually monitor and send an
email if we are integrating it with sns
simple notification service or this
cloud watch can monitor and
based on what's happening it can trigger
an event in lambda and that would in
turn run a function till the environment
comes back to normal so cloudwatch
integrates well with a lot of other aws
services
all right so cloudwatch has uh three
statuses green when everything is going
good hello when the service is degraded
and red when the service is not
available
green is good so we don't have to do
anything about it but anytime there is
an ello the picture that we're looking
at it's actually calling and lambda
function to debug the application and to
fix it and anytime there's a red alert
it immediately notifies the owner of the
application about well the service is
down and here is the report that i have
here is the metrics that i've collected
about the service stuff like that if the
job role requires you to manage the
servers as well there are certain job
roles which are on the system side there
are certain job roles which is
development plus system side now you're
responsible for the application and the
server as well so if that's the case you
might be tested with some basic
questions like the different types of
virtualization and aws and what are the
difference between them all right the
three major types of virtualization are
hvm which is hardware virtual machine
the other one is pv para virtualization
and the third one is pv on hvm para
virtualization on hardware virtual
module
all right the difference between them or
actually describing them is actually the
difference between them hvm it's
actually a fully virtualized hardware
you know the whole hardware is
virtualized and all virtual machines act
separate from each other and these vms
are booted by executing master boot
record in the root block and when we
talk about para virtualization paragraph
is actually the special boot loader
which boots the pv amis and when we talk
about pv on hvm it's it's actually the
marriage between hvm and pv and this
para virtualization on hvm in other
words pv on hvm it actually helps
operating system take advantage
in storage and the network input output
available through the host another good
question is name some of the services
that are not region specific now
you've been thought that all services
are within a region and some services
are within an availability zone for
example ec2 is within an availability
zone ebs is within an availability zone
s3 is region specific dynamodb is region
specific stuff like that vpc is both
availability and
region specific meaning you know subnets
are availability zone specific and vpcs
region specific stuff like that so you
might have thought you might have
learned in that combination but there
could be some tricky questions that
tests you how well you have understood
the region non-region and availability
non-availability services i should say
there are services that are not region
specific that would be iam so we can't
have im for every availability zone and
for every region which means you know
users will have to use one username and
password for one region and anytime they
switch to another region they will have
to use another username and password
that that's more work and that's not a
good design as well authentication has
to be global so im is a global service
and which means its not region specific
on the other hand route 53 is again a
regional specific so we can't have a
route 53 for every region route 53 is
not a region specific service it's a
global service and it's one application
users access from everywhere or from
every part of the world so we can't have
one url or one dns name for each region
if your application is a global
application and then web application
firewall works well with cloudfront then
cloudfront is a region based service so
the web application firewall it's not
region-specific service it's a global
service and cloudfront is again a global
service though you can
you know cache content on a continent
and country basis it's still considered
a global service right it's not bound to
any region so when you activate cloud
front you're activating it away from
region or availability zone so when
you're activating a web application
firewall because it's not a
region-specific service you're
activating it away from availability
zone and regions
so a quick recap imusers groups roles
and accounts they are global services
they can be used globally
route 53 services are offered at edge
locations and they are global as well
web application firewall a service that
protects our web application from common
web exploits they are global service as
well cloudfront cloudfront is global
content delivery network cdn and they
are offered at edge locations which are
a global service in other words
non-region specific service or beyond
region service all right this is another
good question as well in the project
that you are being interviewed if they
really want to secure their environment
using nat or if they are already
securing their environment using nat by
any of these two methods like nat
gateway or nat instances you can expect
this question what are the difference
between a nat gateway and that instances
now they both saw the same thing right
so they're not two different services
trying to achieve two different things
they both serve the same thing but still
they do have differences in them right
on a high level they both achieve
providing nothing for the service behind
it but the difference comes when we talk
about the availability of it
nat gateway is a managed service by
amazon whereas nat instance is managed
by us now i'm talking about the third
point maintenance here nat gateway is
managed by amazon that instance is
managed by us and availability of nat
gateway is very high and availability of
that instance is less compared to the
nat gateway because it's managed by us
you know it's on an ec2 instance which
could actually fail and if it fails
we'll have to relaunch it but if it is
not gateway if something happens to that
service amazon would take care of
reprovisioning it and talking about
bandwidth it can burst up to 75 gigabits
now traffic through the net gateway can
burst up to 75 gigabits but for that
instance it actually depends on the
server that we launched and if we are
launching a t2 micro it barely gets any
bandwidth so there's a difference there
and the performance because it's highly
available because of the bigger pipe 75
gigabits now the performance of the nat
gateway is very high but the performance
of the nat instance is going to be
average again it depends on the size of
the net instance that we pick and
billing a billing for nat gateway is the
number of gateways that we provision and
the duration for which we use the nat
gateway but billing for nat instance is
number of instance and the type of
instance that we use of course number of
instance duration and the type of
instance that we use
security not gateway cannot be
assigned meaning it already comes with
full packed security but in that
instance security is a bit customizable
i can go and change the security because
it's a server managed by me or managed
by us i can always change the security
well allow this allow don't allow this
stuff like that size and load of the
night gateway is uniform but the size
and the load of the uh that instance
changes as per an gateway is a fixed
product but that instance can be small
instance can be a big instance so the
size and the load through it varies
right the other question you could get
asked is what are the difference between
stopping and terminating an ec2 instance
now you will be able to answer only if
you have worked on environments where
you have your instance stopped and where
you have your instance terminated if you
have only used lab and are attending the
interview chances are that you might
your ways lost when answering this
question it might look like both are the
same well stopping and terminating both
are the same but there is a difference
in it so when you stop an instance it
actually performs a normal shutdown on
the instance and it simply moves the
instance to the stopped state but when
you actually terminate the instance the
instance is moved to this stop state the
evs volumes that are attached to it are
deleted and removed and we'll never be
able to recover them again so that's a
big difference between stopping and
terminating an instance if you're
thinking of using the instance again
along with the data in it you should
only be thinking of stopping the
instance but you should be terminating
the instance only if you want to get rid
of that instance forever
if you are being interviewed for an
architect level position or a junior
architect level position or even a cloud
consultant level position or even in an
engineering position this is a very
common question that get asked what are
the different types of easy to instances
based on their cost or based on how we
pay them right they're all compute
capacity for example the different types
are on demand instances spot instances
and reserved instances it kind of looks
the same they all provide the compute
capacity they all provide the same type
of hardwares for us but if you are
looking at cost saving or optimizing
cost in our environment we got to be
very careful about which one are we
picking now we might think that well
i'll go with on demand instance because
i pay on a per hour basis which is cheap
you know i can use them anytime i want
and anytime i don't want i can simply
get rid of it by terminating it you're
right but if the requirement is to use
the service for one year the requirement
is to use the service for three years
then you'll be wasting a lot of money
buying on-demand instances you'll be
wasting a lot of money paying on an
hourly basis instead we should be going
for reserved instance where we can
reserve the capacity for the complete
one year or complete three years and
save huge amount in buying reserved
instances all right so under man is
cheap to start with if you're only
planning to use it for a short while but
if you're planning to run it for a long
while then we should be going for
reserved instance that is what is cost
efficient so spot instance is cheaper
than on-demand instance and there are
different use cases for spot instance as
well so let's look at one after the
other the on-demand instance the
on-demand instance is purchased at a
fixed rate per r this is very short-term
and irregular workloads and for testing
for development on-demand instance is a
very good use case we should be using
on-demand for production spot instance
spot instance allows users to purchase
ec2 at a reduced price and any time we
have more instances we can always go and
sell it in spot instances i'm referring
to anytime we have more reserved
instances we can always sell them in
spot instance catalog and the way we buy
spot instance is we actually put a
budget this is how much i'm willing to
pay all right would you be able to give
service within this cost so anytime the
price comes down and meets the cost that
we have put in will be assigned an
instance and any time the price shoots
up the instance will be taken away from
us but in case of on demand instances we
have bought that instance for that
particular r and it stays with us but
with spot instances it varies based on
the price if you meet the price you get
the instance if you don't meet the price
it goes away to somebody else and the
spot instance availability is actually
based on supply and demand in the market
there's no guarantee that you will get
spot instance at all time alright so
that's a caveat there you should be
familiar with that's a caveat that you
should be aware when you are proposing
somebody that we can go for spot
instance and save money it's not always
going to be available if you want your
spot instance to be available to you
then we need to carefully watch the
history of the price of the spot
instance now how much was it last month
and how much was it how much is it this
month so how can i code or how much can
i code stuff like that so you got to
look at those history before you propose
somebody that well we're going to save
money using spot instance on the other
hand reserved instance provide cost
savings for the company we can opt for
reserved instances for you know one year
or three years there are actually three
types of reserved instances light medium
and heavy reserved instances they are
based on the amount that we would be
paying and cost benefit also depends
with reserved instance the cost benefit
also depends based on are we doing all
upfront or no upfront or partial payment
then split the rest as monthly payments
so there are many purchase options
available but overall if you're looking
at using an application for the next one
year and three years you should not be
going for on-demand instance you should
be going for reserved instance and
that's what gives you the cost benefit
and in an errors interview sometimes you
might be asked you know how you interact
with the aws environment are you using
cli are you using console and depending
on your answer whether console or a cli
the panelist put a score okay this
person is cli specific this person is
console specific or this person has used
aws environment through the sdk stuff
like that so this question tests whether
you are a cli person or an console
person and the question goes like this
how do you set up ssh agent forwarding
so that you do not have to copy the key
every time you log in if you have used
puri anytime if you want to log into an
ec2 instance you will have to put the ip
and the port number along with that you
will have to map or we will have to map
the key in the puri and this has to be
done every time that's what we would
have done in our lab environments right
but in production environment using the
same key or mapping the same key again
and again every time it's actually an
hassle it's considered as a blocker so
you might want to cache it you might
want to permanently add it in your putty
session so you can immediately log in
and start using it so here in the place
where you would actually map the private
key there's a quick button that actually
fixes or that actually binds your ssh to
your putty instance so we can enable ssh
agent forwarding that will actually bind
our key to the ssh and next time when we
try to log in you don't have to always
go through mapping the key and trying to
log in all right this question what are
solaris and ax operating systems are
they available with aws that question
generally gets asked to test how
familiar are you with the
amis available how familiar are you with
ec2 how familiar are you with the ec2
hardwares available that basically test
that now the first question or the first
thought that comes to your mind is well
everything is available with aws i've
seen windows i've seen ubuntu i've seen
red hat i've seen amazon amis and if i
don't see my operating system there i
can always go to marketplace and try
them if i don't find a marketplace i can
always go to community and try them so a
lot of amis available that lot of
operating systems available i will be
able to find solaris and ax but that's
not the case solar s and ax are not
available with aws that's because
solaris uses a different i mean solaris
does not support the architecture does
not support public cloud currently the
same goes for ax as well and they run on
power cpu and not on intel and as of now
amazon does not provide power machines
this should not be confused with the hpc
which is a high performance computing
should not be confused with that now
these are different hardwares different
cpu itself that the cloud providers they
do not provide yet another question you
could get asked in organizations that
would want to automate their
infrastructure using amazon native
services would be how do you actually
recover an ec2 instance or auto recover
an ec2 instance when it fails
well we know that ec2 instances are
considered as immutable meaning
irreparable we don't spend time fixing
bugs in an os stuff like that you know
once an ec2 instance crashes like it
goes on a ospanic or there are various
reasons why it would fail so we don't
have to really worry about fixing it we
can always relaunch that instance and
that would fix it but what if it happens
at two o'clock in the night what if it
happens that during a weekend when
nobody's in office
looking or monitoring those instances so
you would want to automate that not only
on a weekend or during midnight but it's
general practice good to automate it so
you could face this question how do you
actually automate an ec2 instance once
it fails and the answer to that question
is using cloudwatch we can recover the
instance so as you see there is an alarm
threshold a set in cloudwatch and once
the threshold is met meaning if there is
an error if there is a failure if the
ec2 instance is not responding for a
certain while we can set an alarm and
once the alarm is met let's say the cpu
utilization stayed high for five minutes
all right it's not taking any new
connections or the instance is not
pinging for five minutes or in this case
it's two minutes it's not pinging so
it's not going to respond connection so
in those cases you would want to
automatically recover that ec2 instance
by rebooting the instance all right now
look at this the take this action
section under the action so there we
have a bunch of options like recover
this instance meaning reboot the
instance so that's how we would recover
the other two options are beyond the
scope of the question but still you can
go ahead and apply just like i'm going
to do it so the other option is stop the
instance that's very useful when you
want to stop instances that are having
low utilizations nobody's using the
system as of now you don't want them to
be running and wasting the cloud
expenditure so you can actually set an
alarm that stops the ec2 instance that's
having low utilization so somebody was
working in an instance and they left it
without or they forgot to shut down that
instance and it gets i mean they will
only use it again the next day morning
so in between there could be like 12
hours that the system is running idle
nobody's using it and you're paying for
it so you can identify such instances
and actually stop them when the cpu
utilization is low meaning nobody is
using it the other one is to terminate
let's say you want to give system to
somebody temporarily and you don't want
them to hand the system back to you all
right this is actually an idea in other
words this is actually the scenario so
you hand over a system to somebody and
when they're done they're done we can
actually terminate the system so you
could instruct the other person to
terminate the system when they're done
and they could forget then the instance
could be running forever or you can
monitor the system after the specified
time is over and you can terminate the
system or best part you can automate the
system termination so you assign a
system to somebody and then turn on this
cloud watch action to terminate the
instance when the cpu is low for like
two hours meaning they've already left
or cpu is low for 30 minutes meaning
they've already left stuff like that so
that's possible
and if you're getting hired for an
system side architect or even on the
sysop site you could face this question
what are the common and different types
of ami designs there are a lot of ami
designs the question is the common ones
and the difference between them so the
common ones are the full back a mice and
the other one is just enough os ami j e
os ami and the other one is hybrid type
amis so let's look at the difference
between them the full backed ami just
like the name says it's fully baked it's
uh ready to use ami and this is the
simplest ami to deploy can be a bit
expensive it can be a bit cumbersome
because you'll have to do a lot of work
beforehand you could use the air mics a
lot of planning a lot of thought process
will go into it and the ami is ready to
use right you hand over the ami to
somebody and it's ready to use or if you
want to reuse the ami it's already ready
for you to use so that's full baked ami
the other one is just enough operating
system ami just like the name says
it has i mean as you can also see in the
diagram or in the picture it covers a
part of the os all bootstraps are
already packed properly and the security
monitoring logging and the other stuff
are configured at the time of deployment
or at the time you would be using it so
not much thought process will go in here
the only focus is on choosing the
operating system and what goes the
operating system specific agents or
bootstraps that goes into the operating
system that's all we worry about the
advantage of this is it's flexible
meaning you can choose to install
additional softwares at the time of
deploying but that's going to require an
additional expertise on the person who
will be using the ami so that's another
overhead there but the advantage is that
it's kind of flexible i can change the
configurations during the time of
deployment
the other one is the hybrid ami now the
hybrid ami actually falls in between the
fully baked ami and just enough
operating system options so these amis
have some features of the big type and
some features of the just enough os type
so as you see the security monitoring
logging are packed in that ami and the
runtime environments are installed
during the time of a deployment so this
is where the strict company policies
would go into the ami company policies
like you got to lock this you gotta
monitor this these are the ports that
generally gets open in all the systems
stuff like that so they strictly go into
the ami and sits in an ami format and
during deployment you have the
flexibility of choosing the different
runtime and the application that sits in
an ec2 instance another very famous
question you would face in an interview
is how can you recover login to an ec2
instance to which you lost the key well
we know that if the key is lost we can't
recover it there are some organizations
that integrate their ec2 instances with
an 80 that's different all right so you
can go and reset the password in the ad
and you will be able to log into the new
password but here the specific tricky
question is you are using a key to log
in and how do you recover if you have
lost the key generally companies would
have made a backup of the key so we can
pick from the backup but here the
specific question is we have lost the
key literally no backups on the key at
all so how can we log in and we know
that we can't log into the instance
without the key present with us so the
steps to recover is that make the
instance use another key and use that
key to log in once the key is lost it's
lost forever we won't be able to recover
it you can't raise the ticket with
amazon not possible they're not going to
help it's beyond the scope so make the
instance use another key it's only the
key that's the problem you still have
valid data in it you got to recover the
data it's just the key that's having the
problem so we can actually focus on the
key part alone and change the key and
that will allow us to log in so how do
we do it step by step procedure so first
verify the ec2 config service is running
in that instance uh if you want you can
actually beforehand install the easy to
config in that service or you can
actually make the easy to config run
through the console just a couple of
button clicks and that will make the
easy to configure run in that ec2
instance and then detach the root volume
for that instance of course it's going
to require a stop and start to detach
the root volume from the instance attach
the root volume to another instance as a
temporary volume or it could be a
temporary instance that you've launched
only to fix this issue and then login to
that instance and to that particular
volume and modify the configuration file
configuration file modify it to use the
new key and then move the root volume
back to its original position and
restart the instance and now the
instance is going to have the new key
and you also have the new key with which
you can log in so that's how we go ahead
and fix it now let's move on to some
product specific or s3 product specific
questions a general perception is s3 and
ebs can be used interchangeably and the
interviewer would want to test your
knowledge on s3 and evs well ebs uses s3
that's true but they can't be
interchangeably used so you might face
this question what are some key
differences between aws s3 and ebs well
the differences are s3 is an object
store meaning you can't install anything
in it you can store drive files but you
can't actually install in it it's not a
file system but ebs is a file system you
can install services i mean install
applications in it and that's going to
run stuff like that and talking about
performance s3 is much faster and ebs is
super faster when accessing from the
instance because from the instance if
you need to access s3 you'll actually
have to go out through the internet and
access the s3 or s3 is an external
server it's a very external service
you'll have to go through or you'll have
to go outside of your vpc to access s3
s3 does not come under a vpc but ebs
comes under a vpc it's on the same vpc
so you would be able to use it kind of
locally compared to s3 ebs is very local
so that way it's going to be faster and
redundancy talking about redundancy of
s3 and ebs s3 is
replicated the data in s3 is replicated
across the data centers but ebs is
replicated within the data center
meaning s3 is replicated across
availability zones ebs is within an
availability zone so that way the
redundancy is a bit less in ebs in other
words redundancy is higher in s3 than
eps and talking about security of s3 is3
can be made private as well as public
meaning anybody can access s3 from
anywhere in the internet that's possible
with s3 but ebs can only only be
accessed when attached to an ec2
instance right just one instance can
access it whereas s3 is publicly
directly accessible the other question
related to s3 security is how do you
allow access to a user to assert in a
user to a certain bucket which means
this user is not having access to s3 at
all but this user needs to be given
access to a certain bucket how do we do
it the same case applies to servers as
well in few cases there could be an
instance where a person is new to the
team and you actually don't want them to
access the production service now he is
in the production group and by default
he or she is granted access to that
server but you specifically want to deny
access to that production server till
the time he or she is matured enough to
access or understand the process
understand the do's and don'ts before
they can put their hands on the
production server so how do we go about
doing it so first we would categorize
our instances well these are critical
instances these are normal instances and
we were actually uh put a tag on them
that's how we categorize right so you
put a tag on them put a tag saying well
they are highly critical they are medium
critical and they are not critical at
all still there in production stuff like
that and then you would pick the users
who wants to or who should be or should
not be given access to a certain server
and you would actually allow the user to
access or not access servers based on a
specific tag in other words you can use
actually tags in in the previous step we
put tags on the critical server right so
you would define that this user is not
going to use this tag all right this
user is not allowed to use the resources
with this stack so that's how you would
make your step forward so you would
allow or deny based on the tags that you
have put so in this case he or she will
not be allowed to servers which are
tagged critical servers so that's how
you allow deny access to them and the
same goes for bucket as well
if an organization is excessively using
s3 for their data storage because of the
benefit that it provides the cost and
the
durability you might get asked this
question which is organizations would
replicate the data from one region to
another region for additional data
durability and for having data
redundancy not only for that they would
also do that for dr purposes for
disaster recovery if the whole region is
down you still have the data available
somewhere else and you can pick and use
it some organizations would store data
in different regions for compliance
reasons to provide low latency access to
their users who are local to that region
stuff like that so when companies do
replication how do you make sure that
there is consistency in the replication
how do you make sure that the
replication is not failing and the data
gets transferred for sure and there are
logs for that replication this is
something that the companies would use
where they're excessively using s3 and
they're fully relying on the replication
in running their business and the way we
could do it is we can set up a
replication monitor it's actually a set
of tools that we could use together to
make sure that the cloud replication a
region level replication is happening
properly so this is how it happens now
on this side on the left hand side we
have the region one and on the right
hand side we have region two and region
one is the source bucket and region two
is the destination bucket all right so
object is put in the source bucket and
it has to go directly to the region to
bucket or or made a copy in the region
to bucket and the problem is sometimes
it fails and there is no consistency
between them so the way you would do it
is connect these services together and
create and cross replication or cross
region replication monitor that actually
monitors that actually monitors your
environment so there are cloud watch
that make sure that the data is
moved no data is failing again there's
cloud watch on the other end make sure
that the data is moving and then we have
the logs generated through cloudtrail
and that's actually written in dynamodb
and if there is an error if something is
failing you get notified through an sms
or you get notified through an email
using the sns service so that's how we
could leverage these tools and set up
and cross region replication monitor
that actually monitors your data
replication
some common issues that company
companies face in vpc is that we all
know that i can use route 53 to resolve
an ip address externally from the
internet but by default the servers
won't connect to the other servers using
our custom dns name that does not do
that by default so it's actually a
problem there are some additional things
that as an administrator or as an
architect or as a person who uses it you
will have to do and that's what we're
going to discuss so the question could
be a vpc is not resolving the server
through the dns you can access it
through the ip but not through the dns
name and what could be the issue and how
do you go about fixing it and you will
be able to answer this question only if
you have done it already it's a quick
and simple step by default vpc does not
allow that's the default feature and we
will have to enable the dns hostname
resolution before
now this is for the custom dns not for
the default dns that comes along this is
for the custom dns so we will have to
enable the dns host name resolution so
our will have to enable dns hostname
resolution so they actually resolve
let's say i want to connect to a
server1.simplylearn.com
by default it's not allowed but if i
enable this option then i will be able
to connect to server one simplylearn.com
if a company has vpcs in different
regions and they have a head office in a
central place and the rest of them are
branch offices and they are connecting
to the head office for access or you
know for saving data or for accessing
certain files or certain data or storing
data all right so they would actually
mimic the hub and spoke topology where
you have the vpc which is centrally in
an accessible region a centrally
accessible region and then you would
have a local vpcs or branch offices in
different other regions and they get
connected to the vpc in the central
location and the question is how do you
actually connect the multiple sites to a
vpc and make communication happen
between them by default it does not do
that we know that vpcs they need to be
paired between them in order to access
the resources let's look at this picture
right so i have like a customer network
or branch offices in different parts and
they get connected to a vpc that's fine
so what we have achieved is those
different offices
the remote offices they are connecting
to the vpc and they're talking but they
can't connect or they can't talk to each
other that's what we have built but the
requirement is the traffic
needs to or they should be able to talk
to each other but they should not have
direct connection between them which
means that they will have to come and
hit the vpc and then
reach the other customer network which
is in los angeles or which is in new
york all right that's the requirement so
that's possible with some architecting
in the cloud so that's using vpn cloud
hub you look at this dotted lines which
actually allows customers or which
actually allows the
corporate networks to talk to each other
through the vpc again by default it
doesn't happen cloud hub is an
architecture that we should be using to
make this happen and what's the
advantage of it as a central office or
as the headquarters office which is in
the vpc or headquarters data center
which is in the vpc you have control or
the vpz has control on who talks to who
and what traffic can talk to i mean what
traffic can be routed to the other head
office stuff like that that centralized
control is on the vpc the other question
you could get asked is never explain
some security products and features
available in vpc well vpc itself is an
security service it provides security
service to the application but how do
you actually secure the vpc itself
that's the question and yes
there are products that can actually
secure the vpc or the vpc delivers those
products to secure the application
access to the vpc is restricted through
a network access control list all right
so that's and security product in vpc
and a vpc has security groups that
protects the instances from unwanted
inbound and outbound traffic and network
access control list protects the subnets
from unwanted inbound and outbound
access and there are flow logs we can
capture in vpc
that captures incoming and outgoing
traffic through a vpc which will be used
for later analysis as in what's the
traffic pattern what's the behavior of
the traffic pattern and stuff like that
so there are some security products and
features available in vpc now how do you
monitor vpc vpc is a very important
concept very important service as well
everything sits in a vpc most of the
service sits in a vpc
except for lambda and s3 and dynamodb
and couple of other services most of
them sit in a vpc for security reason so
how do you monitor your vpc how do you
gain some visibility on your vpc well we
can gain visibility on your vpc using
vpc flow log that's the basic service as
you see it actually captures what's
allowed what's not allowed stuff like
that which ip's allowed which ib is not
allowed stuff like that so we can gather
it and we can use that for analysis and
the other one is cloud watch and cloud
watch logs the data transfers that
happen so this is you know who gets
allowed and who does not get allowed i
mean the flow logs is who is allowed and
who's not allowed that kind of detail
and cloud watch gives information about
the data transfer how much data is
getting transferred we can actually pick
unusual data transfers if there is a
certain hike in the graph there's a
sudden hike and something happens at 12
on a regular basis and you weren't
expecting it there's something
suspicious it could be valid backups it
could be a malicious activity as well so
that's how you know by looking at
cloudwatch logs and cloudwatch dashboard
now let's talk about multiple choice
questions when going for an interview
you might sometimes find yourself that
the company is conducting an online test
based on the score they can put you to a
panelist and then they would take it
forward so we thought it will also
include multiple choice questions to
help you better handle such situation if
you come across all right when you find
yourself in such situation the key to
clear them is to understand the question
properly read between the lines that's
what they say you know there can be like
a big paragraph with three lines or ten
lines you really got to understand what
the question is about and then try to
find answer for that question so that's
a thumb rule number one and then the
second rule is try to compare and
contrast the services
mentioned or try to compare and contrast
the answers you can easily read out one
or two answers and then you will be left
with only two answers to decide from you
know so that also helps you with time
and that's all that also helps you with
some precision in your answer so number
one read between the lines number two
compare and contrast the services and
you'll be able to easily weed out the
wrong ones so let's try answering this
question suppose you are a game designer
and you want to develop a game with a
single digit millisecond latency which
of the following database services would
you choose so we know that the following
are database services good enough all
right and it talks about millisecond
latency that's a key point and the third
thing is it's a game could be a mobile
game it's a game that you are trying to
design and you need
millisecond latency and it has to be a
database all right so let's talk about
the options available rds rds is a
database for sure is it good for a game
design we'll come back to that neptune
neptune is a graph a database service in
amazon so that's kind of out of the
equation and snowball is actually a
storage right it's it's a transport
medium i would say so that's again out
of the equation so the tie is between
rds and dynamodb if we need to talk
about rds rds is an a platform as a
service it provides cost efficient
resizable capacity but it's an sql
database meaning the tables are kind of
strict you know it's good for banking
and other type of applications but not
really good for anything that has to do
with
gaming so the only option left is
dynamodb again it's the right answer
dynamodb is actually an fast and
flexible nosql database service and it
provides a single digit millisecond
latency at any scale and it's a database
at the same time it's a key value store
model database so the right answer is
dynamodb all right let's look at the
next question if you need to perform
real-time monitoring of aws services and
get actionable insights which service
would you use
all right let's list the services so it
talks about real-time monitoring a
firewall manager what does it provide
now firewall manager is not really a
monitor just like the name says it's a
manager it manages multiple firewalls
and aws guard duty is an threat
detection service it does monitoring it
does continuously monitor our
environment but it monitors for threats
all right only threats now let's talk
about cloudwatch a cloudwatch is a
service that
helps to track metrics it's a service
that is used to monitor the environment
and give us a system-wide visibility and
also it helps us to store logs so at the
moment it kind of looks like that could
be the right answer we don't know that
yet but i mean we have one more option
left that's ebs so what's ebs ebs is a
block storage elastic block store if we
abbreviate ebs it's elastic block store
so all three of them are easily out of
the question the first one is to manage
second one is to find threats
of course it does monitoring so there's
i mean if there is one relation between
cloud watch and guard duty that's
monitoring so easily we can actually
find ourselves slipped towards picking
god duty but know that god duty is only
for gaining security inside but not
about gaining aws service inside so
cloudwatch is a service that helps us to
get a system wide or an aws wide or an
account wide it has number of metrics we
can monitor and get a very good insight
of how a service is performing be it cpu
be it ram b network utilization beat
connection failures cloud watch is a
service that helps us perform a
real-time monitoring and get some
actionable insights on the services all
right let's talk about this 33rd
question as a web developer you are
developing an app especially for the
mobile platform all right there is a
mention that this is especially for the
mobile platform so a lot of services
gets filtered out mobile platform right
which of the following lets you add user
sign up sign in and access control to
your web and mobile app quickly and
easily all right so this is all about
signing in to your mobile app so if we
need to read between the lines that's
how we can read sign up or sign in into
an mobile platform all right so we have
like four options here shield aws massey
aws inspector amazon cognito so let's
try to weed out services which are not
relevant to it so what's aws shield aws
shield is actually a service that
provides a ddos mitigation or ddos
protection denial of service protection
it's a security feature let's talk about
the second option aws maxi is again a
security service that uses machine
learning to automatically discover and
classify the data it again talks about
security and this security is all about
encrypting or saving the data does not
come close with signing up and mobile
platform all right let's talk about the
other one aws inspector now aws
inspector has something to do with apps
it definitely has something to do with
apps so kind of looks like that's
relevant as of now so it actually helps
with
improving the security and compliance of
the apps that we deploy in the cloud so
kind of looks like it could be because
it has to do with apps the last one
cognito now cognito is a service that
actually lets the administrator to have
control access over web and mobile apps
and it's a service that helps us to sign
up and
sign in to an mobile and web app so that
very much looks like we found the answer
so cognito is a service that helps web
app and mobile app for sign up and
signing in and also gives the
administrator to have control over who
has i mean access control over the web
and the mobile app pretty much we found
it so it's cognitive cognito is a
service that helps us to set up sign up
sign in and have access control over the
users who would be using our mobile and
web app all right how about this
question uh you are an ml engineer or a
machine learning engineer who is on the
lookout for a solution that will
discover sensitive information that your
enterprise stores in aws and then uses
nlp to classify that data and provide
business related insights which among
the following services would you choose
so we have a bunch of services that's
going to help us achieve or one of it is
going to help us achieve the about
requirement so it's a service that deals
with machine learning you're a machine
learning engineer who's looking for a
service that
will help you to discover information at
your enterprise store so we're talking
about storage discover information in
store and then classify
the data depending on severity the
sensitivity classify the data so which
service is that so firewall manager just
like the name says it's a manager and
the aws iam
if we abbreviate it it's a identity and
access management so it's identity and
access management nothing to do with
identifying sensitive data and managing
it so the first two is already out of
the equation then the aw is messy we
already had a quick
definition description for aws massey
that it's actually a security service
that uses machine learning it kind of
looks like it could be it it's a
security service that uses machine
learning and it discovers and classifies
the sensitive information not only that
it does not stop there it goes beyond
and protects the sensitive data aws
massey kind of looks like but we still
have one more option to look at which is
cloud hms cloud hms is also a security
service kind of looks like that could be
the answer as well and it enables us to
generate encryption keys and save the
data so kind of fifty percent of it it's
a security service it encrypts helps us
protect the data but aws maxi is right
on spot it's a machine learning service
it helps us to classify the data and
also to protect the data so the answer
for this question would be aws messy so
hope you kind of get it how this is
going so first we apply the thumb rule
identify the question that's being asked
read between the lines and then try to
find the service that meets your
requirement then finding the service is
by first weeding out the wrong ones
recollect everything that you've learned
about the service and see how well that
matches with those hints that you have
picked up and if that doesn't match weed
that out then you'll end up with two
just two to decide from at some point
and then it becomes easy for you to
decide click on the question submit it
and then move on to the other question
in your interview all right so how about
this one uh you are a system
administrator in your company which is
running most of its infrastructure on
aws you are required to
track your users and keep a look on how
your users are being authenticated all
right so this is where the problem
statement starts right you need to keep
track of how your users are being
authenticated and you wish to create and
manage aws users and use permissions to
allow and deny their access to the aws
resources right so you are to give them
permission number one and then i mean if
we put them in the right order first
giving them permissions and then
tracking their usage let's see which of
the service will help us achieve it iam
is a service that
helps us to
looking at the permissions we can
actually predict whether the user or the
group will have servers or not so that
helps us to get a track of who is able
to use who's not able to use certain
servers and all that stuff so it kind of
looks like but we have other three
options left let's look at aws firewall
manager just like the name says it's
actually a firewall manager it helps us
to manage multiple firewalls simple as
that and shield is a service it's a
service that's used to protect denial of
service or distributed denial of service
an api gateway is a service that makes
it easy for developers to create publish
maintain and monitor and secure api so i
mean it's completely on the api side
very less on user and how you
authenticate your user we can get that
by looking at the name itself right if
you abbreviate it or if you if you try
to find a definition for the name api
gateway you would get it it has to do
with api but if you aggregate aws iam
its identity and access management
pretty much meets the requirement for
the problem statement about its aws
identity and access management that's
the right answer all right let's look at
this one if you want to allocate various
private and public ip address in order
to make them communicate
with the internet and other instances
you will use this service which of the
following is this service so it talks
about using public and private ip
address so this service uses ip address
and then this service helps us to
allow and deny connections to the
internet and to the other instances so
you get the question is it let's pick
the service that helps us achieve it
route 53 route 53 is actually a dns
service right so it's not a service
that's used to allow or deny no it does
not do that vpc vpc uses public and
private ip address yes so kind of looks
like a vpc helps us uh to allow i mean
the security and vpc the security group
the network access control list in a vpc
that outing table in a vpc that actually
helps us to allow or deny a connection
to a particular ip address or to a
particular service within the vpc or
outside of the vpc so as of now it kind
of looks like it could be but let's look
at the other services what if if we find
a service that closely matches to the
upper requirement than the amazon vpc
gateway api gateway we know that it's a
managed service that makes it easy for
developers to create publish maintain
and monitor apis and secure api so that
has completely do with api not with ib
cloudfront we know about cloudfront that
it's a content delivery network and it
provides global distribution of
servers where our content can be cached
it could be video or bulk media or
anything else they can be cached locally
so users can easily access them and
download them easily right so that's
cloud front now at this point after
looking at all four it looks like vpc is
the right answer and in fact vpc is the
right answer vpc has public ip address
vpc can help us with a private ip
address vpc can be used to allow deny
connection based on the security group
access control list and the routing
table it has so that's right answer is
vpc all right how about this one this
platform as a service or platform as a
db service provides us with a cost
efficient and resizable capacity while
automating time consuming administrative
tasks so this question is very clear
it's a db service we got to look for and
it's a service that can provide
automating some of the time consuming
task it has to be resizable at the same
time so let's talk about amazon rational
database it's a database
kind of matches the requirement we can
resize it as and when needed
all right looks like it's a fit as of
now it actually automates some of the
time consuming work looks like it's a
fit as of now let's move on to elastic
cache and then try to see if uh that
matches the definition that
we've figured out about elastic cache
it's actually a caching service it's
again an in-memory data store which
helps in achieving high throughput and
low latency in memory data stores so
it's not a full-blown database and it
does not come with
any amazon provisioned automation in it
for automating any of the administration
tasks no it does not come up with
anything like that yeah we can resize
the capacity as and when needed but
automation
it's not there yet and moreover it's not
a database so that's out of the equation
vpc is
not a recessible one you know once we
have designed vpc it's fixed it can't be
resized so that's out of the equation
and uh amazon glacier glacier is a
storage but not a database right so
that's again of the equation so that tie
is kind of between amazon rational
database service and amazon elastic
cache because they both aid the database
service but elastic cache is not a
full-blown database it actually helps
the database but it's not a full-blown
database so it's amazon relational
database that's the one which is a
platform as a service it's the one which
can be resized it's the one which
can be used to automate the uh time
consuming administrative tasks all right
let's talk about this one which of the
following is a means for accessing human
researchers or consultants to help solve
a problem on a contractual or a
temporary basis all right let's read the
question again which of the following is
a means for accessing human researchers
or consultant to help solve problems on
a contractual or a temporary basis it's
like a signing task or hiring aws
experts for a temporary job so let's try
to find that kind of service in the four
services that are listed amazon elastic
mapreduce mapreduce is actually an
framework service that makes it easy and
cost effective to analyze large amount
of data but that has
nothing to do with accessing human
researchers all right let's talk about
mechanical term it's a web service that
provides a
human workforce that's the definition
for it for example automation is good
but not everything can be automated for
something to qualify for automation it
has to be an repetitive task one time
task can't be automated or the time and
money that you would be spending in
automation is not worth it instead you
could have done it manually so that does
not qualify for automation and anything
that requires intelligence right
anything that's a special case right
automation can do repetitive tasks
automation can do precise work but it
has to be repeated task the scenario you
know it should have been there already
only then that can be executed but if
it's a new scenario and it requires uh
appropriate addressing then it requires
human thought so we could hire
researchers and consultants who can help
solve a problem using amazon mechanical
turk the other two are already out of
the equation now devpay is actually a
payment system through amazon and
multi-factor authentication as it says
it's an authentication system so the
right answer is amazon mechanical turk
alright this sounds interesting let's
look at this one this service is used to
make it easy to deploy manage and scale
containerized applications using
kubernetes on aws which of the following
is this aws service so it's a service to
deploy manage and scale containerized
applications so it deals with containers
it also should have the ability to use
kubernetes which is and container
orchestration service all right the
first one amazon elastic container
service kind of looks like it's the one
the name itself has the word and the
relation we're looking for elastic
container service so this container
service is an highly scalable high
performance container orchestration
service let's look at the other one aws
batch it's a service that enables id
professionals to schedule and execute
batch processing i mean the name itself
says that that's meant for batch
processing elastic bean stock that's
another service that helps us to deploy
manage and scale but it helps us with
easy two instances
not with containerized uh instances so
that's again out of the equation would
light scale be a good tie for elastic
container service what's light sale now
lightsail is a service it's called as a
virtual private server without a vpc
it's called as a virtual private
server it comes with a predefined
compute storage networking capacity it's
actually a server not a container right
so at this point that also becomes out
of the equation so it's amazon elastic
container service that's the one that
helps us to easily deploy manage scale
container services and it helps us
orchestrate the containers using
kubernetes all right how about this one
all right this service lets us to run
code without provisioning or managing
servers so no servers run code select
the correct service from the below
option all right so no servers but we
should be able to run code amazon easy
to order scaling easy to auto scaling
ec2 is elastic compute cloud which is a
server and auto scaling is a service
that helps us to achieve scaling the
server so that's the definition for it
could be that's out of the equation aw
is lambda now lambda is a service it's
actually an event driven serverless
computing platform and lambda runs code
in response to the event that it
receives and it automatically manages
the compute resource that's required for
that code as long as we have uploaded a
code that's correct and set up events
correctly to map to that code it's going
to run seamlessly so that's about lambda
it kind of looks like it could be the
answer because lambda runs code we don't
have to manage servers it manages
service by itself but we can't conclude
as of now we have other two servers to
talk about aws batch all right batches
service that
enables id professionals to run batch
job we know that and about inspector
amazon inspector it's actually a service
that helps us to increase and identify
any security issues and align our
application with compliance well that's
not the requirement of the question the
requirement in the question was run code
without provisioning your server and
without any more space for confusion aws
lambda is a service or is the service
that runs code without provisioning and
managing services right the right one
would be aws lambda all right so by this
we have come to the end very glad that
we were able to help you with the
interview preparation for your new job
and we were able to help you with the
different approaches that the companies
follow and train you on those areas and
get you prepared for the interview thank
you we'll meet again in another similar
section like this till then bye for now
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here